Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> Hey,
[music]
heat. Hey.
Heat.
>> [music]
>> Bear Bryant here at RQ Hartford and I
want to talk about something I'm very
excited for. Here are some items here in
a display case that we can have that you
can claim at RQ Hartford which includes
these beautiful, beautiful runes on the
prize wall. But the biggest hot
commodity here are these plated legends.
Now, these plated legends have been
available at all of these regional
qualifiers, but the biggest thing we
have to talk about are the Origins ones.
Yes, this is the last event where you
can claim these Origins plated legends
here, but that doesn't mean you can't
still get your hands on them. You can,
if you're here in the hall, you can get
your 40 tickets and go straight to the
prize wall. And even though these ones
may disappear in the future, we have the
Vendetta ones to look forward to. So,
make sure you get out in the hall, play
in those side events, and get those
tickets straight to the prize wall.
>> [music]
>> Charmer reporting live from regional
qualifier Hartford here in Connecticut
and I'm going to talk to you about a
list that might be growing in popularity
after the result of the Utrect qualifier
and that is none other than Victor.
Victor is a legend that has been very
popular since the game was released, but
it's incredibly popular because the text
on this legend allows you to create
recruit tokens. It's the only legend in
the game that allows you to make a unit
without having to spend a card. It's
going to allow you to go very wide with
your strategies. That means you're going
to have units that are in a number of
much larger than your opponents. You're
going to overwhelm them. You're going to
swarm them. But if you need to get rid
of some opposing units along the way,
you can use cards like Call the Weak.
This is an order staple. It's kind of
the reason to be playing the domain much
of the time. This allows you to give up
something small on your end like a
recruit token and then take out
something much larger on their side. It
could be a key card like an Ireelia or a
Kha'Zix or even an Elder Dragon. But if
they have more than one unit and the
call the week's not going to get the job
done, we have another staple in these
victors lists. Uh that is Imperial
Decree. This makes it so that any unit
when it takes damage on the turn, it
dies. So that could be damage from one
of these recruit tokens as you're
mosying them in one by one into combat
or it could be through other cards like
Bellow's Breath. So that is a combo
you're going to want to keep an eye out
for whether you're here in Hartford or
you're playing against this deck at your
locals. So yeah, this is the Victor
list. Be prepared.
Josh Schneider here at the Hartford
Regional and I have a very special guest
for you. I've got Sam D. Sherman,
regional qualifier champion and runner
up. And in my opinion, as excellent as
that regional qualifier championship
was, that runner up with Rengar, man,
that had the whole community buzzing,
but it's so good to have you here. How
are you feeling coming into this
weekend?
>> Yeah. Uh, my prep didn't really go that
well, uh, I would say, but, uh, you
know, I'm I'm I'm here. I'm ready to
compete and see what happens. Last time,
you know, I didn't really have high
hopes and it went very well. So,
>> very well indeed. Now, I've got a quick
question for you because there was some
talk and I actually saw you doing a
little bit of testing with Kha'Zix
throughout the last couple weeks and I I
received word on good faith that you
were playing Kha'Zix this weekend. So, I
kind of went out on a limb and I made a
hot take, bold prediction that Kha'Zix
was going to take down the Hartford
regional. Hasn't even made the top cut
yet. Yeah. But Sam D. Sherman's on it. I
have faith and I made that pick. So, is
that the case here?
>> Yeah, unfortunately, uh, you're right
that I was working on Kha'Zix and I may
have made some claims to the effect that
I would be playing it, but
>> uh ultimately I I did not finish getting
the Kha'Zix deck to where I needed it to
be to play it by the time I I ran out of
uh of prep time. So, yeah, I fell back
on my old uh Rengar.
>> Okay. All right. So, what you're telling
it telling me is my caster pick. It's uh
it's going to be interesting. We're
we're going to have we're going to have
to lean on somebody else this weekend
for Kha'Zix to bring it home.
>> Yeah, maybe somebody else cracked it. I
do think that that there's something
there with Kha'Zix, but I uh yeah, I
just I was not able to to figure it out
myself.
>> Okay. All right. Well, can you tell us
what you are playing this weekend?
>> Yeah, I'm playing the same exact Rangard
deck as as from Vancouver. I I
>> in my in my prep, I I knew that uh you
know, if if I didn't get there with
whatever nonsense I was cooking up, I
had the Rangard deck to fall back on.
>> Yeah. Um, now what's interesting about
the Ringgar is when you were runner up
with the Rengar, you had some very
interesting interviews where you pretty
much said in the interviews that it was
very interesting to get to that point in
the finals and you didn't really know
how good the deck was. So, tell us a
little bit about that. After hearing you
say those types of things, what leads
you back into Ringar?
>> Uh, well, it's kind of the same
situation. like I I don't I don't want
to play one of these top uh meta decks
and compete with 200 people for a best
of. So, um yeah, I feel comfortable with
Rengar. It's a lot of fun to play and uh
it's a very hard deck to to play and you
know, I think as long as I'm able to
execute, I'll I'll have a you know, an
edge on the most of the other Rengar
competitors if I if I play a little
better.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Well, you performed
outstanding in Vancouver. you're running
it back here this weekend in Hartford
with Rengar. So, my question now is are
there any specific matchups that you're
really looking to dodge this weekend?
>> Um, I've been asked this question a lot
of times and I usually I answer the the
Hook Leblanc deck, but I I played
against that twice already and I I won
four very comfortable games. Um, so I I
think maybe I should stop saying that
one.
>> Uh, but yeah, I don't really want to
face Aurora. Um, don't love that
matchup, but I I also, you know, beat
that a bunch of times in Vancouver, so
uh yeah, who knows? Maybe maybe nothing
can really take down the Rengar. I did
lose already today, though.
>> Okay. All right. Well, we're getting
that loss out of the way now
>> and we're going to hit the ground
running tomorrow. Now, another question
for you is Rengar, of course, you're
going to be looking for that best of
again, but do you believe that right now
after what we saw last weekend and you
treked, do you believe that Rengar has
the chance to go deep once again?
>> I mean, of course it has a chance. I I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's in like the
top
I don't know eight or 10 decks to to to
have a a good chance, but you know,
anything that's a playable functional
deck can can really uh go far in one of
these tournaments.
>> Okay. Well, we believe we believe Sam.
Now, there's a lot of people out there
that look at you as one of the best
players in the game. Again, you've made
the finals in two regional qualifiers.
You are a regional qualifier champion.
Is there anything that you could kind of
tell the people at home? Just give them
a little bit of advice, some things that
they could start working on to try and
get to this type of level. Um,
it's hard to say uh something so
specific when everybody's got different
problems probably, but I think the one
thing that probably will hit for the
most people is um
when you lose a game of Riftbound,
figure out why. What did you do wrong?
Like you you didn't lose the game
because you drew bad and you're unlucky.
Like that's that's just not how
Riftbound is structured. almost every
game of Riftbound, there was some way
you could have played better. Um, maybe
you played around the wrong card or
maybe you distributed your might in a
way that was uh not inconvenient enough
for your opponent or or whatever it
might be. Maybe recycle too many runes
early. Like there I mean there's a
million different ways you can lose a
game of Riftbound, but try to figure out
which one it was and uh you know make a
mental note to to not do it next time.
>> Yeah. No, well that's great advice. We
certainly appreciate that. Now again, in
in my opinion, one of the biggest feats
that we've seen so far was Ringar in the
finals, and you were one game away from
doing it. You're running it back in
Hartford. So, tomorrow, let's start that
run again. Let's get all the way there
once again. Maybe you've got another
shot this weekend. I want to see Rengar
on top. Even if my caster prediction
falls apart, I think it'd be great to
see you accomplish that this time
around.
>> Yeah, and my understanding is it would
be very flavorful for Rengar to topple
your Kha'Zix prediction. Yes, that is
absolutely right. Well, Sam, thank you
so much for your time. We really
appreciate it. Best of luck this
weekend. We hope to see you have another
great run here at Hartford.
>> Thank you.
>> We'll send it back to you.
>> We are live from the Hartford Regional.
I'm Josh Schneider. We talked to Sam D.
Sherman a little earlier, but now we've
got another special guest. Would you
like to introduce yourself?
>> Hello. Uh, I'm H Fang. Uh, I lead the
team on Aspons Climb. Okay, so Aspirants
Climb is the team that Sam D. Sherman is
a part of, and of course we're all
familiar with the success that Sam has
had, but if you guys could just tell me
how did this team form?
>> Yeah. Um, so, uh, a group of us used to
play, uh, different card games together.
Uh, and then so when Riff Riffbon first
came out, we, uh, were like, let's let's
try it. Let's work together and try to
do well at this at this tournament, the
first tournament in Houston. Uh, and
then so ever since then, uh, we've kind
of stuck together. We've added a lot of
new people, uh, just from our local game
stores and, you know, people we've
played against at tournaments. Uh, and
then that's where we are now.
>> Okay, that's great. Well, you guys are
having some good success. And I'm
curious in a big tournament like this,
we come to a regional, how do you guys
as a team support one another through
events like this?
>> Uh, I think that probably the biggest
thing is that we practice together. We
have like a discord um where we uh you
know gather for weeks before the
tournament and we play practice matches
and we talk about you know different
decks that we're working on and and
what's working and what's not and and um
so that that helps us get to a good
place with our uh our decks. And then
also like just being able to play the
game with friends that that you like uh
makes it a lot more fun. And uh you know
if the game is fun it's a lot easier to
to you know keep playing it.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. Anything you wanted to
add on that, HF Bang?
>> Uh, no. He summed it up pretty good.
>> All right, there you go. Now, we talked
a little bit about Sam and you've had
success winning the regional qualifier
in Vegas, runner up in Vancouver, but
has there been some other members on the
team that have had some really good
success as well? We'd love to hear about
them.
>> Yeah, I mean, we had a Jinx best up in
in Atlanta. We had a Lucian best of, and
a lot of us are qualified for the
regional coming up. Um, but yeah, that's
that's that's the team.
>> Yeah. Well, that's great. So, best
ofves, winning a regional championship,
runner up. So, you guys are really
starting to get your footing in the game
of Riftbound. Now, looking forward,
what are the goals?
>> Yeah, I think uh the the main goal is to
do well at regionals. We're all
qualifying for regionals here and so uh
the the goal is to to win that one.
>> Okay. Yeah. Sam, did you anything you
want to add on that?
>> Yeah. Uh,
you know, we we want to keep winning.
Uh, you know, piling up the best of is
kind of where I'm at right now. Um, but
yeah, you know, just the more uh people
we put in the top 64 of these things,
the better because then we'll have a a
uh, you know, bigger squad for the
regional.
>> Yeah. No, that's that's excellent. Now,
Aspirants Climb, where can people find
you guys?
>> Yeah. Uh you can find us uh on all
platforms as Asp as aspirins climb. Um
so we have guides, we have YouTube
videos. So uh find us there.
>> Awesome. Awesome.
>> Isn't it Aspirants Climb RB?
>> Aspirants Climb RB on some of the
platforms. Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. Aspirants Climb RB. Now one
last question and I'm just curious where
did the team name come from? Aspirants
Climb. Like what was the what was the
reasoning behind the Aspirants Climb? Uh
uh so a few of us didn't uh didn't get
tickets for Vegas when uh Sam won and uh
when he was in top eight we were like oh
crap like we need to come up with a team
name on the fly um so that you know Sam
can talk about it and so we kind of had
a discussion about what we wanted to do
and our deal ideals as a team and the
card aspirin climb is a is a really good
inspiration of us trying to climb to the
top. Uh we're aspirational climbers and
so that's how how it came to be.
>> Okay. No, that's awesome. Well, we
certainly appreciate you guys taking the
time to do this interview and sharing
with the community about Aspirants Climb
and hey, best of luck to the whole team
this weekend here in Hartford.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> All right, we're going to send it back.
>> Things are starting to heat up here in
Hartford. We are halfway through day one
of Swiss. Four rounds complete. We've
got four more to go. I'm Josh Snder
joined by Charmer. And as we get set for
this second half, I think we have some
interesting possibilities of what we
could see on stream this round. But
we've seen a lot of exciting stuff
already.
>> Yeah, we've seen some very exciting
decks play out. I was very, very excited
to see personally the Poppy Dazzling
Aurora list. I know that many folks uh
they hear dazzling Aurora and perhaps
they have the mental eye roll or even
they audibly groan a little bit. But not
me, not when it's Poppy, not when it's
just big dudes and big ruinations.
However, we also have some exciting
possibilities lining up here for round
five because as you know, the viewers
are going to get to vote on which one we
see. And I think both are interesting
options for sure.
>> How could you not love that? the viewers
get to vote. We've got some interesting
ones. We've got Draven, which we haven't
seen a lot of, right, in this current
meta. And then you've got Azir and then
we could do Teemo or Lilia. So quite
interesting picks. And Cactus King, it
is worth noting, is in a full suit if
that matters in your vote.
>> Yes. If you are watching at home and you
want to see somebody in a full suit,
play the game. James time versus Cactus
King. Cactus King is adorned in a
massive suit. However, it is looking
like people might be leaning towards
seeing Batsmach take on Milo. And that
would also be, I think, a very
interesting matchup because one, uh, I'm
a huge Teemo [music] enjoyer. Nothing
makes me happier than hidden
shenanigans. But also specifically, I
think Lilia is [music] an under uh
respected is the way I'll word it,
legend. And it does look like that's the
one that is going to win. That's what
we're going to go with. So, we're going
to see Milo on Lilia taking on Botme.
Now, the reason that I think Lilia is
perhaps not respected is because of the
presence of Vex Apathetic. [music] This
is a card that can shut down a lot of
what you're trying to do with the sprite
tokens. But we're going to have to see
if a Teemo is running it and b whether
or not all of the hidden cards are also
traps for the Lilia.
Okay, so we are going to take a look at
this Teemo list and see what we have.
And I see that Vex right away. We do
have a copy of Vex, which is so good
against Lilia because all of those ready
sprite tokens are going to come in
stunned and they have temporary. That's
a big problem. And on top of that, even
if you wanted to try to do something
with the stunned versions of them, they
cannot move this turn either, uh,
because of the text on Vex Apathetic. As
you [music] noted, one copy in the main
deck, likely more in the sideboard. Uh,
another thing that I want to point out
again as a Teemo Enjoyer, is the
presence of three not turns. So, this is
what some people refer to as the casino
teemo, [music] where you're maximizing
the number of hidden cards you're
playing, and you're also hoping to get
triggers on knockturn [music] as well as
getting that Teemo strategist value.
That being said, this is also a deck
that is capable of getting on location
to play some of these hidden cards with
the presence of uh Sprites Call, Sprites
Fountain, etc. Yeah, absolutely. This
deck is also looking to take advantage
of some zetti sprite tokens. This is a
very aggressive Teemo deck. Even has the
sneaky deck hand as well. So definitely
wants to get on the battlefield as
quickly as possible. Get these hidden
cards in play and make it really
difficult for your opponent.
>> Yeah, you mentioned the sneaky deck
hand. That's one way to get a unit that
will uh stick on the battlefield and
that will allow you to play those hidden
cards. [music] But the other neat thing
is even if you open with something like
sprite fountain, when the sprite token
goes into the battlefield you conquer,
you can hide a card and then on the
following turn if [music] the card that
you hid is a unit, you can respond to
the temporary trigger and then still
[music] get your hold points. So if it's
something like a tie turner, like an
Evelyn, like either of [music] the
Teeos, like a Windser, as you can see, a
lot of these hidden cards are also
units, [music] so that will likely be
the strategy. fast starts and then a lot
of hidden shenanigans from the Teemo.
>> Absolutely. Looking forward to seeing
all the hidden strategies as we take a
look at Milo's deck list, this Lilia
Bashful Bloom, and we want to get early
aggression going with the sprites.
And one thing that really stands out
here, we talked about how bad Vex is for
this deck. The Riptide Rex is going to
be important to try and deal with that
Vex.
>> Absolutely. Riptide Rex does give you a
way to target the Vex apathetic. You
will still have to pay the deflect cost.
So ultimately, you'll be a recycling
three runes to get the job done, but
what you get for that investment is a
six might unit and you get rid of a unit
that will be giving you a lot of
problems as the Lilia player. Uh I think
another card worth highlighting in this
matchup is Mask of Foresight. Of course,
you see three copies of that being
played by Milo. This is something that's
going to give those individual sprite
tokens a lot more offense. So, uh, a lot
of matchups you might try to just make
things bigger than your standard sprite
token and then you don't have to worry
about them coming in. But stacking the
mask of foresight makes that far more
difficult.
>> Yeah, absolutely. These sprite tokens
definitely going to be real threats in
this matchup. But we are ready to get
down to the feature area and let's get
the show on the road. Teemo versus
Lilia. Two decks we've yet to see today.
>> Yeah,
>> that's Mac and Milo.
>> That's Mac going to be starting with
Star Tip Peak.
>> Milo starting with that seat of power.
>> I will say I also really like some of
the other [music] tech choices that Milo
has included in that Lilia list. I saw
the one of Brutalizer. Brutalizer gives
you [music] a lot of value with the
sprite tokens because they have
temporary. So once they go away, they
will uh make the brutalizer fall off and
you can always get that value for the I
equipped it this turn.
>> Uh it can really help you push over the
top.
>> All right, here we go. Game one
underway. Milo starting things out with
that Raven Bloom student.
>> Draw. You mentioned the star tipped peak
for batsmack. Of course, wants to get on
the battlefields.
>> Try and hold and get back some of that
power you invest.
>> I will play
>> by playing the hidden cards.
>> Evelyn and I will pass.
>> All right, so passmack is just
developing an Evelyn. No fast start
here. Would have liked to have seen
probably a sprites call. Uh the
fountain, anything that would have
allowed an immediate conquer, but that
was not the case. So just develops and
passes
>> come here and pass focus.
>> Now Milo trying to conquer that star
tipped peak with the student one
>> gets on the board
>> and Milo draws first points by getting
the Raven Bloom on the peak.
>> Tap two.
>> See what Milo does. Does develop the
mass
>> leaves two energy up. And looking at the
hand there, I saw a couple of uh solid
options. There was the discipline as
well as a defy. So depending on what
Batsmack tries to do,
>> could make that Raven Bloom jump up to
as much as five might with the
discipline.
>> Oh, strong play here coming back from
Batsmack with Wind Singer.
>> This would bounce that Raven Bloom
student back to Milo's hand
>> in response. Top two to discipline.
>> The discipline at reaction speed. Love
to see it. buffing it up
>> above three might which means the
Windser cannot return it to Milo's hands
>> in defense.
>> Yeah, Potsmach correctly identifying
asking with the uh clarification there
that it does defend at one more might as
well. So right now it's at a total of
five might but defends as a six and that
means that Bodmach will likely send
Evelyn to the seat of power. seems like
the safer course unless you had
something like a switcheroo in hand. But
>> does just go to the seat and get their
first point as well.
>> So things up. See if we can get some
hidden cards in play here. If we
want to try and stake claim of this seat
of power. Got
>> play Teemo. Mhm. And I'm going to hide a
card.
>> There we go. Teemo strategist coming out
from the chosen champ zone.
>> One card being hidden. awaking
>> and Milo will hold up to two.
>> That southern battlefield is going to be
interesting now with the strategist in
play.
>> Uh channel two.
>> Yep.
>> Milo because of the star tipped peakold
did get to channel a rune exhausted
>> as well as the two for the turn. Shout
out to the unleashed alt art runes for
being absolutely gorgeous. Can't seem to
take my eyes off how pretty those calm
runes are. I've been trying to find them
here at the event and they are MIA, but
I'm sure I will get some before the
weekend is over.
>> Let's see how Milo tries to go about
>> top
>> this particular turn. When did the
sprites come into play? We haven't seen
them
>> on Milo's side just yet. Another mask of
foresight.
>> So, when attacking or defending alone,
these units are going to be real
threats.
>> Ready sprite.
>> Yep.
>> And
>> and now that Sprite comes out. So
>> that is going to be five might into that
southern battlefield.
>> Uh yes, defense trigger is also
no reactions.
>> Great.
>> All right. So
>> properly identifying the order of the
triggers here.
>> Three kill.
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> if you're watching at home, those mask
triggers go on the chain, but the Teemo
strategist resolves first because three
hidden cards are revealed. that deals
three damage to the spray and thus it
dies before the mask of foresights gets
added as far as the might goes and that
is why that Teemo strategist can be so
effective at holding battlefields.
>> It's a tough spot. Milo really trying to
force something out there.
>> Teamo strategists just a free kill on
that sprite.
Now, the one positive that's working in
Milo's favor is that outside of the
mask, which is still sticking around,
the only thing that was expended was the
uh exhausting of your legend. That's
kind of the beauty of Lilia is that you
can create these sprites kind of over
and over to might check your opponent
without committing cards. There is a
scenario where if the card draw of your
opponent is uh lacking, you can kind of
win an attrition war, but so far
Botsmach has not been hurting for cards
in hand.
>> And now we see that ready sprite token
from the fountain. And it is a Teemo
coming down. Excuse me, the Vex coming
down with Teemo there right next to him.
This is going to be a super tough
battlefield to break through.
>> All of these units will come in stunned
for Milo.
Yeah,
>> absolutely brutal.
>> Absolutely not what you want to see. We
do see the watcher in the hand of Milo,
but that gets shut down. The accelerate
will not be beneficial. This is that
time where you need to find something
like the Rex so that you could deal
damage to the Vex. It's also protected.
So even if you try to take the slow path
of developing a unit in your base and
then trying to go over top then the
following turn that's going to be still
protected by whatever the hidden card is
as well as protected by that team of
strategist trigger
>> one for watcher. So we do see the
watcher come down
>> student
>> thousand tailed watcher plus raven bloom
student just developing there in the
backline for milo but
>> sorry beginning trigger this dies make a
sprite then hold to three
>> on smack
>> up three to two now getting that sprite
token off of the death nail from the
sprite fountain.
>> This is such a great example of the
unstoppable force versus the immovable
object. the Teemo player being so hold
centric like yes it's aggressive it
wants to get on the battlefields fast
and early but then it really does just
want to sit at locations for as long as
possible Lilia of course wants to be the
attacker wants to continue to get these
conquers but it is very much impacted by
the Vex apathetic at this point in time
>> I will play it to
>> getting the knock turn here being able
to get that four might unit in play for
One power
>> darkness.
[laughter] I cannot do the voice. But
that is of course the very famous
knockturn line from League of Legends.
>> Sprite into stars.
>> Yep. You're good. Conquered a four. Mhm.
>> Botmag really in control of this game
now.
Serious point tempo.
Now, there is an option if
>> I was just gonna say if there is a
desire to want to still get that hold on
the star tipped. Uh I did see at least
one Teemo in the hand that you can hide.
So once again on the temporary trigger
for the spray on the following turn. If
it's still there, you can play that,
maintain your presence, get that hold
point. I say if because obviously
Watcher and Raven Bloom are in the base
of Milo. We have no idea which
directions they're going to go. At some
point, Milo will likely have to crack
into that Vex apathetic
>> and this is going to be a great
opportunity to do so.
>> Yeah, brutalizer coming down being
attached to the student.
>> So, I go here.
>> Okay, so these are going to trigger and
I will react to that trigger with a
Teemo target.
>> Another Teemo.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Yeah, it's or it's plus two from Yeah,
plus three total. It's two, three, four,
five. As soon as we have the
>> two works.
>> And then these these are still on the
chain. This is over top of it.
>> Uh yeah. Uh
>> any reactions?
>> I will react to the two trigger.
>> Yep.
>> Just listening to the players navigate
through that.
>> Just in case he open five.
>> I I was just going to say
>> uh the the decision to react here is in
case of the open five. So going to
discipline. So now the Teemo strategist
does not have a way to kill this before
the mask triggers as well.
>> Now there is a scenario where you could
still reveal other knock turns here and
jam additional might and repel this
attach.
>> Mhm.
>> Is going to be three damage.
>> Yep. Now mask result.
>> Yes. Plus two more.
>> And now the additional plus two. So that
Raven Bloom student
>> puts you at seven total here
effectively. Like I need seven damage to
kill in a good spot.
>> So Batsmack asking how much damage
needed to kill the Raven Bloom or
>> that's win the combat again. That three
is the damage with three damage. Yeah.
>> So 10 might has three damage. Needs to
deal seven more currently. Five on the
battlefield between the sprite and the
team or anything.
>> Yeah, I pass.
>> I will also pass.
>> All right, there we go. So Milo able to
clear through the star tipped peak
>> getting up to three.
>> Southern Battlefield still going to be a
lot of work.
Now I do like this kind of split
approach from Milo by sending the Raven
Bloom in one direction, leaving the
Watcher to go in the other simply
because this guarantees both units will
get the value from the Mask of
Foresight. Yep.
>> Now, the scary part though is that if
this hidden card is
>> if this hidden card is something that
potentially interrupts this attack, uh,
a switcheroo for example would be
brutal, especially post stupify because
that Teemo strategist is only one might.
Uh, that would essentially be a 12 might
swing if this is a switcheroo.
>> So, here we go. The watcher moving in.
>> Teemo trigger resolving. Three.
Three damage.
>> Three damage going to be dealt.
>> Resolves. I will react with another
Teemo.
>> Another Teemo. Strategist was hidden.
>> This is madness.
>> So, we could see that thousand turn
watcher fall.
>> Turn.
>> Two. If this is Oh, I was going to say
this.
>> Oh, he can't do it. Only three. If this
was four hidden cards and a knockturn,
that would have been the biggest insult
to injury I have ever seen.
>> Noturn definitely going to come down.
>> So you can kill the Vex then kill the
Vex.
>> One damage shy is what Botmack was.
>> Um
>> Botmack is going to play this Noctturn.
I think it's pretty safe if they want to
reinforce to do so simply because
Nocturn has ganking. So if you need it
to go to the Raven Bloom side, uh you
can do so from the battlefield, but also
watcher's only at seven might and you
know the Vex is going to be the target.
So that knockturn is likely to survive
even if it reinforces
>> for the only thing you'd be worried
about is additional combat effects. But
since the second Teemo did not have
another response from Milo, because
again that would have been an opportune
time to play a discipline, play like an
ong guard, something like that. Uh I
think it's relatively safe.
>> Does opt to just go to base anyway.
>> Plays it conservative.
>> So now the plus two up to nine might is
the watcher
>> on you. Anything thinking?
>> So definitely has the capability to take
out Vex and a couple units along with
Vex.
>> Yeah, I think the most likely trade here
if there are no additional buffs. Yeah.
>> Uh would be uh actually everything uh
because of the stupify earlier, you can
clear all of
>> the might from
the battlefield. And so it is a straight
trade.
And so that's that's the only reason why
I was thinking before that maybe that
Noctturn would have been safe to go
>> uh to the seat.
>> Spray is created.
>> Yeah. desperately needed to clear out
that battlefield
>> and dodge that one hidden card to be
able to do it.
>> Gets in there with the sprite up to
four. It's four all,
>> but Botsmack two knock in the back line.
>> Now, I want to give credit where
credit's due. Botsmach is very clearly
smarter than me because uh I had already
forgotten about the plus two might from
the mask of four sightes even though
we've been talking about it. So that uh
sprite token even if a knockturn was
left over still would have cleared any
units that were there. So bots was
correct in putting the knockturn in the
base with eight on the sprite.
>> Four points.
>> Let's see how Botmack
>> goes about this. Getting back onto the
battlefield. Singularity going to
attempt to take out both units. And
barring some sort of buff like an
onguard, there it is.
>> The onguard
>> on to Raven Bloom student
>> will be plus three.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, that's the only thing that would
have
>> to. Yes, that was a mistake. Sorry.
>> Yeah, I was going to say it's the only
thing that would have potentially uh
saved it, but because the brutalizer has
not been equipped this turn, it is just
the base plus one.
>> So turn into starch. Yeah,
>> unfortunately still enough to take down
the student. And now those knock turns
>> have the green light
>> draw card.
>> Going to get that seed of power trigger
as well on conquer
>> up to six. And going back over to Milo,
he's going to have to break both of
these battlefields quickly. Got to break
one for sure.
>> The tempo swings right back over into
Botsmax's favor. So the thing that
you're most concerned about is whatever
the hidden cards are because Milo with
something like a sprite burst would be
able to pretty easily answer the might
on the battlefields. It is just a
question of whatever the hidden card is.
Botsmach does have no uh energy up but
>> any sort of trick on the top battlefield
would be problematic
>> to play accelerated.
>> Here comes that chosen champ for Milo.
getting accelerated here.
>> This is another way that you can crash
into these battlefields because you have
the accelerated Lilia plus you still
have your legend activation
>> because of the double mask of foresight
>> plus two. Yeah, thank you.
>> Gives you options
>> go in.
>> Yep.
>> Uh on move create a sprite on back.
>> And pass focus. This Lilia
>> would have plus three and then an
additional plus two from the mask if
that resolves.
>> Mhm.
>> See Teemo's scout
>> coming out. That's an additional four
might.
>> So eight might total on the side of BMA,
six on the side of Milo.
>> And then with the mask triggers, that
also means it's eight.
>> Could be a trade.
>> Three plus three plus two. So, it's
eight to Oh, it's 8 to8. Yeah. Uh, yeah,
we trade.
>> There we go. Okay, another trade.
>> And I think Milo is still fine with
that. Obviously, you would prefer to
have something left over, but
>> there will be the ability to clear the
other Nocturn as well, prevent any hold
points.
>> Yeah, so good. That ready Sprite, a five
might unit taking out Noturn. Milo able
to conquer up to five.
>> So, one of I was going to say one of the
things that you're worried about right
now is a card like sneaky deck hand.
>> Uh, anything that's going to get Batmach
immediately onto a battlefield to
continue the point pressure. Uh, but
because Milo's only at five points and
Botsmach is not in danger of losing to a
double conquer, this also could just be
a might development turn and passing.
And that's exactly what we see.
>> We can able dying.
>> Yep.
>> Bots still ahead in score, but Milo
>> has these battlefields open right now
>> top four.
>> Yep.
>> And if he can get sprites onto these
battlefields,
>> go here.
>> Defending. They are five might with the
mask of foresights.
>> Yes, you're six.
Well, the biggest issue for Milo right
now is that uh if Botsmach has the
option to double conquer next turn, they
will just win the game. So, if there's
something that answers the sprite and
you can go in with the knock turn and
then uh just for example play something
like the sneaky deck hand to the other
location. Uh speaking of answers,
Windser is a great one. Uh, this could
be the opener that maybe gets Botsmach
game one as a victory. We'll see what
Milo has in response.
>> Yep.
>> Needs to buff up the sprite. Can't do
it.
>> Sprites taken out.
>> Up to seven goes Botsmack. Does he have
a way to present a ready unit? No, he
has sneaky [laughter] deck in. He
doesn't need a ready unit.
>> Sneaky win for Botsmack in game one.
>> Teemo getting it done early.
>> Yeah, glad. Yeah, this was kind of a
mindfing matchup for a number of
reasons. Uh, on the one side, we've got
the Teemo that wants to get on and hold,
>> also has the [clears throat] Vex
Apathetic. On the other side, we've got
the Lilia that wants to continue to
conquer, uh, but then was forced into a
situation where Milo needed to also have
a a defensive stop, a hold, if you will,
or even if it's not a true hold, just
preventing the double conquer from
Botsmach. Notably, the Windser was
important because you had to have a buff
specifically to stop it. Uh, something
like Defy does not work on Windser. Uh,
the only counter spell that hits the
creature abilities or the unit
abilities, excuse me, is specifically
not so fast.
>> And I think in that first game, a big
spot was the initial Teemo Strategist
hit. when that sprite that moved in, it
was killed before the mask of foresight
triggers and it felt like that combat
allowing Botsmack to not have to commit
any resources to that particular combat,
he really held tempo throughout.
>> Yeah. And if you're watching at home and
you're just kind of curious about the
interaction, it's really just the
layering of the defender triggers and
the attacker triggers. So the attack
triggers technically occur first, but
that means that they are lower on the
chain. So the defender triggers go on
the top. And then if you think about if
you just put all the triggers in a pile
and you were picking them up by one by
one, well that means you're picking up
those defender triggers first. So it
fires and then when that happens, of
course the Teeo strategist snipes that
sprite token. And uh I think you're
correct. I think that's a good call out
for when things started to become
problematic for Milo. Uh Milo did keep
it competitive even through a VEX
apathetic. I think the big concern now
is when you go to the sideboard, if you
saw one in the main, you kind of have to
assume there's either more in the main
because they they don't know the deck
list like we do or you have to assume
that more are coming in one way or the
other. It's tough. I mean that Vex
apathetic, you have got to get it off
the board as quickly as possible because
your sprites are just dead in the water.
So, we love the Teemo strategist and I
just love the interaction of being able
to deal the damage, potentially take out
the attacker and also getting that extra
might on the board. That was just so
awesome. This casino Teemo, as you
called it. I love it.
>> Yeah, it's it's a little bit of uh
ratlike roulette, if you want to, you
know, say that Teemo players are dirty
rats, like I've sometimes heard in my
League lobbies. But uh it is to me a lot
of fun because you are rewarded for your
deck building
>> and we're I think seeing a replay of the
moment where the Lilia went in.
>> That was an important turn for Milo to
clear the board on Botmax sides, but the
problem was
redevelop.
You were able to take out the sprite
with no buff from Milo. And then of
course, like we've talked about that
sneaky deck hand.
>> All right, so just a little bit of a
replay there, but uh again, don't go too
far because we have game two coming here
in just a moment. Absolutely. Uh don't
let the replay fool you.
>> That being said, if you are the Lilia
player, what you're hoping for is that
they don't find the Vex apathetic
earlier or uh again, if you're playing
Lilia into the field into this unleash
meta, you have to have some sort of
answer for Vex. It's likely in the
sideboard. You got to make sure that
it's coming in. Uh but step two is also
draw it, right? It's entirely possible
that there are solutions that were in
the main deck that were just not picked
up by Milo. Uh ultimately though, uh you
have to be able to break through that
bunker, if you will, that the Vex
creates.
>> All right, here we go. Game two. Arena's
greatest for Milo. Grove of the God
Willow for Botmax. So, both players
starting with that additional point
right out of the gate.
Raven Bloom student is the opener for
Milo.
>> And
>> Milo does start with the sprite call.
>> Now, this will be, I think, very telling
depending on which battlefield this goes
to because it goes to the Grove of the
God Willow. I feel like Botsmach is
going to follow this up with a hidden
card and that's likely also going to
signal to Milo that the hidden card is a
unit of some sort so that you can still
get that grove trigger post temporary
reaction.
>> Yeah, hiding the chosen champion.
So, a bit of a face up hidden card here
for Botmack.
Milo will now have to plan accordingly.
That's at least five might and damage
come through and it's double mask of
foresight in backto back games.
>> Yeah. So, this was a situation where
>> you're out. Yeah. I'll flip the team
now. Yep.
>> Bounce was essentially daring Milo to
come over there. Said, "You know what?
I've hidden. You know it's a unit. You
know, I want this hole."
>> And
Milo said, "Okay, that's fine. I'll
develop some masks.
>> Get on the other location. And uh at
some point here, you're going to have to
come to my side because I scored first.
>> Yeah, Milo.
>> I was going to say the the points hadn't
updated yet, but I was thinking to
myself as I said, "Oh, I scored first."
But that's incorrect. Botsmach was the
first uh to get on the field because of
the sprites call.
>> So,
>> oh, there's that Vex once again.
So now that northern battlefield that
much more difficult for Milo to deal
with.
>> Sorry.
>> Am I hiding or not?
>> We know there was Riptide Rex.
>> Very curious to see if there was any
other good immediate options
to take out this Vex maybe out of the
sideboard for Milo.
>> Yeah. And this is already kind of a
nightmare scenario that we saw in game
one for Milo, which is the Vex apathetic
paired with that Teemo strategist. So,
anything that you send in has to both
dodge the snipe and survive enough to
take out the Vex. And that's through any
sort of shenanigans. The only saving
grace this time around is that Bosmach
does not have a hidden card. So, Milo
only has to worry about
>> the strategist trigger. So kind of a a
known information puzzle.
>> Yeah, no runes available either for
botmack. So here comes charm in student
>> and vex.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Coming down to that southern battlefield
>> and charm. Charm. Yes.
>> And the raven bloom student will be a
total of five might. It's enough to kill
Vex in combat. Uh Milo,
>> you slow down.
>> The great way to answer Vex on this
turn. The Sprite fountain coming out.
>> What do you recycle? You need recycle
that
>> or that's fountain not that's fountain
not call. You tap three. You did three
energy. That's a fountain. Two two in a
blue.
>> Sorry. So I do this.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Recycle this.
>> Okay.
>> And he's good.
>> Just properly identifying that it was a
little mix up on uh the cost.
>> One for charm, one for deflect.
>> Yep. They are fixing it. But yeah, the
>> charm there is huge because it does get
rid of the Vex. Yes, you had to recycle
two runes to do so. Once for the deflect
and then for the call. But
>> I'll wait.
>> All right, here we go.
>> Responds to it now, right?
>> Yes. If you have any reactions, it's
before I reveal
>> because three hidden cards revealed here
would be enough
>> to give it plus two.
>> Plus two,
>> but now it has to be five.
>> Has to be all of them.
>> And the star cross is an [laughter]
immediate whiff. But this knock turn
>> only one damage.
>> Only one damage. But this knockturn if
they want to reinforce would be enough
to force a trade.
>> I think letting the sprite take it and
then just saving the might on the knock
turn makes more sense because uh as of
right now Bosmach doesn't have any other
units left over.
>> If you really wanted to force a trade
and you had something like sneaky deck
hands in hand, maybe you'd consider it.
Milo
>> I conquer two
>> scoring up to four. The knock turn just
played to base for bot smack.
>> You at three, right?
>> Uh yes. Yes. Four.
>> Now Milo has claimed the points tempo.
>> Almost sitting back.
>> I think Milo is just respecting the
knock turn there. knows that that extra
might is also coming off. So, you don't
want to get blown out by something like
a wind singer as well.
>> Wants to save any might that they can,
but specifically permanent might. Uh
Lilia as a deck just has an access to an
awful lot of might through the sprites,
but it doesn't stick around. And at some
point, being able to hold or at least
prevent your opponent from conquering is
also really important. So, you really do
want to go out of your way to preserve
cards like Raven Bloom Student if you're
Milo. And it's another Vex. Nocturn gets
on the arena's greatest up to four
points for Buttsmack. And it's another
Vex.
>> Create another stand.
>> A hidden card to reinforce two
>> and drop.
>> Yep.
>> And we know Milo has at least
>> five might in base. Gets that sprite
token off the fountain.
>> I'll move student here. Start showdown.
Pass focus.
Uh yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Raven five.
>> Student does get this conquer to five.
>> Uh top three
>> play base
>> and pass.
>> Chosen champion just developed for Milo
this time around.
>> Uh hold the five.
>> Mhm.
>> Five to five the score.
>> Ultimately not a lot that Milo could
have done there other than just again
develop more permanent might because of
the Vex apathetic. Everything that is
entering play is entering stunned. So
you don't want to accelerate the Lilia.
The spray token created from the
fountain left over was also stunned upon
entering. There's also again that kind
of bit about moving, right? You can't
move even if you could do something
about the stun.
>> But here we're going to see a sprite
call just played by Votsmach.
>> And that means it might be going into
this Raven Bloom student with some help.
Or it could be like a wind singer to set
it up and then you send it in.
>> Fountain of blue.
>> Oo, another sprite going to be played
here off the Sprite Fountain.
>> That's six might at least. Two runes up
for Milo to potentially play some
defense here
>> at Grove of the Godwillow.
>> Uh, yeah.
>> Uh, yeah, I pass. You pass. Yep.
>> All right. No response here. Raven
Bloom. It does fall up to six points.
Hot smack at the allimp important six
here holding that battlefield
the arena's greatest
>> tough to break through for Milo. This is
a situation where if Batsmach also has a
unit that you can hide putting that on
the grove might make sense because then
you threaten the hold to eight. However,
if you also just want to ensure that you
protect the other side. Yeah, I I like
this kind of safe pass. Yep.
>> There's not a lot I think of investment
that you want to put on the grove unless
you think you can absolutely for sure
guarantee the win. Um I did see
something like a a switcheroo that you
could hide, but then you don't have the
unit for the hold and if you go with the
unit, then you might have to play that
switcheroo from hand. Maybe it gets it
done. But uh ultimately just playing
conservative. I think potmuck knows that
they kind of have the tempo lead now.
They definitely have the points lead.
They want to put the onus on Milo to
expend more resources
>> and fast.
>> Moving in.
>> Five might for Lilia
to three for that sprite.
>> Um,
you have three enhanced.
>> Yep.
>> Back in the tank here. Deciding on
>> seven of them.
>> He wants to respond.
All right,
>> I'll attempt the switcheroo.
>> So, we do see the switcheroo get played
anyway from hand. Uh, this costs two
energy and a recycle of two runes,
whereas if it was hidden would have only
just been the one power, but again, uh,
or it could have been one energy with
the team ability. Again, if you play
that switcheroo
and Milo does not go to the grove,
essentially you're just wasting the
switcheroo. So, uh, in this situation,
you're just kind of prioritizing,
uh, making sure that it gets value at
the cost of additional energy and runes
as opposed to, you know, if you took the
more economical route the other way. Uh,
and I have no problems with this
personally because if you weren't going
to be doing anything else with the runes
anyway,
>> this can move in because
>> yeah, this can move in this play. This
is stunned as well. So, I just draw.
>> So, the smoke and mirrors coming out
here.
>> Uh, and
>> and with the Lilia moving back to base,
a sprite is created, but there is the
handshake.
>> Can't take smack off the battlefields
and then gank. Yeah.
>> And Teemo gets the job done here in
round five. What a performance.
>> And there on the player coms, not sure
if they caught it on the broadcast at
home, but you did hear Boxmach point out
that it was a hold to seven and then
because of the knockturn as long as
there was no presence on the opposing
battlefield, Knockturn has ganking, so
you can move over, you go immediately to
eight with the double conquer. And uh
that's a lock. That's a big win for
Botsmach. Uh, I am not surprised by the
outcome if only because again it's very
hard to play Lilia into Vex Apathetic. I
think that's the main reason that Lilia
has not been more popular at these
events. But it is still nice to see the
deck in action.
>> Yeah, it really was cool to see it in
action, but definitely not a matchup you
are excited about. And it was just so
cool to see the interactions there with
Teemo, all of the hidden tricks and that
real heads up play at the end like you
talked about with the switcheroo, not
hiding it because again, you're just
wasting it if Milo doesn't move into
that northern battlefield. So, I really
liked that heads up play.
>> Yeah. And you kind of also wanted the
versatility of uh if Milo had some sort
of play that you were not expecting
because this is game two and cards come
in from the sideboard, you don't know
what's coming in. Uh if there was
anything where they somehow tried to get
a combat on the other side because we
did see that the blue Lilia was around.
Yeah.
>> Then you have the switcheroo that you
could play on that side as well. Right.
It's just the conservative play.
Sometimes the best way to win a game uh
in Riftbound or any card game that
you're playing is to just don't make
mistakes that would cost you the game
even if the chances are so small.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Well, I think we
should hear from Botsmack himself,
Teemo. Let's check it out.
>> An excellent cast for an excellent
performance with Teemo here in Hartford.
Now you are officially 5-0 with Teemo.
And how does it feel because you've
actually been playing Teemo the entire
time anytime you registered for a
qualifier?
>> Yeah, now I I've been on Teemo since the
beginning. Honestly, it started with I
just wanted to play I wanted those
colors. I wanted the the mind chaos. I
wanted to I was I had a deck that I was
calling affectionately calling Teemoless
Teemo because it was just control but
with uh but like playing Teemo. Uh I
ended up shifting into like the more
mid-range build for set one. Set two I
was playing the pit crew aggro. Just
barely missed uh best of at Las Vegas
with that one. And then I've been on the
like the blue nocturn build now. Like
Sprite Fountain is a crazy card. No, I I
we have actually been talking about it
with quite a few decks, you know, like
it being a better aggressive tool for
like the Victors that exist now, but
it's just more aggressive tools to help
you just get onto the battlefields,
which is exactly what Teemo wants,
right? And the fact, of course, I mean,
one of my favorite cards of the entire
deck, Teemo Strategist. It's just like
the bread and butter of what I think
this deck has become. Of course, the
Nocturns are incredibly powerful, but
just being able to have one already
there for your ondefend and then showing
a second one that Watcher almost dying.
I was hoping it would make it there cuz
I was like if I get this it's dead. If I
don't I lose all of this but it's still
like I I was like it's it's a worthwhile
trade. 100% was and it ended up working
out for you of course anyway but we were
even in hoping like oh does he have a
stupify in hand you know like that one
one might off but you know that is
sometimes how the casino rolls right but
it's such a fun deck to me to watch and
it leaves your opponent guessing but I
think also when I sit down and I play it
leaves me guessing sometimes even with
how many times you find
>> like that definitely there have been
games where it's like they swing in and
I'm like all right if if we're we're
gambling if this hits we we win in a
landside if it whiffs we we're going to
be struggling for the of the game and
like it hits more often than it doesn't.
So,
>> no. And you can tailor the deck how you
want to, but the cost of which you do so
is a lot of those like powerful mind and
chaos cards that you're talking about.
You know, think about like the hard
bargains or any sort of like extra draw
power from things like stack deck or
whatever. If you play those cards in
your deck, you make that synergy go
down. But incredible pilot, incredible
job. 5-0 here in Hartford. But we have
more action and you [clears throat] have
more rounds to play, Bat Smack. So,
congratulations and I hope to see you in
the future. We'll send it back.
>> Love to hear it. Love to hear the
success story from Tee Obsmack on a
great run so far and really highlighted
the Sprite Fountain as that extra tool
that was gained that allows that deck to
get on the battlefield early to really
get the whole process started.
>> Yeah, Sprite Fountain does a couple of
things for Teemo. Uh, as somebody who
loves Teemo, I've been playing it since
the game came out, much like Botsmach,
and I went through the same kind of
process where in set one, you kind of
played it as a control deck. Uh, set
two, you started to get a bit more
tools, but in sets one and two, the
biggest issue Teemo had was actually
retakes. So you can still get onto the
battlefield pretty early, especially
when your legend is something that you
can always have a turn one play with.
>> But if your opponent can ever crack into
the battlefields because all your stuff
is so small and or meant to be hidden,
you have a hard time retaking. One of
the things that Sprite Fountain allows
you to do is if you draw it late game,
you can use that plus the sprites calls
to kind of like crash into a Battlefield
force trades and then if one of the
sprites survives, you can still hide
something, then go for the hold, etc.,
etc. So, Sprite Fountain helps with the
early game, it also helps with the late
game. And then the other big addition in
Unleash is of course Vex Apathetic. We
saw it be an all-star in this particular
matchup as well.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And if I recall
correctly, you sold pastry time on Teemo
back in Atlanta. Now we see hear it on
stream in Hartford. And uh yeah, I mean
it's a lot of fun. And so maybe some of
you at home want to pick up this deck
because the high rolls and the things
that it can do pretty exciting.
>> Oh, absolutely. This is a deck that even
when you lose, sometimes you just have a
blast playing it. I'm happy to see it
here and I kind of hope that Bots goes
far and I get to see him in day two.
>> Yeah, that would be exciting. I think
we've got a little bit of a recap with
Kangas.
>> Thank you very much. Teemo was able to
get the win. So definitely having fun
for our duelist on stage there. And I'm
going to take a look at some of the big
moments from that last game.
Specifically, the moments that make you
love playing Teemo. This deck is so
exciting. Your ability to hide without
paying the power cost. And really, the
entire deck is built around hidden
units. Specifically, you'll note that uh
our hero here, the Teemo pilot, is on
Oh, let's see if I can center that one a
little bit better. Uh the chosen uh
Teemo Strategist. So, whenever it's
attacked or whenever you reveal it, you
reveal the top five of your deck. And
that's why they're also on things like
the knock turn. But it gets even better
than that because as we start the clip,
the uh Lilia matchup into Teemo pretty
tough. Lilia has a lot of accelerate
units, specifically the sprites. You
want to punch in. The thousand tail
watcher is one great tool to deal with
the Teemo board. Um, and we can see that
the stupify comes down before they go in
for the attack. And then as Milo
actually goes in for the attack, you
might be wondering, well, uh, what's
this other hidden card right here? You
know, Milo's definitely wondering that.
I'm wondering that. We're all curious.
What could Teemo have hidden? There's so
many things. Is it like a switcheroo?
Uh, is it, you know, a wage is a pain.
Um, turns out that they're first going
to trigger this. And this is a reason I
want to break this down is because of
how close Teemo got to just completely
shutting out the Lilia. actually kind of
works out for Milo here because the
first Teemo will trigger revealing three
and then the second Teemo. So, we have
one, two, three hidden cards so far.
We're trying to get to seven with two
Teeos. Theoretically, we just need to
reveal four more and we can get there.
But unfortunately, we only get to 456
for only six total damage. So, it's not
enough to kill the Watcher. The Watcher
will crash with everything. And that
means that Milo's kind of in the game,
but still the Teemo deck is just so good
at getting back on there with the
sprites and with the knock turns back in
bases. We were highlighting that
Batsmark or Batsmack was talking about
that that Sprite found great card in the
Teemo deck. Just get back on
battlefields. Um, so I just wanted to
highlight how close the math was to just
completely blowing out. This is the
Teemo dream right here. If you pilot
Teemo, you want to hit this. You're
hitting noturns. You're almost sniping
the thousand tail. Um, that's kind of
the joy of playing Teemo is high rolling
these flips. Uh, let's take a look at
the next clip, though, because this one
highlights another key point. We saw
this card already, but I want to just
highlight it again. This card in hand
completely shuts down Lilia. Everything
Lilia wants to do is immediately stopped
by this. Let's play the clip so we can
see what the card is. It's Vex
Apathetic. You're going to see this all
over the place. Vex Apathetic is very
popular right now in the format.
everyone uh that's in the cash domain is
on this card. I can't center it. That's
all right. But basically, whenever a
card is played, it gets stunned and it
can't move. Turns out that's almost all
of Lilia's cards. Lilia is very strong
as a deck. If you never play against
Chaos cuz as soon as this hits a
battlefield, it's so hard for the Lilia
player to actually get out there and
score points. And we see Milo try to
fight through it uh with things like
charm, but still just not quite enough.
So, uh that's all that I had for the
breakdown there. It was a 20 for the
Teemo. Shout out all the Teemo hats that
are in the audience and everybody back
home cheering them on. You voted. It was
like 80% vote to watch this one.
Hopefully you got what you're looking
for. But that's it for me. Back to the
casters.
>> Thank you so much, Kangas. That was a
great breakdown. And the fans at home,
they spoke. They wanted to see Teemo. It
was exciting. And I think personally I'm
sold now too, Charmer. Well, hopefully
more people will start attending the
Church of Teemo, but uh if you remember
when we were voting to see what matches
we were going to see, the other option
included Cactus King, who is on Azir,
and this is a player that was also in a
full suit. I hear that we're going to be
trying to jump into some of that matchup
as well. But before we do, I think we
need a primer. So I would like to ask
somebody who is an expert on Azir to
explain uh Azir to me and explain Azir
to the audience. So uh Charmer can you
explain to me what Azir does perhaps the
t take it away I guess Charmer.
Hello everybody. Charmer here at the
regional qualifier in Hartford
Connecticut and I am here to tell the
people what I have seen here today. And
what I have seen is Azir. This is a deck
that I'm very excited to go in depth and
talk about because it is something that
just won in Utrect. It's a very powerful
list, but it is also incredibly
versatile despite being uh what many
feel to be a a very linear deck and
we'll talk about why. So, right out of
the gate, the whole reason to play Azir
is of course the legend ability. You're
going to be playing equipment,
specifically uh gear that is equipment
you can attach to units. But this legend
makes the units for you. You get to
spend an energy, turn that legend
sideways, make a sand soldier token on
any turn where you've played a gear. So,
naturally, we're going to be running a
lot of gear, a lot of equipment, and
right out of the gate as you're looking
at this list, you're going to see uh
maximum copies of Eye of the Herald, of
Doran's Shield, of Soul Sword. These are
all cards that cost one energy to play.
And that's very important because that
means your opening play can be to play
the gear and then make the sand soldier
token. And then in doing so, because
those sand soldiers have weapon master,
the gear is automatically equipped and
you are ready to go into the next turn
with a a relatively powerful unit for
that stage of the game. But it's not
just about fast starts. Yes, this can
make a lot of sand soldier tokens. Uh
you've got those early gear that you
want to play. You do also have to some
staying power throughout the rest of the
game. So cards like Brutalizer or cards
like BF sword for example, uh those are
gear that give you more might, more
power, more bang for your buck if you
draw them in the later stages of the
game and you can still create those sand
soldiers when you need to. There's also
going to be some incredibly powerful
card draw options in this list,
specifically hidden blade and death
grip. And the reason they're powerful is
because of their versatility. Hidden
blade. This is something that you can
use on your own units to draw two cards
if you're running low on cards. Uh you
can also use it on your opponent's
larger units if you don't have enough
might to overtake something and you
really need one of those critical
points. The other big thing about both
this card and death grip, which also
allows you to draw a card, it also does
kill one of your own units and then
transfer its might somewhere else, is
that it allows you to kill your own
unit. That's a very big deal in Azir
because sometimes you have equipment
that is attached to a unit and you want
it to be on another unit. And so this
allows you to kind of cascade your might
around the board. You could conquer one
battlefield and if that unit survives,
use a card like death grip to then buff
another unit, but also free up the gear
that was on it so that you can reattach
it and maybe go over the top, get to
that second battlefield, score those two
points per turn, because ultimately
that's what this list is trying to do.
You want to score two points per turn
whenever possible. Another big reason
why I'm a fan of this list in particular
is yes, it's fast. Yes, it's aggressive,
but you also get the benefit of being
able to play defy. Defy right now is
almost a metading card. It is very often
the most played or at least in the top
two or top three of most played cards in
the room at these regional qualifiers.
Uh it counters something like 79%
of all the spells that exist in the game
as of right now. So, when you have your
units and you're trying to either keep
them alive or try to make sure that you
are scoring those points and your
opponent might have a removal spell of
their own, you can use this to protect
your investment, make sure that you
secure those points. Uh, against other
decks that might want to drag the game
on. You can slow them down. For example,
you could use this to even counter spell
things like catalyst against these
Aurora decks. Uh the other big thing
that is uh important to Azir is of
course the signature spell arise. Uh
this is your closer. This is very often
how you kind of repopulate the board or
it can allow for that double conquer at
the end. This allows you to create a
sand soldier token for each of the gear
that you already have in play. And if
you're playing Azir, it should hopefully
be a large number of gear. But on top of
that, two of those sand soldier tokens
are going to enter already. And that
means that you can use them right away.
So again, if there's open battlefields,
that represents a double conquer on its
own, but on top of that, because they
have weapon master and with the gear
that you already have, even if they're
occupied, you very often can go over the
top. So, uh, this is the Azir list. I
think that it is incredibly powerful at
churning out might, maintaining that
board state, and then allowing you to
close out games before your opponents
really get the opportunity to set up or
react. Uh there's a reason that it won
in Utrect. There's a reason that
Squirtle has won twice with this list.
It's incredibly potent, and I expect to
see more of it today and in the future.
Well, if I don't say so myself, Charmer,
that was a great rundown of Azir. That
was fantastic.
>> Yeah, I'm very happy that Charmer was
able to explain that to me. I needed a
refresher because uh again, here in
short order, we're going to be jumping
into a game featuring Cactus King
piloting Azir. And again, this is a
player that's adorned in a full suit. We
keep mentioning it because uh it's fun
and we like to have fun here. But also I
think that Azir is one of those lists
that we're kind of watching in
particular because Squirtle just did so
well in Utrect. Squirtle has won
multiple regional qualifiers. And then
even for other events a lot of the times
when I'm talking to people I've heard
that Azir is a deck that folks think is
kind of underperforming in terms of
representation. meaning that the people
who play Azir tend to do very well and
yet for whatever reason that's not
converting into more players bringing it
to the large events.
>> And it's interesting because that deck
is another deck to me that's a lot of
fun and it seems to just continue to
pour on the pressure. You're generating
those tokens every single turn. And then
you talked about Arise. I think that's
one of the most fun signature spells in
the game. Just flood the board with one
card. It's absolutely great. But I think
we are ready to get to this feature
match and see Azir and we are going to
be seeing
a favorite of the spirit forged meta.
One that uh reigned supreme for a while.
Draven
>> doesn't even matter. Doesn't even
matter.
>> And then I'll lose it. Boom. Good. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Don't know what we uh hopped into. We
are hopping into game two. It does look
like Cactus King did win game one, but
looks like there was a little uh gold
and immediate expenditure stuff going on
there.
>> Uh also worth noting as we hop into this
game,
>> James time here has not many runes left
over. So quite a bit of recycling done.
We also see in the trash a thermo beam.
>> So this has already been an explosive
game, too.
>> Absolutely. Yeah, you can see no
equipment in play right now for Cactus
King.
Score four to two in favor of James time
holding both
>> battlefields of the God Willow.
>> Okay, I'll react by using a tie turner
on the
>> Ember Monk here.
>> Charm,
>> I'll get the move.
>> Reacted by Tide Turner to get that ember
monk down to the Trafarian War camp.
Yeah, that tide turner is unfortunate
for Cactus King. I liked the play of
trying to move the unit with charm over
to the grove because if that was a
hidden card that was not a unit, you
would have forced the hidden card to go
away because there's no longer a
presence there as well as open up a
battlefield for a conquer with one of
these sand soldiers. because it was tide
turner. Now you're in a situation where
both battlefields are still occupied and
you are going to have to likely not go
into trifiranian war camp because even
with the buffs on the sand soldier
tokens, you're just going to be trading
into the opposing unit.
>> That BF sword making that sand soldier
quite the threat. Clearing out the
northern battlefield
>> as the eye comes out.
>> Yeah, move trigger. moving in the mood
trigger at the war camp. This is a lot
of might.
>> I'll leave the sand the
>> takes out the monk.
>> The reaction from James time uh I think
sums it up beautifully though. Yeah,
because with that Trifarian War camp,
the eye definitely changed the math.
Before I was talking about how Cactus
King was not going to be able to go over
the top of the opposing unit. It would
have just been an even trade, but uh
that definitely changed the equation.
Trifarian War Camp. Great for a deck
like Azir where you're playing a lot of
units.
>> Cactus King able to wipe
the board on James time's side and
leaves quite the presence on his own as
we see the stack tech for James time
looking for something here. Needs to
develop. Only has four runes left to do
so.
Kaknus King threatening to hold up to
six.
>> Now, this is a bit of a predicament for
James time just because you've already
played one thermo beam
>> and your opponent has already found two
more equipment. One of them, of course,
being the BF sword.
>> So, even though you have kind of used
your best silver bullet from the
sideboard,
>> there's still a lot of might available.
And that might is not going to be going
away even if you get rid of the units
because again uh both the BF sword
representing the three might but also
the eye representing might going into
Trifarian camp as well uh are
problematic.
>> Cactus King up to five now holding at
Grove of the Godwillow getting that
extra card
>> looking to continue the pressure.
Another BF sword and another copy of Eye
of the Herald.
All going on. The sand soldier in base
and this Trafarian war camp is going to
be flooded. Two move triggers with the
eye of the Herald.
>> And that is three units now at that
southern battlefield for Cactus King
>> going up to six points.
And it's quite a bit of might at both
battlefields. We have a hidden card at
the southern battlefield as well.
Yeah,
>> threatening to win here on a double
hold.
>> Yeah, the hidden card is also very
problematic because it could be anything
from a hidden blade to a back off. Both
would be disastrous if you tried to go
into that battlefield and they just
answered any solo unit. In order to
prevent a loss, what James time wants to
do is likely attack into the Grove of
the Godwillow, clear the sand soldier
that's there with the one BF sword from
Cactus King, and at least force Cactus
to go to seven, but the issue there is
any sort of uh guards or other option
that's going to play a unit accelerated.
Of course, I see that chosen champion
still available as well.
That is another way that you could face
a reconquer. So, uh, things are looking
a little dire right now for James time.
>> James time begins the process. Does
>> take care of that sand soldier that had
all of the equipment on it with the
rebuke. And now the gust taking out one
of the recruit tokens.
>> The fan moves in. What's the hidden
card? It is back off. And the hard
bargain is going to counter the back
off. So the recruit falls.
>> James time conquering Trafarian War
Camp, drawing a card off of the Draven
Legend Trigger as well, winning that
combat,
>> finding a way to dismantle the southern
battlefield in a big moment.
>> And we will
>> Yeah,
>> with the hidden card, you might have a
chance to hold here if you're James
time. biggest issue is right now if
Cactus King does have uh a way to get
onto that battlefield,
>> it will threaten
uh more than even just a a single card
will hold. I'm actually kind of doing
the math here. So, with the option to
accelerate the Azir from the chosen
champion zone, uh you could send that.
The problem there though is you're low
on order runes, so attaching the other
equipment is not likely going to be a
thing. Um, again, cards like guards
could get the job done.
>> There is always a situation where Cactus
King could just look to hold at that
northern battlefield.
>> Fertilizer
>> for the win next turn if he doesn't feel
he can get through the war camp.
>> Same soldier.
>> Yeah. Uh, there's definitely a scenario
where you just develop additional might
because James time is only at five. So
if they
can
>> I can react. Is that correct?
>> This spot. Yeah. Asking about the react
to the
>> equip. All right.
>> Uh plays the pike. But uh what I was
starting to say is uh if James time
>> pass
>> is holding here. They only hold up to
six.
>> I'll hold here.
>> A conqueror on the other side takes you
to seven. So, unless it was something
that was with a weird inclusion of like
the purple version of Draven, for
example, you're probably fine. Uh, quick
math here. I don't think that there are
enough runes on the side of James time
to do something like purple Draven plus
Ride the Wind. So, uh, Cactus King
is going to try to hold the Grove of the
God Willow, but also has a bunch of
might in the base
>> to threaten a double conquer on the
following turn as well. Uh, blast cone
this guy to this battle.
>> Blast cone going to move the sand
soldier to the Trafarian war camp and
then stun it.
>> So, you are the attacker. You got focus
first.
>> Look at this. He found a way.
>> I'm sorry. I have to find the trigger.
>> Yep. I pass.
>> This is a card that I'm so excited to be
seeing [laughter] in play. It was one of
the cards I was most excited about when
it was revealed for Unleashed. Uh, if
you're not familiar at Homie, did you
see it on the screen? It's a gear. When
you play it, you get to move an enemy
unit, but any time that you do that as
well, you can stun it. And that is
counting future effects. So, Blast Cone
here being used kind of as a as a one
shot, but if you had other effects that
were moving your opponent's units like
Void Assault that we saw earlier in the
broadcast from Kha'Zix or so on and so
forth, uh it stuns there as well. This
is just such a neat card.
Now things get a little bit more
interesting because
>> if James time can force another turn, he
could potentially hold up to seven and
then possibly conquer for the win. So
let's see what Cactus King has needing
to conquer both battlefields if he wants
to win this turn. Well, if he goes for
another potential hold,
>> the most important
>> Northern Battlefield,
>> the most important thing that's
available right now is uh if it's there,
arise
>> could be a play.
>> Don't have to commit it yet. You can
just
>> go ahead and send this one sand soldier
in, see how this combat goes. You've got
the floating energy and then playerize
after the fact if needed. Uh the other
option is of course just cascading these
equipment as well.
Fan going to be killed here to attempt
>> pushing back the sand soldier.
>> More recruits generated for Cactus King.
>> But now just two might left at the war
camp for Cactus.
>> 5.2.
>> Yeah, the overzealous fan of course was
sacrificed to the trigger. Moved the
sand soldier back. Cactus King got the
additional eye of the Herald Trigger.
And this is interesting. We have a
salvage
>> coming down. Oh, okay. Uh I was going to
say I thought
>> and then I saw the salvage resolve. I'll
drop to off the hidden blade.
>> So pike killed.
>> Yeah. Unfortunate because now you've
also given up information to your
opponent if you're cactus king. Evelyn
being revealed of course means that
James time is still on the war camp.
Does get to draw the two from the hidden
blade.
>> Come here.
>> Draw or conquer.
>> Uh
>> and moving up to the grove looking to
draw a card.
Now, as weird as it sounds, there is
some incentive if you can stop this from
doing so, even though it's not
threatening a point
>> because it is denying a card draw and
that is the play that James time is
going to take. Obviously, Cactus King
has a small hand size and they just
accidentally showed you that the card
was a salvage. So, if you can deny that
card draw, then you're kind of playing
with known information minus whatever
their top deck is next turn. And that's
a great position to be playing from. The
one downside is that right now James
time also has no might on their side of
the board. So they would uh need to be
working either with some sort of
accelerate or
>> uh have some combat tricks where they
could develop and then stop the double
conquer next turn.
>> And now the Azir developed.
So once again back and forth we go.
James time looking at open battlefields,
but Cactus King
is set to advance to those battlefields
on the next turn and take the game.
Let's see what James can do about it.
>> And Falling Star, the Sand Soldier, and
the U the recruit.
>> Here we go. That is a way to take care
of that backline. Falling Star clearing
out two of the units, leaving just the
Azir chosen champion.
This is a great time to do so simply
because Cactus King is fully exhausted.
So there is no energy up for Defy and
then plays the Vex. This Vex could have
been huge if it was played to a
battlefield cuz that would stop cards
like Arise from representing uh a
potential lethal uh with the Azir here
and James time fully exhausted. could
also again get away with it with
something like a guards or anything
where you're getting a unit that's
ready. But we also know that Cactus King
is essentially just working with the one
card, whatever it was that was top
decked here.
>> This conquer threatens another draw and
that is successful.
>> Does Cactus King have a way to present
another ready unit?
>> BF sword.
>> Another BF sword coming out.
That is the third. So all three
available. [laughter]
And again worth noting this is post
thermo beam. So three best friend swords
on the battlefield.
>> You know that's what that stands for,
right? Absolutely. Yeah. Absolutely.
[laughter]
>> Put a BF sword on them.
>> Another BF sword going to buff up that
southern battlefield. That's seven might
>> for Cactus King at the war camp.
James time needs to take care of Azir
or the match is over.
>> Now this time around Cactus King does at
least have one energy up so representing
potentially defy potentially on guard
things like that
knowing that James time going to take a
look at some of the options with a
stacked deck.
There are of course you know star cross
in this list. We did just see the one
where it was played on the Evelyn. As
far as cards in the hand of James time,
Cactus King knows at least one is the
Evelyn because it was bounced from the
start
for an accelerated Rengar.
>> Oh wow. Accelerated Rengar.
>> And that is a massive amount of might
coming into Azir.
>> Uh yeah, I'll just
>> see if Cactus King has any response.
Yeah, we can go to damage.
>> I'd like to trade with the Vex.
>> I was going to say this is the decision
you have to make. On the one hand, you
can't really afford to let the Vex stick
around. On the other hand,
>> uh James time is left with the Rengar.
If there's a way to save this Rengar,
it's beneficial because again, it's got
so many keywords. It's got ganking, it's
got deflect, it's got assault. This
hidden card here represents James Times,
I think, best hope and an attempt at
holding for the win.
>> What a game this has been. Back and
forth. It's been fantastic.
Cactus King once again,
the onus on him. Can he figure this out?
Plenty of might represented in that back
line
>> and Cactus King essentially operating
from the top deck like we've said. And
there's the Eye of the Herald. So all
three swords, all three Eye of the
Heralds in play in a post thermmo world
as well.
>> That is going to be a lot of potential
might at that war camp.
>> Yeah,
>> here comes all the eye of the Heralds. a
lot of
>> that soldier,
>> a lot of might coming, but even more
importantly because of the eyes, it's
going to be more units as well. So even
if this is something like a switcheroo
on the Rengar, all of the other units
will still take care of
>> and that's going to do it. He shows the
hand. Cactus King taking it. Azir over
Draven
>> here in round five. What a match. Yeah,
that was I think a phenomenal [music]
ending to that particular matchup. Uh if
only because we got to see the fun back
and [music] forth when we had Spirit
Forged and Draven was kind of running a
muck, right? When it was the summer of
Draven, if you will, there were so many
ways that people were trying to avoid
combat because you didn't want to let
Draven draw cards. It's refreshing to
see uh a game state now where the
Dravens are getting into combat, the
Azir are getting into combat, and we get
to see the fireworks on the battlefield
like that.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And it's still wild
because you mentioned it in that game.
Thermmo beam was used early on and that
game it was drawn out and we find three
Eye of the Heralds and three BF swords
following that Thermo Beam. That's
tough.
>> Yeah. And I think that that speaks to
why post unleashed, Azir is even more uh
consistent because before cards like
thermmo beam could be very scary. They
were a bit of a a silver bullet against
you. Again, in Spirit Forge when Draven
was kind of the top dog of the meta,
there were several other things like
fight or flight that were kind of
denying the combats. But where the game
is now, the Azerists, even if they're
hit with thermmo beam because they have
a critical mass of gear, specifically
the equipment available to them, uh,
they have the consistent starts, right?
You have nine one cost equipment that
you can pair with your legend activation
and turn into a fantastic turn one play.
Uh, arguably some of the strongest, most
consistent turn one plays because it's
uh, a two might unit and whatever the
effects of the gear are. But on top of
that, if you do lose the gear, whether
it's to people main decking salvages or
auctionons to deal with Aurora or in
this case, even after the sideboard, you
have the thermmo beam. Azir just keeps
cranking out more gear. It never stops.
The gear, the sand soldiers, they just
keep coming. Azir just the emperor of
the sands. He's got it all. Let's hear
from our winner. We'll send it over to
Barrett now.
And here we had another fantastic round
five and our other feature match
featuring Cactus King who took down that
incredible deck. Now I got to ask you,
you're playing Azir.
>> That deck just won last week in Utre.
Why did you make the choice?
>> Well, I started playing Azir about two
months ago when Pedro got his first
regional win and I kind of followed in
his footsteps. Got his guide, learned a
lot from it, watch him watch his match
views and watch his V reviews. He's a
really good player and I just taking
everything that he's given up to the
public and
>> so good that he's now won two regional
qualifiers and you could follow in those
footsteps with a deck like Azir 5 and0
now. And I got to I got to bring it up
for the people at home cuz they might
not be following everyone's journeys as
closely as we are. But Cactus King, who
did you play against in round two?
>> Uh I got the round one by and then round
two the name that showed up was Dewali.
>> So
>> and I was I was a little bit nervous.
So, I was This was a hard tournament run
right at the start, but I managed to get
it the game 20. So, I ended up feeling
pretty good about that. Good confidence
boost for the weekend.
>> That's a crazy confidence boost. I can't
tell you anytime I've ever beat Dewali
in like fun games. And here you are, you
get a buy, you got to sit down against a
regional qualifier champion, not just
any of them, but the first one in
Houston, and you win. And it just like
is showing how like anyone can show up
to these events. Your first regional
qualifier ever. And you've already taken
down one champ. Who's to say you won't
beat another one? So, I got to say, how
are you feeling already? One win away
from being into day two here.
>> I'm feeling pretty good. I've hit a lot
of good matchups today and I've had a
lot of good draws. And I'm just looking
to close the day out consistently. If I
just play at this level for the rest of
the day, I should get at least like six
or seven wins by the end of it.
>> Perfect. And then my last question for
you, I got to ask the suit. You look
great, man. Why do you wear the suit
here in the tournament day? Well, I
travel down to these tournaments and I
just like dressing nicely for the park.
If I'm going to come down here, I might
as well make a weekend out of it. Dress
nicely. Just enjoy the atmosphere
>> and enjoying the atmosphere you are. And
being 5-0 helps as well. But
congratulations once again on your win.
You got more tournament to play, so
we're going to send it back.
>> That was excellent stuff. Thank you,
Barrett. Hats off to you, Cactus King.
And I I actually feel a little
underdressed now. Cactus King, he
brought out all the stops with that
suit. Looked great.
>> Yeah, you know, a little behind the
scenes look. We were told about our
wardrobe to uh make sure we didn't look
too out of place amongst the crowd. And
turns out the crowd is dressing better
than us. Cactus King said, "I'm playing
a legend that likes to have the gear, so
I'm also going to bring my own gear,
maximum drip, and honestly just maximum
uh swag from Cactus King." Because
during that interview we heard Barrett
say that they have a win against Dewali
here as well. So clearly the suit is
working. Absolutely. And that was his
first game he played of the day or the
first match he played because he had the
round one buy. So getting paired right
into Dewali a former regional qualifier
champion for your first match of the
day. That is intimidating to say the
least and he was able to do it. So Azir
last weekend in Utre and now right now
undefeated with Cactus King. So who
knows what's in store. And yesterday I
was talking to a lot of people here in
the venue and a lot of people said they
believed that it was going to be someone
new raising that trophy up this weekend.
So who knows? Maybe Cactus King could be
the one.
>> I I hope that's the case. But you know
on the journey there there's a lot of
things that you have to consider right
the meta is ever evolving. You know you
mentioned the results from Utre to where
we had eight different legends
represented in the top eight. So with
that in mind we've got some neat stuff
to look at like the most represented
units that are being played. Uh so this
is the most popular uh units across the
meta and kind of no surprises here. I I
see some all stars, but what really
jumps out to me is the impact of
Unleashed with both Scuttle Crab and Vex
Apathetic being introduced in Unleashed
and now number one and number two.
Absolutely. Scuttle Crab is just so
good. Not to mention delicious. But
Scuttle Crab, it replaces itself every
single time. And I know that zero might,
well, that's not a lot of might, but
that knowledge that you get of your
opponent's hand, that hand knowledge is
so, so important. And we're seeing so
many players just play that card. You
get a card back, you can potentially
conquer early, right? With Master Yi,
he's buffed up. He's got a discipline on
him essentially, and then you get that
hand information. So, there's just so
much happening with Scuttle Crab. And
we've seen Vex earlier today, put a stop
to Lilia, and there's so many other
things that Vex does like stopping these
new ambush units. Yeah. And as we're
seeing, some of the other cards and
their ranks fly through. Uh, notably,
one of the kind of patterns that I'm
seeing pop up is cards that are played
across multiple lists are obviously at
the top. Scuttle Crab played in decks
like Master Yi, but also played in
Ireelia, played even in Azir, as we just
saw. Vex Apathetic, same thing. Played
in Vex lists, played in Ireelia, uh,
played in the Draven lists sometimes in
the sideboard, etc., etc. But then after
that, it really starts to look like
Master Yi might be the most played in
the room because I saw cards like Pit
Rookie that had a high representation.
And while that is clearly a staple in
set [music] decks, for example, uh cards
like Pit Rookie have also been sneaking
into this mid-range Master Y. We saw it
perform incredibly well in Utre, so it
would not surprise me if it is very well
represented at this particular event as
well.
>> Yeah, I think you are absolutely right.
Now, let's take a look at the most used
spells of this weekend here in Hartford
and look at defy up top. Defy and
discipline followed by stack deck. What
can you say about defy? Just one of the
best counter spells in the game.
>> Yeah, it's again kind of the
meta-defining card in the fact that when
you're playing spells [music] or if
you're trying to have any sort of
interactability with your opponent, you
either have to play around defy or you
have to try to include answers that defy
does not hit. So earlier when we saw uh
the Teemo player using the winds
singingers instead of say the gusts,
yes, the winds singers have hidden. It's
the natural synergy, but also windser
gets around defy. Uh we've seen players
including more copies of long sword at
this event because long sword can't be
defied. We've seen, you know, going back
to Atlanta, the innovations that Prismat
brought with bringing the Rengar because
Rengar can't be defied. So this is a
card that even when you're not playing
it, it has an impact on the way you
approach the game. And it really is so
interesting you talked about Master Yi
and just looking through that top 10. So
many of those cards we find in Master Yi
because Master Yi just continues to be
so represented in this format. Could
this [music] be the weekend that Master
Yi uses these things like Defy and
Discipline to get through and actually
win a regional qualifier? Well, if
Master Yi is going to get the job done,
it will be on the back of staples like
that. But I am very intrigued by this
like rise in both performance and
popularity of Master Eyee simply because
it hasn't won the big one. We've seen it
perform well in China [music] and we've
seen it have great conversion rates like
an Utrect. Uh we've seen it crack the
top eight, but for all of that, Master
Yi as the legend here on uh the North
American side or in [music] Europe, no
regional qualifier wins. Yeah, we'll
have to see if that changes this
weekend. Let's take a look at the most
used gears. Now, we just had Azir. Let's
see how the gear looks. We've got Zona's
Hourglass as number one, Sprite Fountain
second, and we saw how good Sprite
Fountain is in multiple deck list now.
Yeah, this is [music] kind of not
surprising just because uh when we look
at the top three, but even further down,
right, uh I would go as far as like the
top six, a lot of these gear [music]
are either defining the deck that
they're in or they are the perfect gear
to supplement your game plan. [music]
Zony's Hourglass played in decks like
Ireelia, uh some versions of Master Yi
and so forth. Any of these decks, uh re
decks that we saw earlier on the
broadcast, we're also running it. any of
those decks where you want to [music]
get on a battlefield and hold, but also
where you're maybe playing a lot more
spells and interactabilities. So that
means less units. That means you want to
save the units you do have on the board.
Hourglass does that beautifully. Sprite
Fountain, we've already talked about the
impact of that. That's a card that is
helping a lot of these aggressive decks
get onto the battlefields faster as well
as allowing them to have retake options.
And then of course, Aurora is just the
buildaround.
>> It's It is the buildaround. And when you
get Aurora out on curve after you've
ramped with the mobilize or the catalyst
of AON, things could be trouble for your
opponent. We were actually talking
yesterday with some people in the venue
during the hot takes and one of the
questions was about Aurora and it was
very interesting to hear the responses.
One of the most popular things was
salvage. So salvage was a big answer and
that's what people talked about. But
that's going to wrap it up for gear.
Let's take a look at the overall meta
for this weekend here in Hartford.
>> All right, let's see if we were correct
in our assumptions. And yes, uh, Master
Yi Bladesman is the most represented
legend here with [music] 11% of the
meta, 185 in total. Now, here's the
thing. You say, okay, it's the most
played deck. It's the most represented.
But honestly, 11% is still a really low
percentage when you factor the number of
players here in Hartford. Yeah, that's
absolutely right. Anytime you have a
meta in a card game [music] where the
most represented deck is only around
10%, that is an extremely healthy meta
game. We love to see it. Is a pretty big
gap down to Diana, but again, Master Yi,
the reason why so many people are
playing Master Yi is because he's just
so consistent. It's not anything super
flashy. It's one of the easier decks to
pick up. It's very straightforward in
what it wants to do, but consistency is
key and ultimately a lot of card game
players, they want consistency.
>> Now, I think there are are some other
interesting storylines as we look at the
top eight most played decks. Uh at
fourth, we have Leblanc. This is a deck
that did [music] not make top eight in
Utre. And uh during your hot takes
segment earlier, many people said that
this might be the most uh overrated
deck. That's right.
>> Right. saying, "Okay, maybe it's not as
good as people think, but still the most
uh played, fourth most played, excuse
me." Uh the other things that I wanted
to point out, even though we're
transitioning a little bit down below,
uh is that there were more victors and
aris being played than Civer and that's
very surprising because typically Civer
and Dazzling Aurora decks have been very
popular here in North America. Yeah,
that was a really good call out that you
made and I think a lot of that has to do
with the best of situation because
players coming into this weekend really
hunting down those Origins best of
because they knew coming in this is the
last time they could get those
particular best of.s. So, I think that's
probably something to do with those
numbers as we look on down the list.
>> Yeah, and again kind of surprising to
see legends like Annie here. You know,
earlier I was talking to people about uh
whether or not you bring a deck because
of whom you might be competing with for
the best of. I think Annie is the poster
child for that. I think Annie is one of
the best decks in the format. But I also
think that because Prismat is so
proficient that it's actually scaring
people off of the list. Absolutely. I
mean, look, even Allen ZQ said he
believes that Prismat is the best player
in the game. And when you have someone
of Allen's caliber, a two-time regional
qualifier champion saying something like
that. Yeah, players are like, well, I
don't want to compete with this guy for
Annie. So, totally understand that. Now,
look at Volibear up here. We saw that
great run almost getting Volibear into
the top eight was Villionaire last
weekend in Utre. We'd love to see that
happen here this week. And then how
about Lux? interesting because we see
that infinite combo come out and a lot
of people were curious.
Was it going to be more popular? Was it
going to take more of a role in the
metag game and it doesn't look like it
has?
>> No, it was certainly not uh more
represented than really what we saw in
Utrect. It was in the 20s there as well.
Uh 24 players bringing it this time
around. Uh, another thing that I think
is worth noting as we're going through
these uh, lower representations, despite
the top eight in Utrect, Darius still
down at only 1.2%, [music]
20 total players in the room, set also
top eight in Utrect, only 20 total
players in the room. So, that is a very
interesting thing that their success did
not translate into more market share in
terms of representation. [music]
Yeah, it is a great point. And I think
with Set, very similar to the issue with
Annie, right? Because we know that Colin
has just been racking up the best ofves
with Set. The only one to make it to the
top eight in a regional qualifier with
Set. That's going to do it for round
five. But don't go anywhere cuz we've
got round six from Hartford coming up
next.
Hey everybody, Grenton here and I am
very fortunate to be joined with none
other than the dark child himself
technically, Prismaticism. How are you
feeling today?
>> Yeah, I'm feeling pretty good overall.
I'm two and two right now actually,
which is pretty bad, but I think I've
been playing very well today. Very clean
overall. It's just been very tiny
decisions that could have swung things
the other way.
>> Cool. Right on. And you just came back
from Utretch, right? And where you had a
top eight finish again. So, walk us
through how that kind of event went for
you.
>> Yeah, it went pretty well overall. The
first five rounds I was playing really
well and then I think I got a bit too
happy with myself and then lost a bit of
focus and then lost in round six and
then played pretty sloppy the rest of
the day. I could have easily ended up
five and three in that event. It was uh
not great. Um but managed to crawl my
way back and then I lost to Colin on
stream. Also misplayed in that match but
had amazing tiebreers. Ended up being
the one X and two player that made it
into top eight and then Squirtle rolled
me instantly. So still a pretty good
showing. That's my first top eight bait
in set three actually because I I missed
in missed on tiebreakers in Vancouver at
X and 2 and then Sydney got paired
against Allen last round. So, and so
you've been obviously on Annie since
almost the beginning of time. Uh, right.
So, there's a couple pioneers of the
Annie deck list that you know have been
circulating and stuff like that. So,
walk me through a little bit how your
prep has changed from Origins to Spirit
Forge to now unleashed. We're in our
last regional now for Unleashed, right?
So this is kind of where you're going to
get the most amount of information for
set three before we go into vendetta. So
how does your kind of thought process
when you approach these events change
cuz everybody just assumes oh yeah
prismaticism is going to be on Annie. So
how do you kind of prepare for these big
events?
>> Yeah. So I think there's a shift from
early set into later set where early set
there's it's a pretty big jungle meta
decks maybe there are decks that people
have an idea these are pretty good these
might be the best decks but there's no
deck list established for them anything
like that. Whereas now you get late in
the meta, people are really committed
onto one legend. You know what the meta
is going to be. You know there's going
to be Master Yi, Aurelia, Diana, and
like Aurora. Those are going to be the
big ones. And like Vex has dropped off a
cliff where she was very big in the meta
early on. Um and then you get familiar
with the deck lists. People are playing
the same deck list within a few cards of
each other. So you can really prep
against that overall. Uh and then with
Annie, I think I'm just just be the
better player. Just try to be the better
player. I don't haven't made too many
changes to the deck. I've made a few
tweaks. Um, but overall it's like people
can copy my deck from early in the set
and it's pretty pretty much the same
same deck and then just have to perform
better.
>> Yeah. So, when you're preparing for a
new set, when you're looking at like
spoiler season when all the cards are
out, you think you're pretty comfortable
at like finding almost the optimal kind
of 40 cards, getting that all set up,
and then you tweak throughout the the
>> Yeah, I I think once I pick a deck, then
I can start optimizing it pretty
quickly. But I have difficulty picking a
deck. Like I think every single time
it's been within two weeks of an event
that I've actually settled on a deck and
been like, "Okay, this is the deck. I'm
going to actually start really working
on it, going in depth with it." Um, but
once I do, then I I think I get pretty
far in a short amount of time.
>> Yeah. Right. I mean, we've we've seen
you put up results very consistently and
obviously this, like you mentioned, the
meta kind of shifts and we now have an
established in air quotes meta for
Unleashed where we know that there's
some decks that are powerful. There's
some decks that are pretty sleeper as
well. You know, like not a lot of people
in North America at least play Azir,
right? but it's a very real deck and a
very competitive deck in the European
region. So, I'm curious, are there any
kind of matchups that you're hoping to
avoid this weekend or any matchups that
you're like, "Yes, please give me like
13 rounds of just this."
>> Yeah, and 13 rounds of Victor, I'd be
undefeated guaranteed. That was one of
the most one-sided matchups in Utract.
And it's it should have been even more
one-sided probably like maybe a 9010
matchup. Something insane.
>> Uh I think Ye is pretty difficult. It
It's a bit die roll based. I think in
general Annie is a deck that does a lot
better going first, but is also pretty
playable when going second. Uh I think
Azir is also pretty tough where they
they're able to keep up the fight early
game, keep up tempo early game while
also having a better late game overall
late game win conditions. Um after that,
like Diana's kind of annoying if the
Diana player is good, like very good,
then it can be a tough matchup. Um but
other than that, I think I can just take
anything. Like I don't have any bad
matchups. I think even even if I say
there's a player equal skill level to me
on Yi or on Azir, it's still probably
60/40.
>> Okay.
>> And and then compared to other decks
like the Diana has some very bad
matchups against like Kai'Sa or other
removal decks can have have a lot more
trouble. Um so it's like I'm not too
scared going into any matchup.
>> Yeah. And I think that kind of
highlights not only obviously your skill
as a as a TCG player, but something that
I think that is not touched on enough is
really hunkering down on one legend and
just becoming the master of that legend,
right? We've seen it with, you know,
other players like Colin on set, you on
Annie, right? Uh, you know, Villionaire
on Volibear. These are just people who
have really mastered their craft. So,
what kind of advice can you give people
cuz obviously this IP there's a lot of
fan favorites. People will be like, "Oh,
I love Teemo or I love Jyn." How do you
kind of approach where your deck might
not be tier one? Yeah.
>> But what kind of tips can you give
players to really like hunker down and
focus on a deck? I You can keep in mind
with the best of system that you don't
need to be the best deck in the room or
even the best player in the room. you
just have to be the best player on your
legend specifically. So, and I picked
Legends. Um, every single one that I
picked is a deck that I I feel like I
can top eight with, that I can be very
competitive with. Probably don't don't
have any bad matchups or very few of
them. Um, but it's also a deck other
than Miracle Draven that's been off
meta, more on the fringe, not the the
main focus at least. It maybe uh like
secondary focus of the of the meta game.
And then that's where there's less
people I'm comp competing with, so it's
overall a better chance for me to
outperform as a player.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you so much,
Prismaticism. Uh, before we wrap things
up, where can people find you?
>> Yeah, people can find me on Twitter and
Metify, uh, various versions of
prismaticism or prismaticism. And then
I've also got a Twitch,
twitch.tv/prismat.
I'm going to get back into that in July
after all these events are done. It's
been busy month. And yeah,
>> thank you so much. Good luck. Thank you.
Cheers.
>> [music]
>> One of the many stops that you can come
to here at RQ Hartford is, of course,
the merch store. Now, there are plenty
of items here that you want to be able
to pick up while you're here in
Hartford, but they continue to be at
every regional qualifier, and this
includes Riftbound merch itself,
playmats, sleeves, and of course, even
some booster box product as well as some
champion decks. But that is just the
start for you to begin your Riftbound
journey. If you're here at one of the
regional qualifiers, you can also pick
up some exclusive Riot merch, including
plushies, statues, and even some acrylic
stance to represent your favorite
legend,
Josh Schneider, here at the Hartford
Regional, and we've got a fantastic
cosplayer here. We've got Pike. Would
you like to introduce yourself?
>> Yeah, so my name is Mar. I'm also known
as Cobalt Cosplay. I've been cosplaying
for about 13 years and uh League of
Legends is a huge part of my entire
experience cosplaying.
>> Well, that is awesome. This looks great.
Now, I got to ask, did you make this
outfit here?
>> Yes, it is 100% made by me. Um, it's a
full competition piece, so I feature all
different kinds of techniques from
leather work to fabric dying to chain
mail to 3D printing, 3D modeling,
fabric. You name it, it's probably in
this costume. Wow. So, you you've done
it all here. Um, now this looks like
it's it's kind of heavy. Like, is this
is it uncomfortable to walk around in?
>> Honestly, I'm very mobile. The most
weight is in the shoulders just because
there are some electronics in there. For
the most part, I have mobility in my
legs and my arms. Uh, you know, he's
designed like an assassin, so it it
proves helpful in real life for
movement. So,
>> okay, that's awesome. Now, do you get
hot in this in this here? [laughter]
>> Yeah. So, it's mostly my face just from
being closed in here, but body-wise,
it's not terrible. I I've survived many
hours in this costume before. So,
>> I heard that you guys did a special
photo shoot today. Could you tell us
about that? Yeah. So, we actually went
out on the stairs in the convention
center and we had all all five of the
cosplayers uh arranged in a really
beautiful formation and they took some
some video shots, some photo shots of
us, a really cinematic, beautiful
pictures. Um, we went outside on the
grass to get some like sunlight and they
did kind of a pan through of all the
cosplayers doing their poses. Uh, it was
really awesome.
>> That's awesome. Well, Mara, thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
interview. Looks fantastic. Appreciate
all the work you do for us.
>> Thank you so much.
>> And we'll bring it back to you.
>> Back to you. Back to me. I'm not sure.
Anyways, we've got three more rounds to
go here in day one at the Hartford
Regional Qualifier. I'm Josh Schneider.
I'm joined by Charmer. We just saw an
interesting couple of matches in round
six and I can't wait to see what's in
store for us here. No, in round five.
Can't wait to see what's in store in
round six.
>> Yeah, you're just so excited for round
six that it is on the tip of your
tongue, escaping your brain and and
that's okay. But you are correct. We did
see some great matchups to end round
five. Of course, we get to see Cactus
King on that Azir in full suit. Talk
about not only the victory they had, but
also the victory earlier in the day
against Dewali. And hopefully we will
continue to see some of these fresh
faces do well. Yes, there are some
storied players in Riftbound and we're
keeping an eye on them, but we also like
to see upandcomers find that early
success in their career maybe at their
first regional qualifier like Cactus
King was talking about.
>> Yeah, absolutely. If you haven't been to
a regional qualifier, you've got to try
to get to one of these events because a
little time of practice, a little
testing, and you too could be at the
qualifier and raise that trophy or at
least go for those best of. There's so
many best of to go for. And I think
that's really the centerpiece for a lot
of people is that best of prizing. It's
so unique to Riftbound
and the players just rave about it.
Well, I'm also just going to go ahead
and say if you are wanting to go to a
regional qualifier, but maybe you're
intimidated by the main event, there are
fantastic side events all weekend long.
There's a wonderful 2v2 event. 2v2 is my
favorite way to play the game. There are
also things to see like the cosplayers
that we've been featuring. There's merch
to pick up. So, uh, even if the main
event is a little bit intimidating or
you don't feel, even though I believe in
you, if you don't feel like you can win
a best of or you don't want to go
through all of that, come to one of
these regional qualifiers. It is a
wonderful time.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Now, Charmer, are you
ready to see what we are going to be
featuring here in round six?
>> Of course I am. I I'm excited to talk
about the possibilities.
>> Let's see it.
All right. Now, actually, we're not
going to see it. We're going to let you
vote,
>> right?
>> Ezreal versus Ezreal. [laughter]
>> All right.
>> Or Ivvern versus Pike. [music]
We'll throw it to you. You vote and
that's what we'll feature. Yeah. If you
are watching us live in the chat, you
get to vote A or B for the match you
want to see. And uh I didn't want to
throw my bias in, but I think it's hard
to turn down this Mr. Rays versus
[music] Senbon matchup because Ivvern
the Greenfather is a deck that uh I am
now a believer in thanks to uh Boulevard
who got [music] the best of Ivvern in uh
a previous event uh at Vancouver and I
saw him playing it. I was like, "Hey, I
like that list." But also, one of the
things when we were talking about the
meta [music]
uh representation is there's a lot of
players in the room on Pike, like almost
a surprising amount. So, I want to see
what this pike list is all about and how
it can potentially play into Ivvern
because cards like the signature spell
death from below have a lot of value
into Ivvern.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Because Ivvern is
going to be playing a lot of units that
have less might to try and get the bird,
cat, dog, and porro online and that
could be very interesting. But there was
a lot of answers yesterday as one of the
slept on legends was Ivvern. So, we get
to see that now here in round six how
that goes. And I think we are ready to
get down to the feature table and let's
let's see how this shakes out. Nope.
Nope. Sorry. Voice is in my head or
saying deck list first. Let's take a
look at the deck. We're going to take a
look. Uh and I think this is important
to look at because you learn a lot about
what the Ivvern player is trying to
accomplish when you look at the chosen
champion. So because they are going with
nurturer, this means that they are
trying to find the items to kind of
assemble the pieces with nurturer as
opposed to going with the order domain
version of Ivvern where you're trying to
focus on uh as you pointed out the dogs,
the cats, the [music] porros, etc. the
birds. I love the birds. Uh, another
thing that this tells you is this is a
list uh, as I look at it that is not
really trying to do anything fancy other
than just play a lot of might and get
uh, some advantages with the bush,
right? You see a lot of the units that
are going to [music] get some additional
value from those bush tokens that are
created and then you're going to back it
up with cards like friendship.
>> Yeah. Well, friendship is a very scary
buff spell when you start getting
multiple of these tags in play because
if you can get four plus four might for
one energy is pretty crazy. And
something else I love to see in this
deck is that flurry of feathers charmer,
it could be a counter spell, but it can
also flood the board with the bird
tokens. Yeah. And because this occurs at
reaction speed, you can do so where
you're using it to reinforce potentially
uh as you had pointed out, uh you
[music] can play the four bird tokens.
And if that is at a bush where they're
getting that plus one might because it
kind of becomes a one-sided trifarian
war [music] camp, uh this represents at
burst speed potentially reinforcing a
site with eight additional might. So
it's a great spell to highlight.
>> Absolutely. I think
>> for reaction, not burst. You are
correct.
>> Oh, [laughter] no. You're good. Voice.
>> There we go. Ivvern, going to be
exciting to see. Let's check out the
pike deck.
>> All right. So, this pike list is one
that I'm very intrigued by. Very excited
to see what they're doing. And uh I was
wondering if we were going to be seeing
this as a bewitching spirit list. And
that is the case. So, if you are not
familiar with how this works, Bewitching
Spirit is a card that when you play it,
you can choose a player and they discard
a card. This paired with the legend
ability on the Blood Harbor Ripper or
paired with cards like Pack of Wonders
means that you can play it, bounce it
back to your hand, and then replay
[music] it and rinse and repeat and
really just kind of rip the resources
from your opponent's hand over and over
and over. And we saw [music] this
earlier when Pike was going against Lee
Sin. It was an Aurora Lein deck and Pike
got that combo online where you were
constantly recycling the Bewitching
Spirits and just completely shredded the
opponent's hand. So, if you're able to
get that online while also controlling
the board with things like the Falling
Star, the Star Cross, and the Void
Seeker, controlling the board, you're
taking out their hand. This really is a
very interesting iteration of a more
controloriented build. Well, the other
thing that I want to point out in
particular is of course Fizz. Fizz has
been a very powerful card since it was
released, but it's even more powerful
when you have so many ways to return
[music] Fizz to your hand. So again,
legend ability or pack of wonders allows
you to replay Fizz, which replays stuff
from your trash. Rinse and repeat is the
name of the game.
All right, we are ready to go and send
it down to the feature area. Round six
here in Hartford.
The energy in the room electric as we
close in towards the end [music] of the
day as players look for a spot in day
two.
Need to get at least 18 points. You're
looking to get six wins on the day.
>> I've played so many card games. All
right, the players here having a brief
chat about the card games they've
played.
Seems like it's a lot. I can certainly
uh empathize and sympathize with that as
somebody who is uh very old and has
played a lot of card games.
I think one of the things to highlight
as we get ready to jump into this is
potential strategies. If you suspect
that Senbon is on this pack of wonders
combo with the bewitching spirit, what
Mr. Ray is likely looking to do is
develop some presence early and we do
see that but then also I would not be
surprised if we see something like ultra
soft porro become a priority in the late
game. It
>> is worth noting we are playing to nine
points this game. We have the aspirants
climb
>> or not. So that's the other thing that's
very interesting with Ivvern is uh it's
nine by default with aspirin climb.
However, if you want to brush something
like we're seeing now, then that takes
it down to eight points instead.
>> I have a feeling this could shift
multiple times throughout this game as
the first point goes to Mr. Rays with
the mutated Mouser
>> and we have the Crimson Pigeons coming
out as well in the back line.
>> I'll pass you.
>> And I like this play from Mr. raise. Not
even trying to be koi with like, oh, I
can overwrite this later. Uh, you're
just saying to your opponent, I know you
want the game to go late. Part of the
reason that I think Sunbon starts with
Aspirin's Climb is you want to give
yourself time to find your combo, find
the ways to strip your opponent's hand.
And so, if the game goes to nine instead
of eight, you get more opportunities to
do so. But also, Mr. Rays is generating
that bush early, which is of course
providing the additional might to
whatever units are there. In this case,
it's the Mouser. Uh, and suddenly that
is big enough to repel or at least trade
even with that Knox hopeful despite it
being such a powerful turn one play.
Shinbon doing some digging on this turn.
The Scrier's Bloom predicting two and
then drawing
that came down on the first turn
alongside of the Noxis hopeful and the
stack deck as well. Now we see the list
as cat is called.
>> So it's negative right now. So, the cat,
the mouser getting a minus two
>> might.
>> Now, this is something that we didn't
highlight when we were talking through
the list, but of all of the matchups,
this might be the one where the list
matters the most. If you're not
familiar, we just flew the card up, but
it allows you to name a tag for units
and then when you exhaust it, you can
give a unit with that tag minus two
might. We heard Senbon call cat. So any
cats that are out there, the list can
give it minus two might. And because
Ivvern in particular cares about unit
tags, this is super relevant because you
know there's going to be a bunch of them
in the deck.
>> That's absolutely right. Sinbon getting
on the board as well with the Noxis
hopeful hiding a card there at Aspirants
Climb. It is back to Aspirants Climb.
The Brush Battlefield
>> switched back currently. I believe that
was a face up hide of the pike legend
from the champion zone.
>> So, uh it is known information, but that
also is very scary for Mr. Rays because
that means, you know, you have to
essentially go over eight might. Uh it's
four for the hopeful, two for the pike,
and then if they pay the power, that's
two more. That's too steep for Mr. Rays.
So, Wisely looks like going to go to the
other location, but still develops the
bush as well.
And Mr. Rays will score up to two with
the pigeons.
See if Mr. Rays will further develop on
this turn
from the brush, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And the judge just putting that die out
there saying, "Hey, this gets the plus
one from the bush." So representing that
with the die, that's going to be the
same for the mouser as well as the bird
token because uh again the brush gives
plus one might to birds, cats,
dogs, poros.
>> That's right. All the critters. All the
critters buffed up as the frisky hunter
coming down onto
the brush battlefield bringing a bird
token along with it.
>> Sen holding up to two
>> four
>> does have a pack of wonders down.
Could potentially see that pack plus
trove combo coming up in the near
future.
Well, the interesting thing is you could
also in this scenario if you wanted use
the pack on your uh copy of the list
replay it because it would enter ready
just name either the same thing or
something different and then also
reactivate the list. So that's one of
the nice things about running a card
like the list even if you're not running
into Ivverns all day long because you
can use pack of wonders to just name a
different tag. It's a a very versatile
combo. It's not just wonders and
bewitching spirit. There is a lot of
things that you want to return to hand
and reuse and we're seeing that now.
>> Yep. Absolutely. So, the falling star
taking out the frisky hunter and the
list being used once again to name bird
this time.
So, the pigeons
killed as well.
>> Pick this up. We do see the Pike chosen
champion flipped face up there and then
return back to hand. Knox is hopeful
will retreat back to base.
And this is just a move where Sunbun's
trying to set up for a future retake
style turn. Uh, one of the things that
you do is you return all your units back
to your base. You put your chosen
champion back in your hand so that you
can potentially rehide it when you get
to another spot. But even if you don't
rehide it, you can play it for three
energy. And then if you do have uh the
red power, the fury power, then you can
also kind of give it pseudo accelerate.
It would enter ready. Uh the thing is is
while Senbon does not have fury runes,
currently set, they do currently have
that gold token generated from their
legend ability. So still would have the
option to pay for it one way or the
other.
>> Mr. Rays able to hold up to three.
>> What a run so far for Mr. Rays with
Ivvern.
Undefeated through five rounds
looking to send Ivan into day two. Here
comes the chosen champion.
The Nurturer into play as Ray looks at
the top three cards of the deck and
finds a porro. It's the ultra soft
porro.
>> So now gets to buff one of those
friendly units.
And this is the unit that I was talking
about earlier where uh if you're trying
to avoid the bewitching spirit combo,
you can use something like ultra soft
porro to generate a bunch of might in
the late game. Uh you do have to get it
on a battlefield and then start
utilizing it each turn. But because it
has five might itself and because by
that stage of the game you usually have
a lot of ways to protect it, it is a
>> pretty easy way to generate a bunch of
bird tokens and then of course those
bird tokens get buffs when they go into
your brush and so on and so forth.
>> Absolutely.
The daring porro developed for Mr. Rays
as well. Back over to Sinbon.
Hopeful is the lone unit in play
currently for Sinbon. did bring down the
treasure trove at the end of his last
turn. So, we do have pack plus trove in
play, which means
>> go for
>> could be a card and an extra rune each
turn.
>> Four versus two
>> and you pass focus.
>> Yeah, I was highlighting earlier the
ability to bounce the list back to your
hand and then reuse that, but you're
absolutely correct. You can do the same
thing with treasure trove because it
just says when it leaves play does not
have to hit the trash. So returning into
your hand does still let you draw the
card and channel that exhausted rune,
>> but Noxus hopeful does get the job done
here. Crash in. If you're Sunbond, you
like that you still have all of your
runes available because you're going to
want to follow that up with likely
developing more might at least in the
base. Uh you don't have a lot of hold
options in hand unless you want to hide
the pike and then also keep a combat
trick. But uh developing might safely in
base and then setting yourself up for
another retake the following turn would
also make sense.
>> Can we see Fizz here?
>> Oh,
so utilizing the gold to uh mitigate
some of the power costs, but we're going
to use Fizz on the Falling Star.
>> So that takes out Mr. Ray's chosen
champion.
>> Yep.
>> Very strong play here.
take away that potential card advantage.
>> And now we're kind of seeing the power
of this pike list on display once the
pack of wonders is active. You have so
many juicy targets for it. We saw it use
uh used on the trove here. Again, draws
a card, channels a rune earlier. We saw
it used on the list which allowed a
double activation in a single turn. And
now that Fizz is available, you can also
potentially start looping Fizz with your
legend ability or um you know with the
pack of wonders and then you've got the
stacked deck still in the trash, but any
other spells that you're playing for the
rest of the game are also going to be
targetable by Fizz. We did see the deck
list earlier and pretty much everything
that's in the list uh is hitable. And
it's very clear that Sinbon doesn't want
to just give any of these units up for
free. We saw the Noxis Hopeful being
returned back to Sinbon's hand with the
legend ability, generating another gold
token, and then just replaying it for
two energy in the backline. [snorts]
Pike's very good again about getting
into those battlefields and then getting
out with that Pike ability and then
getting extra value
as Mr. Rays conquers up to four once
again. The aspirants climbs currently
covered up by a brush of battlefield
token.
So up to four and currently only needs
eight. Uh that is going to be I think a
difficult thing for Senbon to navigate
when we get closer to uh when the game
would close out because the reality is
the benefit of the brush is really in
the hands of Mr. rays. If the brush is
not available, Sunbond has to play to
nine, but still has to treat Mr. Rays as
only going to eight on any given turn.
So, that is something that you'll have
to keep an eye out for as we get closer
to that stage of the game. But, right
now, we just have four points on the
side of Mr. Ray, three on Sunbond. So,
we're kind of in the that middle phase
of game one.
>> Mr. Rays just using a development turn
here. Playing the frisky hunter in that
stalwart porro in the back line.
Now let's see what Sinbon has for us
here. Has developed a nice board. Has
plenty of options with this pack of
wonders.
>> Void. This
>> going to pop a gold generate a power and
it is the void seeker
>> attempting to take out this daring porro
at the battlefield.
>> Yeah, there is a defy available in the
hand of Mr. rays that could be used to
counter spell this. I think one of the
things that you're thinking about if
you're Mr. Ray though is even if it's
counter spelled then you still have to
worry about that Fizz turning around and
going back to hand and replaying the
same void seeker. So Mr. Ray opting
instead to just allow that to go
through.
And now just
using the pack of wonders plus treasure
trove shenanigans to get that extra card
and the rune
has two more runes to work with.
Contemplating a second pack of wonders.
That is the call for Sinbon.
>> Conquer.
>> Yep.
>> Battlefields are open. Fizz moving in.
>> Pick this up. We're back to Aspirin's
climb as Sinbon gets an extra point.
>> Yeah, and that second pack of wonders
was played specifically to pick up the
Fizz. So, it gets the conquer point.
Goes back to the safety of Senbon's
hand. And that's because of the ability
to use it for cards like the Void Seeker
in stack deck. And you see Mr. Ray's
asking to see it now, thinking the same
thing that I was just talking about.
Okay, this Fizz is a problem. What can
it get?
Yeah, that Fizz replaying the void
seeker
>> could take out any of the units
currently in play for Mr. Rays if they
are at a battlefield.
We talked about it at the start of this
match. These Ivvern decks generally have
a lot of low might units in play with
the bird, cat, dogs, and porros. The
star porro moves into aspirin's climb up
to five goes Mr. raise and
>> conquer the northern battlefield as
well.
>> Six to four and currently Aspirit's
climb is covered up.
Yeah. And so this is the important stage
of the game because uh again going
forward a double conquer from Mr. Rays
does represent winning the game.
However, Senbon,
unless they have a situation where they
somehow double conquer and leave the
brush, right, you run into a situation
where
>> if you leave the brush, your opponent
gets bonus might coming back in to
retake it. But if you get rid of the
brush, then you're also not any closer
to winning where they stay uh in the
same striking range, right? So, it's
kind of a tough choice to make at times
because there is an incentive to maybe
leave the brush if you think that you
can get to eight. It's just usually not
the right call.
>> And Mr. Rays setting up a hold here at
the brush.
Each of these units getting plus one
might. There's some birds there. Well,
just one bird. There's a cat and there's
a couple porros. That's a lot of might.
Mr. Ray is going to hide a card there as
well.
>> Now, if you're Sunbond and you see that
hidden card, you're probably thinking
something like perhaps a back off. Um,
could also maybe be like an Emperor's
Divide. We'll see how Sunbond navigates
this particular turn. This is a lot of
might. It's technically even more might
on defense because of the presence of
those stalwart porros. They do have the
shield keyword, so they get the
additional might when defending.
And now we see Sunban go into the deep
thought. Hand on head, deep sigh, trying
to do the math. Is this something that I
can break through?
>> Just be able to see the
>> Yeah, right now there is 12 might at
that southern battlefield for Mr. Rays,
but as you called out, that would
quickly go up to 14 on defense
because of those two porros.
If nothing else, Sinbon does have to
take Mr. Rays off at least one of these
battlefields because Aspirin's climb is
covered up. So, we are currently just
playing to eight points
>> as the Fizz comes down.
>> Yep.
>> Going to play the stacked deck. Let's
see what he finds. Another stack deck.
He grabs the falling star right away.
>> Yeah, that was a snap choice. And that
makes sense. There's a lot of runes
available to Senbomb right now. And this
falling star represents at least one
activation, if not two. But most
importantly, it represents something
that is not stopped by defy.
>> And it is going to be targeting both of
the stalwart poros
that are extra mighty on defense.
There's three cards in hand for Mr.
Rays. Does he have anything to react
again? Defy not an option to the falling
star. I did see the hand. There is a
Defy. Obviously not an option, but one
of the other options available is Flurry
of Feathers. Doesn't have to be played
right now, but there is a situation
where if Senbon goes into this combat
and you play the Flurry, just like we
talked about before, that represents
eight might that just magically appears
on this brush in defense. We'll see if
Senbon takes the bait here or
understands that the four energy up
represents a potential eight might from
Mr. Ray.
>> I would not be surprised at all if Mr.
Rays has stole some games that way so
far on his way to a undefeated run
through the first five rounds here in
the Hartford regional qualifier.
Now, if you want to be conservative on
the side of Senbon, a lot of options
available with double pack of wonders.
You could use one to bounce the Fizz and
then play another Falling Star. Or if
you don't want to commit that much
power, you could also play that Void
Seeker. We're also about to see a cleave
come down and then you could bounce and
replay the cleave from the Fizz. There's
also that list there. We're going to see
that activated on the bird and that
could be returned and replayed.
>> So at the moment it's one activation of
list
>> and then the attack
seven might coming in with the Nox is
hopeful.
>> I have a feeling we're going to see a
flock of birds. Are
>> we going to see it? It is seven versus
four,
>> but
>> with a plus eight, that's suddenly a lot
of might to get over. And because you're
now in a showdown, you don't have to
worry about any pack of wonders uh
interactions. You would only be worried
about what would be coming from the hand
of Senbon.
>> Here comes the flurry.
>> The flurry. The flock of birds incoming
to the brush. That is eight total might
represented. They're all getting the
additional plus one.
>> Sinbon goes, "Oh no,
>> you have not what I expected."
>> One, two. Okay.
>> And so going to take out three units,
the cats and two birds
with the damage assigned from the
hopeful. And Mr. Rays still sitting with
six might on the brush because of the
flurry. I feel like when you play furry
uh flurry, excuse me, it should be
required for you to say caw four times.
Like every time you put the bird down,
you say caw caw. I feel like that is on
the the implied text of the card.
>> I am totally okay with that charm.
[laughter]
I think the fans at home would be as
well. Be entertaining for sure.
All right, here comes Fizz after an
unsuccessful
>> attempt to get that battlefield.
>> All right, this is a lot of runes
recycled.
>> Wow.
>> Now, if you're wondering why so many got
recycled, it's because one for the Fizz,
two for the falling star, plus one for
the deflect on the bird.
>> Uh this is still potentially worth it if
you need to slow things down because as
we pointed out before, uh Mr. Rays is
just playing to eight with that brush
covering up Aspirin's climb and they're
going to be holding to seven here. Uh so
Sunbon essentially had to recycle all of
those runes to prevent the win.
>> Absolutely crazy. Sinbon down to just
two runes and he is going to scoop it
up. Mr. Rays on Ivvern with Aspirin's
climb covered up.
>> I know. I love it.
>> Unreal. It's nice not having to worry
about that. [laughter]
>> And you just heard Mr. Ray say that it's
nice not having to worry about that.
Specifically referring to aspirin's
climb. That's the nice thing about
Ivvern. Aspirin's climb is not real and
cannot hurt you. Uh you said it was a
scoop. I would like to point out it was
only a scoop because Mr. Ace showed that
he had the win. So the play there
because you have the presence on the
battlefield is you uh play the Emperor's
Divide that was hidden because your
units are ready and they return to base
from the Emperors. and you can just send
them to the other side. There was no
resources available for Senbon to stop
it. So, uh, very nice game one win from
Mr. Rays on Ivvern of all legends.
>> Getting it done with Ivvern so far. It
is worth pointing out both of these
players have finished in the top 64 of a
regional qualifier
>> in the past. So they do have their
regional championship invites, but
looking to go even further this weekend.
Sinbon starting things out in game two
with Pack of Wonders. Sending it back
over to Mr. Rays.
It is Frozen Fortress Battlefield of
Choice for Sinbon and Vile's Lair.
>> I'll kill it
>> for Mr. Rays as the disarming rate comes
out right away taking out the early pack
of wonders for Senbon.
>> Discard a card.
>> All right. And so the answer from that
is going to be a fast play of Bewitching
Spirit from Senbon. We really didn't see
the Bewitching Spirit factor into game
one. We saw double pack of wonders. We
saw a lot of replaying the same cards to
get those abilities. Uh working in the
favor of Senbon, but Bewitching Spirit
to kind of play that attrition game was
MIA this time around utilized very
early. And uh this is actually
important. I just want to highlight
right now Mr. Ace has no calm runes did
whiff after using the one recycle on the
rake uh in the early play. So we're
going to see a porro developed and then
a pass.
But if you're Senbon, you know, right
now you're not having to worry about
cards like Defy and that gives you a big
window of opportunity here.
Back over to Senbon.
Mr. Ray getting on the board early. Oh,
so not only is there a falling star, but
I believe brought in from the sideboard
is a piercing light.
>> Piercing light
>> that is going to hit both of those
units.
>> And you're not repeating, right?
>> I'm not repeating.
>> So
>> just two might for the rake. So it'd be
enough to take out both. There is a
situation where even though you don't
have defy up, uh something like
friendship would save at least one of
them or some other might buff like a
discipline. And we do see that come down
>> and that's why Mr. Race was asking
whether or not it was going to be
repeated.
>> But again,
>> oh the list, the list coming out. It
didn't matter that he didn't repeat it.
The discipline saves the porro, but list
finishes it off anyways.
And Senbon gets on the board with the
spirit one all.
>> What a followup there.
>> And to close that turn out, we did see
Senbon use the legend ability of Blood
Harbor Ripper to return the Spirit to
hand, make that gold. Uh, I feel like
Sunbound is going to prioritize playing
Bewitching Spirit a bit more this game
just because there were so many surprise
plays like that flurry in game one that
if the hand was stripped might not have
been as much of a concern. Uh, it also
just might be something where your hand
is dictating it, right? The last time
around you had the pack of wonders combo
early. This time it was ragged. The last
time around you also had uh spells with
Fizz. This time Fizz is MIA. So, why not
focus on the spirit? It's the best thing
you can be doing anyway.
>> Absolutely. Just need to get that
battlefield to a or get the spirit to a
battlefield, I should say, to keep that
loop going with the Pike Legend and
having another unit in play.
>> Traveling merchant.
>> Uh oh, sorry. So, you'reing first.
>> Sorry. Okay. So, you're at two.
>> Going up conquering to two Sbond. I did
notice a card brought in from the
sideboard and we know that because it
was not in the main deck when we talked
about it. Uh and that is that death from
below that signature spell from Pike. So
was not played in the main deck because
it's not targetable by Fizz. But when
you run into a deck like Ivvern, being
able to play it once and then
potentially just pay a power to play it
over and over and over again and kill
multiple units is incredibly powerful.
Uh in this matchup, it's actually kind
of a nightmare for Mr. Ray. So, the one
thing to keep an eye out is uh windows
of opportunity because death from below
is defiable.
>> It's a great point,
>> but bewitching spirit. The game plan
right now bounced back to hand with Pike
replayed. We see Vi discarded from Mr.
Rays.
>> Chosen Champion will be hidden next to
the traveling merchant for Sinbon at
that northern battlefield. Turn player,
please finish your turn. Three
additional.
>> All right.
>> I was just going to say this is exactly
the power of looping the bewitching
spirit because the decision that Mr.
Rays was forced to make that last turn
was do I discard vi peacekeeper arguably
the most powerful unit to come from
unleashed or do I hold on to defy which
is the meta-defining most played card in
the room. You want to hold on to both.
You can only save one. did opt to save
the defy, but that means you've got a
little bit less might to work with this
turn because the the VI as an ambush
play after you attack in is now off the
table for Mr. Rays.
Mr. Ray is a tough spot right now is
what he finds himself in
>> as lost point tempo. The bewitching
spirit online I base. Sure.
Here comes the nurturer. Mr. Ray is
looking for a unit within the top three
cards finding the ultra soft porro.
>> And again, this is a card that I really
likes in the late game because if you
can get it on a battlefield and get even
just one or two activations from it, you
can generate a lot of might in your base
to set up for retakes. Uh you could
generate a lot of might on an existing
brush to make the holds that much easier
for you. Uh, I also like that pickup.
The only other choice from that Ivvern
that you might have considered uh was
not an actual card you could choose from
Ivvern, which would have been the not so
fast. So,
it's an easy pickup.
>> Discipline on the Frisky Hunter. That's
five might plus two might with the bird.
And Mr. Rays knows the hidden card is
Pike, which could only represent up to
four might.
>> Six versus seven. I'll collect that.
Sure.
>> So, six might for Sinbon and he will
lose the battlefield here taking out the
frisky hunter in the process. But we get
a brush
>> in replace of that northern battlefield.
>> Damn, we are even in points.
>> That's also important because now that
bird token is bigger than a bewitching
spirit because of the plus one might
from the brush, but also because this
bird has hit the gym, is getting swole,
has that buff token. Uh it's now holding
down the fort on that side. Uh the one
downside for Mr. Rays though, you only
have one rune available. You can't
really stop the spirit from walking onto
the other battlefield and that will open
up the ability to return Bewitching
Spirit to the Hand of Senbon with the
legend ability.
>> Gustless.
>> Here comes Gust. Have to
>> pay the deflect cost.
>> It's a three.
>> Let's see if Mr. Rays reacts here. We
know that Defy is in hand. One ready
rune for Mr. Rays. And it looks like he
is going to bring out the Defy.
Countering Gus.
And now the Bewitching Spirit to the
Southern Battlefield. Up to three goes
Sinbun.
And that Bewitching Spirit returned to
hand with the Pike Legend ability.
Another gold created.
>> Now, one of the reasons that I think Mr.
paused so long on that defy uh is one
there was the second one in hand but
also you know bewitching spirit is
likely going to be played again that
turn. So if you use the first defy on
the gust then you have to say okay am I
keeping the second one or am I giving up
the other card in my hand which we saw
after right that was the ultra soft
porro you want to get that developed uh
we did see Mr. raise opt to use one defy
and then kind of just give up the other
one. But it was not an easy decision to
make. And again, that's kind of the
power of looping this bewitching spirit.
One of the things Mr. Rays could do to
combat this is just generate additional
point tempo early. Sen's not really uh
racing things. They're just trying to
slow things down at the moment. So that
does work in Mr. Ra's favor, especially
if they can stick this ultra soft on
this turn.
Also worth noting that Sinbon was able
to kill that chosen champion for Mr.
Rays on the back line that last turn. So
that extra card advantage that Mr. Rays
was picking up
taken away here as he puts the ultra
soft porro down onto the northern
battlefield reinforcing
>> and going to play out his hand here. The
stalwart porro the last card in hand.
The bird comes back to base passing back
over to Sinbon with no cards in hand.
>> And a bit of might at that northern
battlefield.
>> Here it is. The chosen signature spell.
>> Death from below.
>> The kill unit with three or less might.
You can play again for your trash for a
power gold plus a purple share.
>> So he is going to wipe that northern
battlefield. taking out the little porro
first and then he can replay it for a
power. The ultra soft porro falls as
well. And so as we were talking earlier,
we mentioned the power of death from
below because you can hit so many units
with it and then end on a big unit at
the end. And I had said at that time,
you have to find your windows of
opportunity. Well, even though Mr. Rays
still had one energy open, you saw one
defy used and another one discarded. So
that was the window of opportunity to
give that a try because you know there's
only one defy left in the deck somewhere
and with limited cards in hand on the
side of Mr. Ray, the likelihood that
that was it was very low.
>> Bird trying to move into the southern
battlefield. Sinbon taking care of that
bird token with the void seeker. Another
stalwart porro is developed
>> as Mr. Ray sends it back over to Sinbon.
We see the treasure trove coming out and
being popped right away for the extra
card and rune and just developing on the
back line. The merchant in the spirit.
>> Sinbond still up here. Four to three.
>> Now
>> Mr. Ray low on cards.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say the the
issue for Mr. Rays is you're in a
position where every card you draw, you
kind of have to play. Anything that you
leave in your hand risks being stripped
away from the bewitching spirit. So, uh,
if you draw a unit, you kind of have to
play it. And if you draw a spell, uh,
even if it's something like a a
discipline or, you know, something that
you might want to use.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, Blitzcrank coming out. When played
to a battlefield, you can move an enemy
unit there. So, the Bewitching Spirit
taken down as Mr. Rays did go up to four
points evening the score
and now holding at that southern
battlefield. That is the brush
did replace it on the last turn.
>> Yeah. So this one of blitzcrank that we
saw in the main deck. Unsure if there
were more in the board comes down and it
is a massive answer to this looping
bewitching spirit. Uh the question now
is
>> it's just a five and two mark right?
Yeah, the question now is does Senbon
have an answer for the Blitzcrank?
Otherwise, that will keep returning back
to Mr. Ray's hand. Does have the answer
with the merchant.
>> Yeah, Falling Star plus Merchant
clearing out that southern battlefield
for Mr. Ray. Sinbon not developing any
units, just putting the Scriers's Bloom
down there. And Mr. Rays does find a way
to develop the Frisky Hunter bringing
that bird along with it. So, two units
in the backline as we go back over to
Sinbon. Great game two here in round six
of this Hartford regional qualifier.
>> We do see the Fizz coming out. This is
going to be a great option for Sinbon.
>> All right,
>> replaying the falling star clearing out
the backline and Anox's hopeful comes in
as well.
>> I was just about to play. You see that
Fizz quickly recycle four runes because
Senbon I think properly identified the
runes are there to be spent and if you
can keep Mr. Ray's board empty then
you're in a better shot at winning the
game. Mr. Ray answers with this Ultraoft
trying to find some sort of presence
that you can get going. But uh again you
have to worry about uh more Fizz action
in the future as well. And another
falling star clearing out the ultra
soft. Porro and Mr. Ray says that's
going to do it for game two. Sinbun
sending us to game three here in round
six.
>> Yeah, and it's very interesting that we
saw almost a completely different game
play out in game two. And I think it's
because Senbon started early with the
bewitching spirit and just kept on it.
Yes, you weren't scoring a lot of points
quickly. you weren't putting a lot of
might on the board quickly, but because
it stripped Mr. Ray's hand so
effectively and because Mr. Rays did not
have uh a lot of ways to get cards back
in hand in game two, it was really the
difference maker.
>> Well, here we go. Game three, the
deciding game between Mr. Rays and
Sinbon. Mr. Ray going first. Plays out
the stalwart porro
forbidding waste and seat of power. the
two battlefields here in the final game.
And another early Bewitching Spirit for
Sinbon once again attacking this hand
very early as Mr. Rays discards the
friendship.
Yeah, early Bewitching Spirit. Uh first
turn play because Senbon is on the rune
as I like to say going second uh does
mean that the strip is coming early and
often. It's also a little problematic
for Mr. raise because you likely don't
have a way to stop this spirit from
ending up on a battlefield unless maybe
uh it's some sort of sideboard tech like
maybe there was a charm or something
brought in. But the the likelihood is
very small and that means that not only
does the spirit get the conquer, but
then we'll also be able to go back to
the hand because of the legend ability
and that becomes the rinse and repeat.
Uh here we do see Mr. Rays play the Azir
and hide a card. I just want to
highlight really quickly the reason Azir
is ran in this list is one you can move
your bird tokens around when Azir moves
but also if you look this Azir is a bird
it has the bird tag that's absolutely
right yeah Azir can get that additional
might as well at the brush
the synergy here with the Azir sovereign
So now Sinbon working with bewitching
spirit
and currently Mr. Ray holding that
northern battlefield which has become
the brush piercing light
>> and here comes piercing light
repeated.
>> We do see hidden blade
in response. Mr. Rays will kill his own
stalwart porro to draw two but his board
is wiped. The bewitching spirit moves
in. The brush erased currently
>> back to the seat of power
>> as Sinbon goes up to one and bounces
that bewitching spirit back to hand with
Pike.
>> Senbon did have to recycle a number of
runes to pull that off because of the
deflect as well as the power cost.
However, uh Mr. rage because of the
early recycles as well is only on five
runes. Does develop that ultra soft
porro to try to find something that can
stick. Uh I keep mentioning that this is
the game plan and keeps trying to get
there but just hasn't been able to
actually stay on the battlefield with
the porro yet.
>> We'll certainly try to do it here in
game three. Once again, Mr. Rays having
to decide on which card to discard. It
is the Crimson Pigeons
>> as we see the list come down.
>> So, looking at the hand of Sunbon, I saw
the list. I think I saw a second copy of
the list, but I saw something that was
not in the main deck, so it had to have
come in from the sideboard. Uh, and that
was an Angler Beast. Angler Beast also
combining with the list is kind of
diabolical in general, but in this
matchup is brutal if Mr. race goes wide
with bird tokens or uh other small
units.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right. The
angller beast would just return them all
to hand and those tokens can't go to
hand as the ultra soft porro moves into
the southern battlefield. Mr. Rays two
points and the brush coming back out.
Blitzcrank is the play on that southern
battlefield to draw in the bewitching
spirit. And Sinbon is going to play Gus
looking to save the spirit.
I like that Senbon saved that one energy
for the Gust. Again, I thought I saw
maybe a second list. There were
certainly other options, but recognizing
that this was how you won the second
game. So, you cannot fall to a
Blitzcrank. You have to protect your
Bewitching Spirit
and is able to successfully do so with
the Gust. Also, that gives information
over to Senbon because if Mr. Ray was
sitting on a defy. You have to assume
that it would have been played in
response to the gust there.
>> Now back over to Sin Bon as he stares
down.
>> 11 total might currently at the Southern
Battlefield which is the brush.
Mr. Rays does have point tempo
>> second copy of the list.
And this ultra soft porro
going to lose minus4 might here.
>> And that is brutal because
>> there's the death from below.
>> Death from below. Right now
>> I had talked about the information that
you gained from that gust and the
windows of opportunity in game two for
this death from below. So this is
another window of opportunity and it's a
huge one cuz this will clear both of the
units from the battlefield again. And
Mr. has been trying to stick these
ultrasoft poros all series long and the
answers have just been nonstop from
Senbon
>> and it does resolve. Both units killed
from death from below for Sen.
Clearing out Mr. Rais's hold once again
having some great answers here the last
couple games. The bewitching spirit plan
into that death from below has been
excellent.
>> 13 and 12 minutes. How much?
>> 13 and 12.
>> All right. And I believe in the hand of
Mr. Ray, I saw a charm picked up, which
uh if that was the case, there was not
one in the main deck. So, that would
have also come in from the sideboard,
but I did mention it earlier as uh
something that could have been a
potential answer at one point for Mr.
Rays.
Uh the Ivor Nurturer is going to allow
Mr. raise to at least find another unit
and apply the buff as well.
>> That will be the turn for Mr. Ray. So, a
five might unit in the back line as he
tries to reestablish this board,
but that bewitching spirit will continue
to go to work. Now, the good news here
for Mr. Rays, he does have a bit of
cards in hand. So, oh, it was another
friendship was not a charm. So we have
the frisky, a discipline, a daisy.
Mr. Ray is not quite in that same dire
straight position
with cards as he was in game two.
Uh did just pick up Crimson Pigeons
though, so we'll be able to generate
some additional might to the base here.
Could actually generate a healthy
amount. There is that daisy in hand as
well. While it's not really discounted
much right now, there's enough runes on
the side of Mr. A if that is a decision
to be made. Typically, I think you want
to save Daisy as that kind of surprise
ready play as a retake though.
>> Ivvern moving into the seat of power.
Both battlefields now brush
as Mr. raise goes up to three points
>> and will further develop with the frisky
hunter in the back line.
>> Yep.
>> And there pigeons
>> there are the crimson pigeons developed
to the base as well. Uh Senbon here does
again just have that bewitching spirit
and that is the one downside to the pike
list at times. Yes, you can strip your
opponent's hand over and over again. you
can remove units, but sometimes you just
lack the might to go over the top and
reconquer. That being said, there is an
open battlefield. There is also that
angller beast we had talked about in the
hand. I also believe I saw a down well.
So, if things get too out of hand and
Mr. Ray goes incredibly wide, Sunbon has
a panic button available.
>> Witching Spirit does move into that
southern battlefield. Up to two points
goes Sinbon and just continuing this
cycle
>> with the bewitching spirit and is going
to throw down the downwell right now.
>> I had just talked about that panic
button and I think Senbon says I can't
allow Mr. Rays to one have this hold and
two have all of this might in the base.
I'm too far behind on the might on my
own side. So to buy some time I have to
play this down well. Personally, I love
this from Senbon because again, you
really need to slow down Mr. Rays until
you can either generate more might on
your side or just find more answers for
the things that were already being
played.
>> So now Mr. Ray is just bit of a reset
here. Going to look to
refill that back line once again.
Now, one potential downside to the
downwell, pun half intended, is that it
refills Mr. Raay's hand, this means that
your bewitching spirit is a little bit
less effective going forward because uh
they have all those cards that went
back. So, they're going to be able to
kind of pick and choose. There is a
redevelopment being done by Mr. Rays.
So, we see the same units that went
away, replayed, minus the nurturer. So,
we have the ultra soft poro and the
frisky plus the bird token generated
from the the fun cat.
>> Now, Sinbon going to play the falling
star
>> targeting the ultrasoft poro and the
frisky hunter. Frisky hunter down
>> and now the list will come out.
>> I'll respond to the
>> calling porro.
>> And then I believe Mr. Raza is
responding with a discipline here to the
activation. Yeah, we'll get that plus
two needed to keep it alive after the
minus two might from the list.
>> Yeah, I think the problem though is
there's a second list. The thing about
Senbon Claws is he's making a list and
he's checking it twice.
>> And that's twice the porros being
targeted by the list there. And that
will clean it up. And now the angller
beast does come down. Gets rid of just a
single bird token. But perhaps more
importantly gets some might on the side
of the board of Sunbon and Mr. Ray says,
"Wait, what is this card?" [laughter]
>> Yeah, you love it when the opponent has
to look at the card. Senbon able to
develop while clearing Mr. Ray's board.
It's the exact turn that he needed. The
downwell was a complete reset, but now
he's actually able to
answer those opposing units and develop
his own threat to try and push forward
his game plan.
So on the side of Mr. Rays, we know that
there is still the Ivor Nurturer in hand
that was bounced back. We know that
there is the Crimson Pigeons because
they were bounced back. I saw a second
one picked up. We see this Azir
developed as well and that's
accelerated. I also believe I saw the
pick up of a VI peacekeeper. So, uh, Mr.
Rays still has a lot of options to both
generate might and keep the pressure on
Senbon.
So, we'll see if Senbon can continue to
kind of stem the aggression. The Angler
Beast was a good development. It allows
you to contest some of the battlefields
a little bit better. The Bewitching
Spirit has helped strip the hand a
little bit, but because of the downwell,
there's still a lot of cards in Mr. Ra's
hand and potentially more after you find
some with this Nurturer coming down. So,
even though it was a great reset, a
great follow-up turn from Senbomb, this
is still an uphill climb.
>> Yeah, it really is. And that southern
battlefield going to be quite
quite the task for Sinbon here as the
Ivvern unit does get buffed.
And it looks like the trusty ramhound
coming down in that back line for Mr.
Rays.
>> Yeah, the the thing about a trusty
ramhound is it's a good boy.
>> It really is.
>> It's a good boy.
So right now, Senbon looking at a total
of 6 + 5, 11 might at the Southern
Battlefield.
>> Stack deck.
>> Yep.
>> Starts with a stack deck.
players.
>> I love this tech of the angller beast
>> coming in from the sideboard because
even though it's expensive, the fact
that you can also still either use your
legend or use pack of wonders to return
it if the birds come back is such a
threat to Mr. Rays. You're really saying
like I dare you to try to beat me with
that flurry of feathers again like we
saw in game one.
>> Yeah, would definitely be a bit tougher
with the beast. around.
Four damage dealt to Ivvern Nurter with
that void seeker.
And now we see the pack of wonders.
>> Sure.
>> And the list is going to finish up
Ivvern.
>> Yeah. And I was
>> that minus two might.
>> I was talking about this earlier. I love
the interaction with pack of wonders and
the list because it makes it so much
more versatile for being able to just
keep reutilizing it for uh very low
investment. Like yes, you have to play
the pack and the list, you have to find
them, yada yada, but simply just
spending one energy each turn to give
something minus two might is a pretty
big deal. And then you might not even
have to do the one energy every time
when you're playing against lists like
Ivvern where they have a lot of shared
tags. It really is, I think, a neat
inclusion from Senbon.
>> Now, Mr. Ray does hold up to five here,
but Senbon was able to go to that
northern battlefield with the Angler
Beast.
>> Hiding a card there,
>> that pike. Yeah, I was about to say we
pretty much know that's got to be the
legend Pike underneath. And as a result,
this becomes kind of just a a math game
for Mr. Rays. If Mr. Rays had the
ability to play something like a flurry
or generate a bunch of bird tokens, that
is very relevant because that Azir, if
it were to somehow make its way back,
whether that's through Emperor's Divide
or some other ability, and then go over,
it could drag all the birds with it. The
other thing to consider is I think we're
about to see the best friend of Ivvern,
the signature unit, Daisy. All right,
>> this comes down and it's a massive
amount of might.
>> Daisy is ready.
>> Costs a bit less
>> because of the bird and dog in play.
>> And now Daisy plus trusty ramhound
moving into the northern battlefield.
All right. So, this I believe is 11
might versus what is currently nine
because of the power was paid on the
pike
>> and no other effects played. They both
passed. So, Daisy does go away. Daisy
was not able to activate the stun
portion of the text because not all four
tags were present. But still again, a
lot of might that enters ready. And as I
said before, important for Ivvern for
some of those retakes from the hand
without having to develop and pass
another turn.
>> Now the Ram Hound going to be reinforced
with the mutated Mouser. Up to six
points is Mr. Rays. And keep in mind
there's no ready units currently for
Sinbon.
He'll have to find a way to contest
these battlefields.
>> And just going to move back the Azir
Sovereign and hide a card at the
northern battlefield is Mr. Ray as we go
back over to Sinbon.
All right, this is going to be a
critical sequence as we're hitting uh
the end of game three. Mr. Ray
threatening to win the game from six.
You're holding one battlefield. You have
a bunch of might in the base to either
take the other one or maybe even set up
a double conqueror. You pointed out no
ready units on the side of Senbon. So
likely has to be some form of removal to
deal with these. We see the void seeker
come down. Uh the other important piece
of this equation that I want to point
out as they're talking through this real
quickly though uh is the timer. Senbon
is also less uh or excuse me more than
two points away from Mr. Rays. So even
if this timer runs out and they go to
overtime, if Sunbon can't close the gap
on points and they're just kind of
stalling, this will still be a victory
for Mr. Rays in the series.
>> Do see the treasure trove come out. A
quick pop. Really digging here and he's
just going to give the handshake and
Ivvern is 6 here in Hartford. What a run
so far for Mr. Rays. I got
>> this is such a fun match that we got to
enjoy because uh we got to see Ivvern on
display and again just generating a lot
of might. Uh we heard a lot of people in
your hot takes say that Ivvern was
perhaps an underrated deck and we're
seeing why now. It is capable of holding
very well but also capable of hitting
some of those key retakes with cards
like Daisy. But I also want to give
Flowers on the other side. Sunbond
looked very good with this Pike list and
I love the pack of wonders stuff
combined with the list that we got to
see.
>> Absolutely. There's just there's so much
going on there with pack of wonders. You
have of course the pack of wonders plus
treasure trove to get that extra card
and rune each turn, but also the
bewitching spirit, right? You could
bounce the bewitching spirit back each
turn. We saw Fizz, right? Being able to
replay those removal spells that he was
effectively using. We saw the Fizz
taking advantage of the void seeker from
the trash several times and being able
to hit those units on the battlefield.
So, there's a lot of good stuff
happening there with pack. Yeah. And
with the list as well, being able to use
it or or use it for, excuse me,
situations where your damage from cards
like Void Seeker are not enough to get
the job done is great. But we also got
to see it used very well post sideboard
with death from below. So if you're
trying to set up good value from death
from below where you want it to hit
multiple units using the list to kind of
knock things down so that they're below
that might threshold so that you can
keep replaying it. Uh it was incredibly
effective.
>> Yeah, it really was. That death from
below when you set it up just right with
the minus might from the list. That was
so good. And we didn't really get to see
death from below go crazy, right? There
wasn't a bunch of little units on the
battlefield at one time, but that was
really cool to see. But Ivvern, we did
find the play that you talked about with
the the birds, the flock of feathers
coming in, and all of a sudden you've
got eight might defending out of nowhere
that your opponent may not be expecting,
and I don't think Sinbon was in that
first game.
>> Yeah. Or even if you are expecting it,
maybe you're hoping that they're not
running lots of copies. I mean, we got
to see on uh the deck list on the
broadcast that it is just one in the
main deck. So, Senbon, even if they knew
about it, was kind of playing the
percentages, but it just represents so
much emergency might with those birds.
And the worst part is is unlike other
combat tricks like a discipline where it
might save your unit, that leftover
might sticks around. Those birds stay on
the board after the fact.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely right. And I
don't think we can highlight enough that
the fact we just saw Ivvern [laughter]
go 6 and 0. I absolutely love to see it.
Like Mr. Rays is locked into day two
right now. We've got at least one Ivvern
heading to day two. And we've talked a
lot about the diversity in the meta and
how we could see different decks make a
deep run in day two and into the top
cut. We saw two new legends and then top
cut last weekend and we're already
seeing it now where we're seeing
different decks. We're seeing great
diversity undefeated. I love it. Well,
you're talking about our win in for day
two that we just saw. Let's take a look
at some standings. So, again, round six
still going, but these are some of the
players that are knocking on that
doorstep of securing their spot in day
two. And as we talk about diversity, I'm
seeing uh a lot of Diana's, a lot of
Azir, but a couple of Vex's as well.
That is super surprising. It has been
some time since Vex has had good
success. You have to go all the way back
to Sydney where you had Vex have a
really good run. So, it's interesting to
see two at that 5-0 mark as we continue
to look through the list. Aurelia there.
And how about that Teemo? We saw Botmack
earlier. He's up there undefeated right
now. So, we could potentially see Teemo
in day two as well.
>> Yeah, we got to see that Teemo. Uh we
did also see Mr. Rays on that list and
we know that that was a successful
winning in. So, for sure you're going to
have an Ivvern in the day two here at
Harford.
>> Absolutely. That is great news for all
of us. And now, let's hear from the man
himself, Mr. Rays, who has put Ivvern in
day two. We'll go over to Barrett.
And an incredible round six here for our
feature match. A deck I don't think I
could ever be believing right now. Is
now 6 and0 locking in day two. Mr. Rays
on Ivvern. How does that feel?
>> It feels amazing. I did not expect to go
6 and 0. Um Ivvern has a lot of tough
matchups in some of the most commonly
played decks like Master Y. So I managed
to dodge Master Y for six rounds or five
rounds. Um, so there was definitely a
little bit of luck there, but in terms
of the deck itself, I've been playing it
since Unleash came out. So, I mean, I've
been practicing it non-stop. I've been,
you know, tweaking the list constantly.
So, I have all the reps I need into it.
It's just I need to see the right
matchups. I need to just, you know, win
some die rolls, right? Like, I I know
what I need to do. Um, the the things
that are out of my control just kind of
went my way. So, it it really worked
out. And then the Pike that I just
played, I mean, he's an amazing player.
That is the hardest time I've ever had
against Pike. In game one, I like didn't
even know what was going on because I
was like, how does this list work? Um,
but I just managed to kind of figure it
out as I went and and and took it in
three. So,
>> it is a really interesting list. I I
know. I've actually talked to him a
couple of times about that list. And the
fact that even like we say his list, but
the list, right? And it's like actually
a crazy card against you. You're like,
"Oh, I have a lot of this trait. That's
not good.
>> I don't like that card at all." But
speaking of, you said like obviously
there's bad matchups for the deck,
things like Master Yi, and you said
you've dodged a bunch of those, but I
I've actually been praising Ivvern a lot
because there are some matchups in the
format that are really prevalent that I
think it's a great matchup, specifically
Ireelia. that deck wants to do a lot of
movement and running around and Ivvern
doesn't mind like parking onto a
battlefield as long as you have the
point lead of course but things like as
we even saw in game one Emperor's Divide
when they leave you alone bring you back
and then you can just do it as an
offensive push but my question here
because I for the people at home if you
think Ivvern isn't good enough here's a
6 and0 Ivvern my last question for you
>> what do you think is the allstar card of
the Ivvern deck why do you what do what
pushes that deck over the limit And why
is it underestimated?
>> I I think it's there's really not one
card in Ivvern. That's the thing that
makes Ivvern really good is that it's
all of the two drops that can sit on
brush with four might. There's really
not many decks that can actually just
pay two and have four might sitting on a
battlefield. So, you know, when you
throw out a mouser with tank and maybe
buff it and now it's suddenly five tank
for two, um you just have really
efficiently stated units. And when you
just play a whole bunch of them, it, you
know, it ends up all working together.
So, I think like, you know, the hidden
cards are so important, but there's not
one that I would say is really the best.
They all have their uses, and when you
have multiple different hidden cards in
your deck, your opponent has to try to
play around all of them or just hope you
don't have the one they don't want to
see. So, I think Ivvern is really just a
combination of cards that work so well
together. Um, there's not really a card
where it's like you play it and you win.
It's more like you have to play the
right cards at the right time, go wide
enough when you need to, and go in and
out of battlefields when you need to,
and it just works out. I mean, there are
some cards I've debated on a lot, like
Daisy. I mean, I want to play Daisy.
Originally in the list, I had Daisy. I
took Daisy out. I was like, "This is not
really good enough cuz it needs setup."
But, you know, I I tried other things
like Grand Stratgeem, Vile, and it just
I came back around to Daisy. I was like,
I'm playing enough of the different
tags. I can play Daisy for five or six
runes, which is which is fine. And she
comes in ready and you can just go onto
a battlefield and no one's really ready
for correct might running in at you on
your last turn.
>> Like you said, really good at holding on
those battlefields and then rushing in
as soon as possible. And I could you
couldn't have said it better and I don't
think in any other words. It wasn't just
one card. It's the entire petting zoo
itself and all the friendly animals. Mr.
Ray, congratulations. 6 and0 lock uh
locking in day two, but you have more
tournaments to play and we have more
action to get to. We'll send it back.
>> Thank you for that Barrett. Mr. Ray
showing us Ivvern can also put up
results and it was a very fun best of
three series to see between that Ivvern
and Pike list. And I want to dive into a
couple of those key moments, especially
if we're looking here at the end of game
one, right? We have an aspirin's climb
that's actually hiding under this brush.
This aspirin's climb is usually going to
push the points that we need to win the
game to nine. However, we have that
brush. We have a hidden card here as
well, which you know, we don't know what
that is if we're uh sendone here, which
it could be a back off, it could be a
emperor's divide. so many different
cards that we can hide in this iron list
that you just don't want to risk running
into a brush uh with three three birds
there, six total might right now. It's
very hard to kind of get over. However,
if you don't clear this brush, this game
is still an eight-point game. So, the
name of the game here now for Pike is to
try to at least clear the other
battlefield, that rockfall path. That
way if the rockfall path gets cleared,
then we have to still play one more turn
before we can actually score our eight's
points as we can see up here. So if we
actually go ahead and roll the clip,
we're going to see this exact sort of
strategy played out here by Senbon where
the name of the game is, okay, I'm going
to play this Fizz out. I'm going to get
a falling star and I'm just going to
clear the backline and I'm going to
clear this bird. And that way I'm kind
of insulating myself. I'm making sure
that I have another turn. However, this
just kind of goes to show how important
the brush is in Mr. Ra's Ivvern deck.
So, he's going to think for a bit and
then he's going to let that happen. And
what kind of happens on the next turn is
exactly like the best case scenario here
if you're Ivvern where now you're like,
"All right, well, my opponent's more or
less tapped out. I'm going to go to the
beginning of my turn. I see the Scrier's
Bloom and then Mr. Rays, you see that
nod? He knows he has it in the bag. He's
going to hold a seven. He's going to
awaken all his uh all his birds there
and he's going to flip over that
Emperor's Divide which is just going to
bring all those birds back home and
close out the game. So, a way to cheat
your kind of way into that win by
turning off that Aspirin's climb with
that brush. If we jump into the next
clip though, Pike was not just going to,
you know, take this and allow a 20. Pike
was going to fight back and try to force
that game three. And that's exactly what
we see here. We saw in the interview
that they talked about a card called the
list. And I think this is one of the
coolest cards in Riftbound currently.
And if we actually take a look at this
setup here, there's a very nice
setup where we have a unit at a
battlefield and a unit at home. Both
these units don't have a lot of might,
right? So what we're going to see here
is we're actually going to see Senbon
play a piercing light to try to kill
both those units. However, what's going
to end up happening is we're going to
have our friend here, Mr. Ray, who's
going to try to pump it up with a
discipline. And that's where the list is
just going to show up. We're going to
name porro. We're going to exhaust the
list and we're going to bring that might
back down of the porro to kill it. So
obviously Mr. Ray wants to read that
piercing light. See how he can
counterplay that a little bit. We're
going to see that discipline come out.
So you're essentially two for oneing
your opponent a little bit. You're
making him expend a card to save a unit
when in reality he's not saving a unit
anyways. And like we talked about in
that interview, there are so many porros
in this deck. There's so many cats, so
many dogs that this list, even if you're
playing it down for a poor right now,
you're going to get that value. And
that's exactly what we see here in this
one from Senbon. And then moving to our
last clip, this kind of just shows how
much removal is needed to really push
forward and force this game three.
Again, we have a very, very stacked
battlefield, right? We have the ultra
soft porro
that's over here that can just print out
birds, right? We have a stalwart porro
as well. So, we have some two pretty big
units, but the signature spell from uh
Pike, Death from Below, notably, you're
allowed to play it again if you kill a
unit that has three or less three or
less might. So, we're going to see
actually Senbon here play that uh Death
from Below, target the Porro first, and
then recycle another power to be able to
kill the ultra soft porro. This is a
very, very removal heavy heavy pike
list. And I think that's part of the
reason we saw Senbon be able to force a
third game, but Mr. raise. Ultimately,
you know, the zoo of Ivvern just was
able to take it home. So, what we're
going to do now is we're going to toss
it to a short break and we have a lot
more exciting riftbound when we come
back. Stay tuned.
>> An excellent match to be played there. A
nice and easy 20 for round one here with
Merc Tron is bad piloting this Aurora
deck that we were kind of teasing at the
top of the day of some changes that were
being made. And wow, the the the Baron
Nasher finally coming in in full force
for this deck. And from what I've been
told, it's supposed to be for these sort
of Diana matches, but we saw you side in
these extra new obviously the Elder
Dragons and the Fer Blades still
existing in the deck. Do you think that
this is probably the best version of
this deck that you could be coming into
this event? I mean, uh, compared to the
pre-Q that I played yesterday. Yesterday
I played more of just kind of like a
mid-range civer, uh, lower to the
ground, I was playing dead Predators,
and Dead Bloom Predators is one of my
favorite riffound cards of all time.
Loved it in set one. I've been playing
Aurora since set one. Uh, but every
single time I played uh, Predator
yesterday, I wish that it was a Baron.
Um, and so my buddy uh, shout out to
Ali. Uh, he's the one that said, "Hey,
you should do this with the deck." So,
kind of just put all the cards in the
deck that he said should go into the
deck and I played it this morning and
that felt great. That felt incredible.
>> I mean, it looked great. I mean,
genuinely, it looked so powerful and so
decisive. Also, you you play very
cleanly and from what I've been told,
you're relatively new to the game. Um,
you also have a team that has been
formed, Merc, who we uh we do want to
highlight, I think, throughout the
evening. So, um, can you tell me real
quick about your team in general of like
how did you all come together? How did
you all meet each other? And why
Riftbound and why now? Uh, so I feel
like what had happened was one, we met
all online essentially. Um, Eric and
Michael reached out to a bunch of
different people and I'm just kind of
chronically online and uh, I've been
playing Magic for god over almost 15
years at this point. But yeah, I'm I'm
partially new to Riftbound. Uh, I've
been playing since December of uh, this
past year. Uh, started playing at Pax
Unplugged during just one of the learn
to plays. Fell in love with the game.
Been playing League since 2010. So,
shout out my other Caitlyn Mains.
Can't wait for her to get a legend, man.
>> No, that's going to be a ton of fun. And
and then that that adds up then because
like this is your first regional
qualifier and a strong start here with
round one and piloting this Dazzling
Aurora deck which again when I look at
this new version I do think it might be
one of the best events and it's tailored
to maybe take down the entire thing
because of the specific choices that
have been made. But you know I'm glad to
bring a new team onto the the scene. I'm
excited to see your performance this
weekend as well.
>> And um
>> just congratulations for round one. I
know you've got a long day ahead of you,
so we're going to go ahead and we'll
send it back.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello everybody and welcome to the
regional qualifier here in Hartford,
Connecticut. I am Charmer and I am
joined by some amazing guests. I have
Knack and Eric from Team MC. No, no,
listen. I I know that I'm doing this bit
like I don't know him, but we've
actually been talking throughout the
weekend. Granton was even playing games
with you all. How are you feeling about
this event here in Hartford with your
kind of coming out party as a team?
>> It's been great. Hartford has been
phenomenal so far going into it. Um kind
of unexpectedly the team came together
within the last few weeks. Uh and
everyone's been meshing really well. We
kind of like calling ourselves the vibes
team. Um not for nothing, but uh
everyone's super cool with each other.
We have some fantastic players. I mean,
Knack won best of Rumble in Vancouver,
so that was uh great for him. Um, and
then we have Tron, who played this
morning, round one, um, as Civer Aurora.
So, it's been it's been awesome to to
come out here and have fun at Harford.
>> Yeah, that is correct. I was actually on
the broadcast for that Tron is bad game
and uh, it was a fun go, but I want to
hear a little bit about how your team
came to be, how you came together. Yeah,
I mean it's not a long story. It's a
little bit funny. I kind of went on
Twitter. I was like, "Hey, I'm looking
to improve." Um, and I was already
talking to Knack and some of the other
guys on the team just to kind of say
like, "Let's just do something together.
A lot of us are already content
creators. Uh, and we just decided, hey,
like let's just make uh, you know, a
Riftbound team out of this." And uh, I
already owned Merc. Uh, we've been in
the esports space for a while, so we
just decided to inherit the name. And
now we're here. We're hanging out at
Hartford. Yeah, after he sent out his uh
he sent out his tweet, I replied with,
"I have a best of Rumble and a camera
deal." And it the rest is history.
>> We shook hands right there. That is one
heck of a sales pitch. And with that in
mind, what has been the process for kind
of getting to know each other as a team
since you're so new as far as like play
testing and play styles?
>> Yeah. So, I think the first start for us
was setting a schedule. So, we have kind
of a strict schedule going into it week
week by week. does fluctuate depending
on how people's livelihoods are going,
but we'll kind of test Mondays and
Wednesdays. Uh we're testing different
decks, testing different uh you know,
theory crafting really trying to get an
understanding of what works for us. I
mean, a lot of us are playing a lot of
offmeta legends, so it's it's a little
different than a typical team, but we do
have some people who are playing meta.
Uh so that helps us get the practice
towards, you know, some of the goals
that some of the guys are going towards.
Yeah, I would say it's definitely been
super cool. Like everyone's just vibe
together really well. It's interesting
for me because pretty much the entirety
of the team is on the East Coast, so I'm
on West Coast hours, so I get to sleep a
little bit earlier than they do, but
they stay up like DJ hours. It's crazy.
You guys go late, but yeah, much love.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, I know what that's like as an East
Coast player myself, and sometimes
whether it's playing or creating content
with some of the folks on the West
Coast, it is very, very awkward. One
final question that I want to ask you
before I let you gentlemen get back to
it. What is your goals for this event
and for the future specifically for team
Merc?
>> Yeah, for team Merc as a whole. Um I
would love to see some of our guys end
up placing day two top 32 even. I mean
great if we could get a top eight that'd
be fantastic. Um I know I mean I'll pass
it on to Knack. I don't know if you have
any specific goals you want to chat
about.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean my personal goal
at this event get best of Rumble go back
to back. I would love to do that. But as
a team, you know, we love the other
teams. We love Challenger TCG. We love
the secret sauce. Amazing teams. They're
like very hyper competitive teams. But
our team is like a good mixture of like
content, personality, and very
competitive people. So, I would call us
like the best of vibes team. We want to
be known as the best of vibes.
>> All right. Well, if people want to check
out the vibes, where do they find you
all? And as far as social media in the
future? Yeah. So, all of our platforms
for Merc is mercgg.
>> Yeah, we're merking it every single day
on Twitter. We love Merkinit. And um as
for my social media, you can find me on
YouTube. I do vlogs um@nack-d
on YouTube and Nackd on all the other
social media platforms as well. Much
love to all of y'all. Much love to Riot
Riftbound. I love this game. I love
Merc. Let's go.
>> All right. Well, I just want to thank
you two for taking the time to answer
the questions. I want to wish you the
best of luck for the rest of the event.
We hope to see more of you soon. And
with that, we're going to throw it back
to you.
>> What's up, everybody? I'm live here with
the one and only Jeff Jones. Jeff, it's
been a while since we've seen you at one
of these regional qualifiers. What you
been up to?
>> I've been playing card games.
>> Card games?
>> Yeah. Okay, nice. I know. I saw you. You
know, I just saw you.
>> I've We have seen each other. We have
seen each other.
>> So, you know what? I've been up
>> since Vegas. But you were also notable
for being at Houston and making top 32.
It might be a while since people have
seen you in Riftbound, but um
>> I went to Vegas, but I got food
poisoning, so I didn't get to play it.
>> Yeah, that seems a little disappointing.
Are you Do you feel like you have
something to prove now? Like now that
you're back into the game?
>> No.
>> No, nothing.
>> No, no, I'm just playing cards. What?
>> Well, do you know what the new set is?
Have you been up to date on the on the
format?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, good. I'm just making sure. Just
ridiculous. Look at this guy.
>> Cuz I thought maybe maybe you were just
lucking your way into five and one right
now. Is
>> that just lost?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm five in one.
>> I'm still the lease in cuz that's what
you'd played all the way back in
Houston, but that was like Yeah.
>> for I'm uh playing uh LeBlanc.
>> LeBlanc. Okay. So, I just found out from
a French Canadian that you're not
supposed to say Leblanc.
>> Okay.
>> Leblanc. And you don't say this the
>> Well, I'm American, so we say it all
dumbly.
>> Can you say it American for us?
>> Leblanc.
>> Leblanc. All right. You also Jeff
tweeted out one time after regionals how
confusing it is to see the Riot game
IDs. You're just Jeff Jones.
>> Jeff. Yeah,
>> that's iconic.
>> Jeff,
>> what's the funniest name that you've
played against either today or since the
last time you made your legendary tweet?
>> Well, none of them have been crazy
except for that first one where it was
like, I know he's going to be watching
and it was like Ari Sugar Daddy or
something like that
>> and that's the only weird one you've ran
into. There are like some like that was
like the the like most memorable one
>> that that's got to be memorable. Do you
know what mine is?
>> Is it the knowowers? No.
>> Is it just Kangas?
>> The knowowers know. It's not Kangas.
That's not my riot tag.
>> But Well, yeah. Cuz whatever your League
of Legends,
>> it's whatever my League of Legends name
is.
>> What is it when you play League of
Legends?
>> When I play League of Legends, it's Sir
Buttkick.
>> Sir Buttkick.
>> Yeah. Rate my name.
>> But out of 10. How where was it stand
for you?
>> Well, is it because you get your butt
kicked a lot? I bet you're not very good
at League.
>> [laughter]
>> There's no way. I've seen this guy play
other card games. There's no way he's
good at league.
>> So, thank you, Jeff, for taking the time
to chat with us. Any final shout outs
you have for the fans out [laughter]
there?
>> No, no, no. This is fine.
>> That's it?
>> Yeah, that's it.
>> Cool. Thanks for taking the time.
[laughter]
>> For the record, I am not very good at
League of Legends. And yes, I am
sensitive about it. So, please don't
bring it up, Jeff. Okay, Jeff Jones,
everybody. What a
>> Yeah. What a what a good interview. You
know, it's it's ironic that we're just
tossing it to ourselves at this point.
>> We are. Yeah. You tossed it to you. I
just tossed it to me. And I was ready to
make a joke about how I walked up to uh
the Merc squad uh and just all them in a
circle uh were just straight murking it
together. Then that then we went to
another interview and that was with Jeff
and I, you know, good interviews back to
back. You also got to interact with the
the Merc squad. Uh that was the
interview before that last one. So, uh
what was your impression of them?
>> They're just a bunch they're based on
vibes. Yeah,
>> that's that's vibes. We recruited a team
and they're just based on vibes 100%.
And it's lovely.
>> Especially when you have like the super
competitive teams like the core TCG,
stuff like that. To instead have a team
that's coming in still putting results
like best of Rumble in Vancouver. Pretty
cool. Um but then also team that's more
focused on just having fun, repping the
team, kind of cool. I see also I don't
know if they're technically a team, but
the Rift Baddies are out there. Have you
seen the Rift Batty shirts?
>> Yeah, I got a pin. Did you get a pin?
>> You got a pin. I didn't get a pin.
>> You got to go get a pin.
>> All right, I'll look for a pin later.
Um, but yeah, it's awesome to have just
different groups uh hanging out and
making communities in Riftbound. So
hopefully uh if you're watching this,
you've either found one or find your way
into one because I think that's the best
way to enjoy card games is just playing
the game with friends.
>> Yep.
>> I mean, like I said, you either win or
you learn.
>> You win or you learn.
>> And it's always more fun to learn with
friends.
>> Again, uh a great mentality to have for
somebody who loses a lot.
>> What?
>> Notably. Huh? No. You
>> You don't lose ever?
>> No.
>> Cool.
>> Undefeated. Well, we haven't played each
other yet.
You don't want to play against me.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. I'll I'll go in.
>> Challenge accepted.
>> Limitless table. We'll record. Well,
that's I I have a theory though on that
deck. But you know,
>> you have many theories.
>> I have many theories. [laughter]
>> You're rolling your eyes as you see it.
All right. Well, I'm hearing that we're
ready for our next match. So, uh let's
take a look at the deck list and see
what's ahead of us today. First, Dark
Lizerero Luisero. Dark Luizo and uh
Kaisa list.
>> Yeah. Uh Kai'Sa. But we haven't seen her
in a while.
>> No.
>> Our favorite resident spell slinger.
Some might say
>> the kind of uh boogeyman of origins
format. And even in spirit forge, this
is one that I was playing a lot. Had a
lot of fun with. Um and I think it's
still one of those decks where it it
will really reward somebody who knows
matchups incredibly well. If you know
every matchup on the field, you're going
to go very far in tournaments like this.
You have so many removal tools. And
we're seeing also the double time warp
here. So really playing for these like
big swings where you go from, you know,
uh, six points to seven then hold for
the game, stuff like that.
>> Yeah, this is a pretty Origins core. I
would say it looks like set one Kai'Sa a
little bit. Obviously, we have some
>> tech pieces as well in it is with the
addition of inferna to kind of have like
a little bit of surprise on attack. Are
there five unleashed cards? I think
there's only five unleashed cards. We
got inferna, we got smite.
>> Oh, smite. Yes. Eclipse.
>> Uh, turn to dust. Was that um that's a
spear forge I suppose?
>> I believe so.
>> So then there's only three spear forged
cards if my math is correct here with
the fourr runners and that. So this is a
overwhelmingly uh majority origin.
That is awesome. Yeah, we have the
obviously thousand tail watchers for the
might swings which is always going to be
a three of ferris 4runner is a
terrifying card to play in this meta
with the amount of Leblons that we're
seeing because you just give them a
forerunner if they have a mirror image
and then with carsis they are now
printing mechs in their base
>> and their mirror image will probably
make a token that will create another
copy of the 4erunner. So then they get
four death triggers let alone if they
have that car is on the field like you
highlighted. So it's a tough one. I
think maybe why it's a two of in this
list. And there's two Dariuses. Darius
is one that was very popular in Origins
format. Fell off a little bit in Spirit
Forged, but um man, it just punches
really hard. [laughter]
>> Yeah. I mean, Darius Cleave as a combo
is, you know, old as time itself. Uh but
the cool part of this Kaisalist, right,
is it allows you to play these more
power hungry spells, you know, like a
hex tech ray, even the smite where you
just have that free power in your legend
zone. So dealing three for one, that's
it. No power, no recycle is very strong.
And banishing instead of killing is so
impactful in this meta. Not just for the
Leblon decks, but there's a lot of cards
that care about [music] being put to the
into the trash. If you manage to smite
an Elder Dragon when you're playing
against an Aurora list, you can't
recycle it anymore.
>> Exactly. Yeah. And even things like
carry on dredger are in pretty much
every order list that we're seeing so
far. [music] So not just the long hits a
lot of the field. Let's take a look at
the competition though and see what the
Kai'Sa is up against. It's going to be
Diana Lynsanity's Diana.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a spicy
matchup. Obviously, when you pit two,
you know, kind of spell slingy decks
against each other, it's going to be
very tempo oriented and no one does
tempo like Diana.
>> Yes, Diana is the queen of tempo. Very,
very hard to outresource this deck. Um,
when you look at things like the Fizz
being able to loop the Starcross and
Moonfall as well, I mean, you have two
really good targets with Fizz, let alone
the classics like Ride the Wind, which
can help you get out onto battlefields.
Starcross is one of the classics there
and then Moonfall. Would you say this is
the strongest uh signature spell? I know
this is a debate going around the
strongest one.
>> I think Moonfall's definitely up there,
but stuff like Thrill of the Hunt, we
have to talk about that those as well.
But there are so many powerful signature
spells that have been added. Yeah.
>> Yep. But Moonfall, I would say, is a
huge one. Especially if you have
abandoned
kind of posted up there with your units
and you kind of move a and you have
these big might swings, it can get
really, really nasty where the math for
the Kai'Sa player is going to be very
difficult to calculate. And that's what
Kais' excels at is being like, you have
this much I need to deal with. I will do
exactly that much damage. Clear your
board and move on. But there's so many
tricks and notably two main deck hard
against a deck that runs time warps is a
very interesting call out to look at
because you have to play around those or
else you're just dramping yourself four
runes, three if your Kaiser is ready and
you're getting you're walking into a
hard bargain. Also want to point out Hay
uh very very powerful unit throughout uh
the unleashed format and uh we had seen
some decks running gears in the Hay
builds but I'm not seeing any gears in
this list. So, this is just going to be
spells to draw an extra card, units to
make the Hay big. You're not going to be
using the Hi to discard things like the
Sprite Fountain that had been kind of
making their way into some lists um to
give you more options on the Hay and
also just be decent cards on their own.
>> Yeah. And another notable one as well
that we actually have as a one of uh is
the Eager Apprentice. So, an OG
>> Yeah, I like that.
>> Yeah. So, this is a very fun one because
it's almost like a Vex cheerless.
>> Mhm.
>> But doesn't have to be in combat, right?
You're just sitting at the battlefield.
You can reduce your spells, your hard
bargains. now cost three if you want to
repeat them. So, it again forces the
Kai'Sa player to really think through
their lines. And this is going to be a
very, very fun match up to watch.
>> I'm excited. And we don't have to wait
long cuz I'm hearing that the players
are ready. So, let's send it over to the
round seven feature match. We have two
more ahead of us. And this is going to
be a fun. We have Starring and Abandoned
Hall. Again, two battlefields that are
great for both of these players. Uh if
you have manage to take advantage of
this as the Kaisa player,
>> then that is obviously something that
you can force Diana to kind of do some
different math as well. But this is
obviously going to be it's Diana's
[music] cream of the crop battlefield.
>> Yeah, I'm also hearing uh some audios uh
you know issues being sorted out on
stage, but looks like they are now all
sorted. Game one underway here for our
seventh round feature match. One more on
the day and then we're going into day
two. So, a lot of players eagerly uh
awaiting their next couple rounds are
hoping that they're able to get into
that day number two as the game has
started. And watchful sentry for Dark
Lero.
>> Yeah, I feel like I'm watching an
Origins RQ, right? Picture perfect
sentry on one for Kai'Sa. But this is
where you have to be a little careful
because there's a lot of backline
pressure that the Kai'Sa can apply
depending on the list they're running
and just tapping out to player Diana is
very risky. Yeah, things like Starfall
can immediately snipe that out. We know
that guys love that. I believe it was at
least a two of, if not a three of in uh
Dark Louis's build. Um, taking a look
here.
>> Star Falling Star is a three of There we
go. Yes, there we go.
>> It's just as an efficient card with the
fact that you don't have to recycle two
because of your Kaiser, right? It's
pretty much two in a power to deal three
twice wherever you kind of want.
>> Very, very efficient card. But we're
going to go for the first point here
with the watchful sentry and then
actually pass with four up. Terrifying.
>> Yeah, we know that there's hexacray. We
know that there is void seeker as well
in the list as well as a lot of the the
newer spells, things like eclipse coming
out.
>> Dantrica.
>> So, we're going to Oh, and the moonfall
off the top.
>> Pretty good spell.
We're going to stack deck as well to
pump the Diana. Dana is going to be at
four might now after this stack deck
resolves cuz of the abandoned hall.
>> Mhm.
>> So a bit out of range of that hexac.
>> Exactly. Important for that
specifically.
>> Now hexac ray would still make a trade
with the uh watchful sentry which would
also get the one might bonus from the
abandoned hall.
>> A good one as well. Yeah.
>> Eclipse a newer addition to the arsenal.
Reaction speed give a unit minus four
this turn. The reaction speed is really
really solid on that. But the hard
bargain comes out. Yeah, we there's one
of the hard bargains out, but again,
this is not terrible because
>> you can try to force a trade here.
Actually, you don't have enough anymore,
right? Because we have the abandoned
hall trigger. That's going to make it a
five.
>> The hex tech ray doesn't really push you
down and you don't have enough for that
stupify either.
>> Hexray would still do three and then it
would pump the sentry to two.
>> Oh, correct.
>> So, it would be enough.
>> This is exactly a trade.
>> And there it is. Yeah. So, Hex Ray will
come out as long as Dark Lero will
actually trigger the abandoned hall.
puts the might on it. There we go.
>> Just to double check, um, even if this
is no longer here, when combat resolves,
it will heal.
>> Uh, yes.
>> We're looking to perhaps ride the wind
or flash, uh, is what I'm judging based
on the question they just asked the the
judge.
>> Uh, and showdown.
>> Very, very good play here. Solid. Yeah.
So, the showdown ends. heal uh uh units
heal at the end of the combat and uh
even though no units died, heal still
goes through. You can just rescend the
ready Diana in solid play from LSanity.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And this is again the we said it
at the beginning. It's a battle of tempo
and that's exactly what we're seeing
where we need to protect this Diana. We
need to score some points. And we did
that over all over a watchful sentry.
>> Yeah. Right. That's kind of crazy to
think about. But I would say that that's
decent still for the Kai'Sa because
yeah, we can just accelerate in a Kai'Sa
survivor.
>> Clear out the uh Diana, get a draw, and
Lanity had to use a decent amount of
cards to pull that play off. Now, we do
know that there's the Moonfall in hand,
so that is known information.
>> Uh and a great card to uh deal with
certain board states, but just
establishing.
>> Yeah, we're just going to develop here.
It's totally fine. We do have that uh
that Moonfall like you mentioned. So we
can go to the Starring if we need to and
we can kind of set up there. Obviously
Kaisan the abandoned hall is going to
pull herself back. But again Moonfall is
a card so she might not be very safe on
that backline and I wouldn't be
surprised to see Dark Lero also sort of
set up. But I mean Singularity is a
beautiful card to have here when you're
tapped out. Yes, you have to recycle.
Well, you're just paying Singularity's
regular cost cuz you're never mind.
>> It's the normal Singularity cost. Uh,
fantastic use of singularity here.
Moonfall is still a threat, but with no
units on the board for Lsanity. He's
also going to have to find some other
way to get out to a battlefield here.
And it's just going to be
>> How about we do
>> developing? Yeah. Round two.
>> This time it's a merchant instead of a
Raven Bloom student. But find me another
singularity,
>> right? I I I mean, at this point, that
would be crazy. But think about the one
for two trade plus, you know, getting
through the ride the wind and still
getting the draw off the Watchful
Sentry. Feels like uh Dark Luise is just
going to be so far ahead in card economy
at this point.
>> Yeah, Kai Kais' doing what Kais' has
having a full grip of cards in uh in his
hand. Uh so many different options. I
think I see a smoke screen. I think I
see a stupify as well. Hex Ray and we
have one available uh to use. But no,
actually, yeah, we're going to develop a
massive board in the back.
>> That is pretty intimidating. Two Raven
Bloom students to use proactively on
your turn. And Kai'Sa, you're going to
be slinging a lot of spells. So these
guys could realistically get up to like
five, six might, let alone the abandoned
hall if you're attacking into that and
then doing combat tricks.
>> Yeah, I'm looking at the hand. I think I
see three different one. I see two
stupifies and a hex tech ray. So that
alone gives your Raven Bloom students
five might. And you're drawing two cards
off those stupifies as well.
>> Yeah. So Insanity will advance the Vex
Apathetic into the Watchful Sentry and
then use the Moonfall. We knew that this
Moonfall was in hand. It was going to
happen eventually.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, this Kai is going to get
uh pumped down to two might and then the
watchful sentry for combat damage
purposes will be at zero. Even though it
does technically go into the negative,
but this is where you have to kind of
figure out how are we going to deal with
this Vex, right? There's a million runes
untapped here on the side of Insanity.
Not a ton of cards in hand though. So, I
think Dark Lo's asking himself, does he
have it?
>> Yeah,
a lot of runes up still. Is that eight?
I believe eight for Linsanity right now.
And uh gives you a lot of options. I
mean, you already have the merchant, so
that's going to be enough to at least
get another point on the abandoned hall.
>> But this is the second Vex Apathetic
committed. So if Dark Louise can get
through this one, then you kind of
imagine a lot of people are only on two
of those in the main deck.
There's the Hex Tech Ray.
>> That's three damage.
Uh pass back.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, we are going to trade
here. Let's like Oh, yeah. Uh I draw a
card.
>> Okay,
>> that's fine.
>> Only one point scored. The merchant will
move in and discard acceptable losses.
Yeah, not going to expect a lot of
gears.
>> And here he comes. The staple of the
deck. The reason why Diana is so
popular, I I would argue, is what a
phenomenal card. And this is where if
you're Kai'Sa,
>> I think the name of the game here is try
to remove this way before he can start
moving.
>> Mhm.
>> Linsanity like that. That's the uh the
positive of Hoy is what you can get done
when it's moving around the board. But
the downside is that it doesn't have
deflect. It doesn't really have a
defensive option. There are three runes
up for Linsanity. potentially something
like a a hard bargain could be in hand,
but I think that's one card in hand if
I'm seeing that correctly.
>> Yeah, it looks like they hit a card at
the battlefield. They played the Hay.
They had three in hand uh during that
showdown.
>> Okay, this is very nice.
>> Tide Turner will swap with the Hay. Oh.
Oh, and also trigger the Starring moving
back the Tide Turner. Oh, wait. No,
moving back the Merchant Ter. Yes. Yes.
>> Very heads up play here by Linsanity.
>> Hay will then move. So it draws and then
we'll discard a card.
>> So we discarded the Fizz and then we're
going to eclipse the Raven Bloom.
>> Nice.
So Hay gets the bonus might for
discarding a uh creature unit and then
the eclipse will give the minus four to
the Raven Bloom. Easy combat win for
Linsanity.
>> Yeah. So we have an eight might who has
>> one might reduction from Yeah. Just plus
two is totally fine here. You're not too
right. That's points.
>> Both players just confirming the current
points and boards. Sale Insanity has no
runes up.
>> Dark Louise still has the play on this
turn.
>> Can you clear this way?
>> Another Stupify would put Hay to six.
And if you do manage to top deck the
Falling Star, it's not looking terrible.
>> Yeah.
>> Other options. Uh there is the thousand
tail watcher. You could just uh play
that and then I guess still not enough.
Yeah, if if you had one more energy that
would feel really good to trade with
Hoi. Letting the Hi live a turn can be
really scary especially on the star
spring cuz Linsanity can play a unit to
the star spring, move the Hoy back and
then move the Hi again and get two
triggers off of it.
>> Yeah, and right now we have Lanity
predict
>> with one card in hand. Did you have to
start trying to take it or
>> insanity asking the judges if he can
still use the predict from the eclipse?
>> I don't believe any actions have
happened since that
>> he merchant. Yeah, he did merchant after
the eclipse. He responded to his
merchant with the eclipse. So
>> the top of his deck
>> has changed from when the eclipse
>> a lot of move shenanigans in the list. A
lot of units do stuff when they move.
>> Move do this deck.
>> Think about it. Quay's basically just a
fancy merchant, you know.
>> Yeah, maybe it's the merchant's teacher.
>> Ooh,
>> and we're just going to develop the
4Runner. I again, I don't hate this
either. Uh, if we really we don't really
care about getting the fifth point. I
think we can keep our raven blue home
and use it for a big swing on the next
turn with the 4Runner and perhaps a, you
know, thousand tail watcher, a stupify,
something like that. Uh, we are letting
the Hay kind of bounce around a little
bit, but again, it depends if we have
another unit in hand to play down onto
that star spring. But this is really big
for Linsanity specifically if he has the
unit cuz then you can move draw a card.
If you discard a spell, you draw another
and then you can get another movement.
And Lanity was falling behind in card
advantage. So this is an opportunity for
Linsanity to get back some of that card
advantage. Get back into the game and
even up the points as well. Now we have
to be careful about when we move this
merchant as well depending on what the
one card in our hand is. We don't want
to get rid of a a card we really want or
a card that we want to use as discard
fodder for the Hay. And it looks like we
didn't draw a unit because we're just
going to bring Qui home and then
trigger.
>> Now, what's the discard going to be?
Ideally, you want to pitch like a lowc
cost spell. Something like, I don't
know, a Gust or uh Moonfall. Okay.
>> Moonfall is a target for Fizz, so it's
not completely dead when it hits the
trash, but
>> there was one already in there though,
which is the unfortunate part.
>> Yeah.
>> And it looks like Tide Turner in. That's
basically a sacrificial unit. You don't
really care at this point if it survives
or not. So, I could imagine Lanity just
passing from here. Haven't gotten a good
look in the hand.
>> I see a gust. Looks like a ride the
wind. Maybe
>> it might just be movement uh spells.
Yeah, there's a ride the wind for sure.
>> Processing here. If you want to dig, you
could like ride the wind back up to the
star spring draw. You haven't triggered
the Star Spring, so you could still play
a unit there and move away again.
>> Like there are options for Linanity
here, but it's basically like do you
want to save those options for a later
turn? Okay, we're going to
>> Yep.
>> Now, is there a unit drawn? Cuz then
again, play it to the Star. Move way
back. You can still move.
>> Oh, okay.
>> That's all three in the trash now.
>> But you're drawing a lot. Every time you
discard a spell, you draw an extra card,
so it's a plus one.
>> And we did draw a unit. Looks like we
drew that Raven Bloom.
>> Okay,
this is I I love that we're getting to
see Linsanity show the power of Hi. This
is what Hay uh potential looks like is
when you're able to move it multiple
times in one turn and just kind of it is
your engine. It's your big unit that
punches and it's your draw power.
>> Now, we're going to go again cuz we Why
not at this point?
>> So, ready? Unless you want to save it
for the next turn, like if he doesn't
have enough spells in hand to protect
it.
>> So, we've moved away three times this
turn. All three times we've discarded a
spell.
>> So, we've drawn six cards this turn.
>> This is our now seventh card that we've
drawn on top of the one that we've
drawn, eighth card that we've drawn.
>> And this is the ideal one that you want
to discard cuz Stupify essentially it
usually it just turns into a draw one
anyway. Uh with abandoned hall it
actually can do a little more but
at least for now it was just the draw
and it looks like another superfy in
handic
>> and was that
>> there's a star cross bounce. Yeah,
bounce the tide turner
>> and then what could that be?
>> I'm curious why we left the merchant
home. We didn't bring the merchant to
the hall and then bounce the tide turner
and hide it at the hall so you can
>> swap swap into the hall. Yeah.
>> Well, again, we didn't really see the
rest of their hand. We know there was a
ride the wind they use. I know there's a
gust in hand and a stupify, but I'm not
sure what else. So, I'm not sure if
we're maybe trying to hold the cards
that we have. Obviously, a Raven Bloom
gusted at the right time is good, but
Kai'Sa also has access, excuse me, to
reaction speed spells that can kind of
pump the Raven Bloom outside of the uh
Gust sort of
>> Yeah.
>> uh window,
>> make it bigger, so Gust will not
actually resolve.
>> But we already knew about the Thousand
Tail in hand for a dark Louis Arrow. I'm
expecting that that is one of the big
push plays with only one rune up and
you're basically just expecting that to
be the tide turner. There's not a lot of
hidden cards that Diana would play
outside of the tide turner. Trying to
think of any really. Maybe like a oneup
switcheroo if they're having fun.
>> Yeah, if they're just having a good
time.
>> Wages of pain. Things like that.
>> But yeah.
>> Yeah. Accelerating the Watcher. We know
it's a Well, we're almost know it's a
tie turner. Yeah. Hit in there. So,
we're just going to kind of push into
that Starring minus three on the Hay
minus one on the Raven Bloom student.
>> There it is. uh screen. So, no move
targets.
>> Yeah, we're still moving the H. We're
still keeping them safe. Yeah.
>> And now the Hay can proactively try and
punch back in on that Thousand Tail
later.
>> Draw comes in. You have to discard off
the Hoy. Let's see what the discard is
for Lynanity.
And with the Thousand Tail minus on the
uh Raven three defending seven
currently, I believe.
>> Yep. Titer did come in after the the uh
watcher trigger, but it's not going to
matter. They're going to get cleaned up
here. We're going to go to five for Dark
Louise. Pretty free for him to go try to
push for that abandoned hall. It's also
very safe to go on abandoned hall cuz
you can play anything.
>> Yeah.
>> Get your Raven Bloom up to four.
>> Pretty good. Pretty good.
>> Quake can clear regardless.
>> Correct. So you're a I think it's still
the correct call because you want to be
able to win in one turn on the following
turn, but this does kind of feel like a
sacrifice for Ren Bloom. Um the only
thing that really checks the way right
now would be specifically stupify cuz
then you go to four, they go down to
four, but you have to imagine Lanni will
have any spell to play to pump up on
that abandoned hall.
>> Yeah. Also, [snorts] if you force Dark
Louis's hand first and you force him to
play the stupify [snorts] and then with
the stupify and the abandoned hall
trigger on the chain, you can then gust
before the mic gets added to kind of
clear the way for you as well. So, it's
very much, you know, two cowboys just
holding up and who's going to shoot
first?
>> Who who draws?
>> Was it Han or Greo?
[laughter]
>> Age. Yeah,
>> age old debate.
>> I don't know. Yeah.
>> All right. Eight might attack seven.
There's a stupify. Uh, is that is that
good?
>> There's the hard bargain. And that is
the second hard bargain played. So,
Insanity should have no more of those
left for things like the time warp,
which we had highlighted before. Now,
>> respond to my trigger.
>> Respond to the move trigger. Okay.
>> Did dark Louis arrow uh get get the plus
two on the Raven Bloom?
>> Uh, it got countered.
>> Okay. True. Yes. The spell never
resolved. That's a good point.
>> Mhm.
>> So, the stupify plus uh traveling
merchant will actually be enough to beat
over the Raven Bloom.
Suddenly, Lynsanity takes a commanding
position on the board, hiding another
unit at the Starring. Expecting that to
still be something like a tide turner,
but again with the Star Spring
activation, you can move the Hay back
and keep it protected. This is why Hay
is so strong. Linsanity was behind on
points, behind on units, behind on cards
in hand. Had one card in hand to start
that one turn. And Drew, how many was
it? Seven off of the Hay in one turn.
>> It was uh nine total. That is crazy how
much work Hay put in to get Lanity back
into this game. This card is incredible.
>> It was Yeah, we had four moves. We all
pitched spells. So that's eight cards
plus the card we drew for turn. So nine
cards in that turn.
>> The normal move, the ride the wind, the
placement for the Starring the next
move. Yeah. And then on Dark Liz Arrow's
turn, it was the tie turn to move back
with Starring again. So if you want to
say kind of like 11 cards
>> 11 cards in one turn next turn. Yeah.
>> Yep. Oh,
>> this is why when I talk to players and
they're like, "What do I do against
Diana?" I say, "You see a Hay and you
kill a
>> You kill immediately on site." Yeah.
Let's see what Dark Lizer has as a
rebuttal. Looks like a thousand tail
watcher.
>> Going to have to probably respect the
hidden card here if I had to guess.
I mean, there's also six runes up.
>> Yeah. And I believe Lanity has two in
hand.
Two in hand, it looks like.
with a bunch of runes ready to go.
>> Yeah, I mean this could be a lot of
things. Eclipse, great card. Smokecreen,
if you read that they're on something
like that. Sometimes I still see those
pop up in lists.
>> What's kind of interesting here is I if
I'm not mistaken, I don't think I saw
him discard his gust. So he could just
gust his way back to hand. [laughter]
>> True. He could
>> starcross works too. and Starcross might
that's enough to win because then
Linsanity on the next turn reveals the
tide turner or the merchant moves back
the hoy goes and reconquers the
abandoned hall darker understands that
says let's go next game GG Linsanity
takes game one
>> and like we talked about earlier right
it's battle of the tempo right it's
whoever kind of gets that swing Kai'Sa
was in a very very good spot and that's
what Kai'Sa does best is it kind of just
eats away at your resources either
through car outv valing you for cards in
hand or getting rid of your board
through kill uh for damage spells, but
we saw Quay did what Quay does and
refilled the hand of Insanity to allow
him to come back into the game.
>> And I think one of the big pivotal
moments that Dark Lewis arrow is going
to be thinking back on here as we get
ready for game two is like using the
singularity to clear the two units felt
good at the time, but then once a hits
the board, you're like, "Ooh, I kind of
wish I had that singularity for the
way." So maybe saving that next time.
With arena's greatest, you already have
a point. This should be uh better for
Dark Lazarero uh in terms of tempo to be
able to close the game out faster. So,
this is interesting. Uh, we have a
falling star in hand and only one fury
rune. But with Kai'Sa,
>> we can just matter.
>> We can get rid of that Diana if we think
it's going to be a big threat or we
might hold this falling star like you
mentioned for that Hay when we see it.
>> We can fall. We can do the origin
special where we falling star into a
Noxis hopeful.
>> Um, but again, we do have a hex tech. We
have options here, but I think we're
really trying to develop this Noxis
hopeful. So, we do have to play
something. And if we do, there might not
be an opportunity for us to hex right.
>> I see time warp in hand as well. So we
have late game secured in terms of like
a clear win condition.
It's going to be about controlling the
early game. I don't hate the idea of
just sniping this. I know that could
come out on the next curve, but you have
the hopeful, you have the hex ray to try
and deal with that at that time. Let's
see what darker's decision is.
>> Oh, hard bargain. Okay. Looking for Oh,
no. We're tapped out. Okay. Yeah,
Gust actually might have been nicer
because Dark Lero would be like, "Okay,
well, I'm just going to play Watchful
Sentry [laughter]
and then the Nox is hopeful."
>> Yeah, that would have been really good
for Darkness actually
>> in
>> with perfect information.
>> It's kind of funny to think about that,
right? You're like, "Okay, cool. You
basically just minus one and I
reestablish or re uh create the board."
You could also just play the hopeful for
four and just not leave any uh runes up.
doesn't feel as good, but in a pinch
that's what part of like the
adaptability of that card is it's still
a four energy for might. Not the worst
curve.
>> Yeah, not the worst curve. You keep that
falling star. Dark Louis Zero obviously
knows how punished he got by that Hay.
So,
>> I think we're just holding it until we
have a second answer and then we can
kind of use that second answer to get
rid of the Diana or keep that second
answer for the Quay. Uh we do see a
Moonfall in Hannah. I think that was a
star cross as well. So you kind of had a
window to get rid of the Diana and Or if
we do tap out to play a then there is a
world where you get absolutely punished
for it.
>> Yeah, sing with Giga punish that.
>> Yeah, I think Lynsanity is going to keep
up star cross runes if I had to guess.
>> I would imagine if you're 6 and0 you've
probably gotten very comfortable certain
matchups. That's a ride the wind off the
Diana.
>> So the spell will be added to hand.
We're going to get a card draw here off
the sentry dying.
Debating maybe moonfalling this Noxis
hopeful looks like
and yep, that's exactly what we're going
to do for Lindsanity. Get rid of the
development. So, we pretty much just
took a turn off if you think about it
for Kai'Sa. Uh, and we Lindsanity was
able to get onto even points now, which
is important in this arena greatest
game. It allows you to go a little bit
slower at the beginning unless you're
really trying to blitz down. Ooh, Vex
Apathetic was visioned and then put at
the bottom and that means that that is a
flash added to hand. But also important
to note the uh Starcross is not live
anymore. There's only one rune up. So
this could be an opportunity for Dark
Louise to snipe. But I think that
Insanity that was a pretty good sequence
of plays. Now we're going to bring the
Kai'Sa in. And we left one available for
the trigger.
>> We're going to reveal Quay. Leave him on
top.
>> Okay.
>> And now we reward we're rewarded, right,
for keeping that falling star in hand.
However, if you actually look at the
runes, we're going to we don't have
enough to Hay and Ride the Wind.
>> Yeah. Or Hay and Hard Bargain. So,
playing that Hay at at all is kind of
scary for Linsanity. I would be
surprised if he does drop it. I'd expect
more like just drop a couple two energy
units. Maybe that Vex Apathetic in hand.
And there we go. Yeah, it makes sense if
they're going to snap the Vex apathetic.
And again, like a singularity here, you
have to, you know, pay the deflect cost
and then you're kind of baiting it out
for the Hi on a future turn. I think
this is fine for Insanity here, but it
does mean [snorts] Dark Louise is going
to get ahead in points. Holds for four,
can potentially get a fifth, but not
even pressure to could just move back to
Kai'Sa. And there's one Moonfall already
used. You can expect reasonably that
there's not going to be another one in
the immediate future, although there's a
lot of cards in Lanity's hand, so it's
not against the cards. Now, we do go to
eight next turn, so we can do some funky
stuff with that Hay as well. So, we have
to keep in mind that our opponent might
potentially just draw five cards
randomly next turn by by playing Hay.
So, we have to take into account the
current what looks like four or five
cards in hand plus an additional maybe
three or four that could maybe be drawn
based on what we've seen get recycled to
the bottom.
>> And I just huge development turn which I
absolutely love this from Dark Louise.
>> Yeah, I mean in Linsanity best case
scenario for points will just equalize
with Dark Louise. And now Dark Louise
has so many units that it's going to be
really hard for Linsanity to conquer and
then hold both of them.
That's already what 6 10 14 might
represented attacking because of the
assaults on the infernos.
>> Now we do have to play this very smart
here. If we're Lanity, we want to make
sure we leave runes up for, you know, a
hard bargain, a a star cross, anything
that's going to allow us to kind of
protect our units.
>> Uh but we also try to we need to develop
now, right? We're just absolutely losing
>> the math on the might on the board. So,
we need to devel
available. Ho's going out to the base,
not to the battlefield. Three runes are
still up. I always think it would go to
the battlefield and then Oh, maybe a
merchant. [laughter]
I was going to wait to the battlefield
because then you can flash it back in a
pinch to protect it. Um, but Lanity is
going to opt instead to just place the
Vex Apathetic at the arena's greatest.
Quite a base. Has not moved the Raven
Bloom student yet and actually passes
turn. They're not going to even try and
put the student to the uh rockfall pass
to get an extra point.
>> Yeah, this is now kind of helping Quay
get over that falling star.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. So you can tide Turner in
response to the falling star, bring the
Hay in, pump him with discarding a unit,
and then if you really need to flash him
back to give him another plus three
>> or um Starcross as well.
>> Yep. Put him back in your hand at least
for now.
Let's see what Dark Louise has
available. It's going to be very hard to
clear this way. A little easier to clear
the Vex, you'd have to imagine. and Dark
Louise. All he has to do is score two
points here and he can deal with the Hoy
on a future turn as well.
>> We do have a Brin here in the hand for
Isa.
>> Oh, is that something? Yeah, if you just
straight up Brin here and that will
pretty much force the Tide Turner cuz
you expect the star uh or the falling
star I would imagine at that point.
>> Yep.
>> That'll pump the Hay to eight. But then
Hay's at the battlefield and here we go.
>> Here comes Tide Turner.
>> Swaps. Quay will draw a card and then
discard a card and that's
>> a unit still on the chain
>> flash. Yep.
>> Okay. So reacts with the first reaction
and then uh on the next activation of
the chain he goes for the flash pulling
back the units. Hay gets another move.
This will keep Hay and Vex alive.
>> All right, we're going to get rid of the
star cross. Interesting.
>> I would imagine you have another in hand
at this point. You've drawn so many
cards as an insanity. But this does mean
that Dark Louise can just send in like
two Inferno.
Maybe maybe like Kai'Sa and an Inferna
if you want the draw cuz it's almost the
same might attacking. But the point
being you're going to go to six. You're
not going to commit that many units to
do so and you still have a lot of
resources in hand. So Dark Louise can uh
at least threaten Linsanity with a fast
game. Lanity is going to need a couple
of turns to win cuz you're not going to
hold for a point here. You would go up
to five and then seven. It's going to
take three more turns for Lanity to win.
Dark Louise, if he gets two points here,
we'll only need one more.
>> Yeah. And we have to keep in mind, too,
we have that time warp in hand, right?
So,
>> that's a really good point, actually.
Yeah.
>> If we can play around that hard bargain,
we could set up a double conquer like
you mentioned with the Inferno.
>> Let the Lanity kind of spread out on the
battlefields he wants to spread out on.
It's not really a danger zone if we go
to seven points and then all of a sudden
time warp hits the table.
>> Exactly. You don't with the time warp,
you don't have to conquer two
battlefields on the next turn. As long
as you uh have enough runes to either
pay the hard bargain cost or just kind
of force sanity to uh exhaust beyond
being able to hard bargain, then you
just conquer the one time warp. You win
the game that way. How does Dark Louise
want to approach it? Taking his time to
think. We're on game two and uh still 29
minutes on the clock. So, I think taking
your time to think here does make sense.
This is going to be most likely the most
important uh turn in the series here.
>> He doesn't love his position right now.
He does have a Darius in his hand.
Unfortunately, he doesn't have enough to
develop it. Nothing at the battlefield
to hit with Hexte Ray. Your options
really are kind of just are you going to
play the falling star or you just going
to try to get your fifth and sixth point
and move on?
>> Cuz if you falling star, I mean, I guess
you just hit Vex twice and you do. That
doesn't feel great.
>> Three. Yes. You could hit the tide
turner uh Raven Bloom, but then Insanity
still has a rune up. So like any stupify
or something will save the Raven Bloom.
>> Uh
nine of runes right now.
>> Pass.
Dark Louise chooses to pass. Not going
to conquer two and go to six points.
>> Going to try to do that next turn. I
think is going to try to put We're going
to be at 11 runes if I'm not mistaken
next turn. Looks like we have nine, six
exhausted, three ready. So, you kind of
have to be able to conquer both with
only using one rune, which is going to
be very difficult if we're trying to
time warp.
>> Yeah, I I guess if you're trying to do
the time warp at the the six ramp, but
that is tough. That is hard to pull off.
Let's see if Dark Louise is rewarded for
the attempt.
Yeah, we could also just send everything
to one battlefield, pass the turn,
protect it from being broken with stuff
like maybe putting a Darius there as
well, just make a ton of might on that
one battlefield and then when we get the
turn pass back to us, we can time warp.
So, there's a little bit of options
here.
>> I'd go to five and the time warp. You
hold for six, time warp for seven.
That's still not enough unless you have
like double time warp at that point.
I feel like uh moments like this is when
I always just think back to what is a
deck's strength. You have Darius's, you
have infernos, you hit harder than you
defend for. So I I wouldn't be a fan of
a attempt to hold and defend a point.
Um, but the idea of punch in, take both
battlefields, and then time warp makes a
little more sense to me. It's just I
don't know if you have enough. I Let's
do the math here. It's going to be 10,
14, 19 might attacking in. That is
actually quite a lot. I think that is
enough assuming we don't you know have
pumps or uh you can't gust the infernos
cuz the moment they enter combat they
just automatically
they become three might. Yeah.
>> And we don't have an abandoned hall or
anything like that. So if you can you do
have to play around gust it does swing
it three-way.
>> Uh and now we're just going to split the
battlefields it looks like. And we
haven't even exhausted any runes right.
So if we're developing more units it
throws the math off as well for the
Kai'Sa. But let's say we're playing to
base and not to those battlefields. So
maybe not super scared of the time warp
just yet, but it looks like we're hiding
another card, which I can only assume
might be another tie turner.
>> Yeah, so far that's the only hidden that
we've seen. And you know, I've been uh
saying how surprised I am at some of the
plays here, but I think it's important
to also highlight the fact that Dark Liz
is 6 and0. Clearly has been playing very
well. So I'll almost always default to
just say, "Yeah, the player has an idea.
Maybe I haven't seen the line, but you
got to respect the decision-m that
they've had." And there's a thousand
tail off the top. That's a good card.
You're not going to accelerate it
because the Vex Apathetic is at a battle
field. So, this is not going to be able
to come in uh and do any damage this
turn unless you would try to clear the
Vexpathetic first. But with that many
runes up, I think that this makes sense.
Now, pretty much any one of our like
infernas or the Noxis hopeful can just
go in and start trading with the board.
Now,
>> we just have to be careful, right? There
is a world where that's the one of
Kha'Zix that's in the deck that's hidden
as well.
>> So, we have to be careful of that. the
mutating horror Kha'Zix which is a form
might
>> also hidden
>> it's got ambush it's got the uh
>> oh ambush excuse me I always think it
has hidden for some reason
>> well because yeah you know ambush hidden
about the same thing
>> they're spooky is what
>> they are spooky they come out of nowhere
but it could have it in hand because
there is enough runes up currently for
lsanity to pull that one off
>> but we definitely have something spicy
hidden there and it looks like it's
probably going to be a tide turner which
is going to make do things again
>> do things let's see
what unit is sent in. Sending multiple
if you expect the tide turner could
almost guarantee that the HY goes down.
Uh or at least like something like a
flash has to be uh committed for the Hoy
to stay alive. Cuz if you just send in
like one inferna and then the Titan
swaps with the Hoy, the Hay can pump
himself back up to five and the Inferno
is not going to be able to trade with
him anymore. It would still trade with
the Vex and it looks like Dark Liz is
actually going to opt for that line.
And notably, this isn't damage that the
Watcher did. It just reduced might. You
don't care about going in. There's no
healing that's going to happen. You just
want to make things unfavorable for uh
Diana. You want them to use their
resources here because you do have
essentially a four-point swing in your
hand with the time warp if you can get
on those battlefields.
>> Yeah. I mean, that you're not going to
be able to play it because of the
thousand tail coming down. Yeah. But if
you can just conquer both of these, then
the next turn you have a lot of might.
like that thousand tail being on the
field and lsanity I think now that I
think back on it dark not going for
those two points realize the lensity
needed three turns to win like you have
some time to play as Dark L as long as
you get two points this turn if you
don't get two points this turn I think
that's when you start to sweat
>> yeah that's where it becomes dangerous
right obviously we we know that
Linsanity isn't running time warp right
so there is exactly uh at least two more
turns that we need to play if we want to
win on lsanity side but now we're just
kind of in the tank trying to figure out
what are we doing are we going to bring
that
way over. Does that punish us? Right?
Because there is also
>> a falling star in hand that we know of
for Dark Lin. Everything is very primed
now into falling star range because of
that Watcher.
>> But if you start, you know, forcing out
baiting out some of the uh energy costs
of cards in hand, maybe they run out of
energy for that uh hard bargain. And
even one hard bargain won't be enough to
stop it. So, as long as you get the uh
Diana under three, three energy or
lower, then you can just snipe the Hay
at that point. That feels pretty good
for Dark Louise.
And I think we'd still be No, it would
be at 11 runes again cuz we paid the one
energy cost for the Thousand Tail.
>> Exactly. Yeah, we'd be back to We only
paid one, right? So, we might
>> And then you'd pay another one for the
uh the falling star. Correct. I believe
that would put us at uh or put Dark
Louise at 11. But let's see what's
happening here on the board.
>> The Gust comes out. Yeah, we're gusting
our
our uh tide turner, excuse me, and we're
going to tie turner and move them over.
I think this is okay. I think this is
what
>> this is play.
>> Oh, trigger.
>> Yeah, it's just play.
>> I know.
>> You can't move units there. You can't
move units from there. You just cannot
play units. So, if you had a hidden unit
there, you could not play reveal it and
play it to that battle.
>> You could reveal it. You wouldn't be
able to play it. So, it just go back to
being hidden.
>> Okay. Oh, is that [laughter] actually
what would happen?
>> Yes.
>> Oh, that's very funny. And then when you
lose control of the battlefield, then it
would finally move to the trash. But it
would just be stuck there hidden until
you lose control of that battlefield,
which is pretty funny.
>> Here comes the falling star. So it is uh
hard bargainable. Unsanity could throw
that out at uh repeat cost and make sure
that that Hoy does not die to it, but
then the Hoy would die to something else
cuz there are at least uh the Inferno
plus a Noxis Hopeful that could swing in
and take it out. Oh,
>> do we not have a hard bargain in hand?
And if if no hard bargain, that's even
worse for Linsanity here.
>> I know we have a star cross, so I think
we're debating a star cross, but next
turn, can we start? We have a ride, so
we can get active with our Quaz again.
But looks like we're just going to let
him hit the trash.
>> It's tough. Like what do you starcross?
Do you star cross the Noxis hopeful? It
comes right back. Do you start cross the
Kai'Sa? It can accelerate. Do you star
cross the Brin here, the thousand tail?
Like, right. Like
>> you generally don't start. Yeah, the
Inferno can ambush in as it's like
really tough to nothing on that board
you wanted to start cross. So, I guess I
understand letting it go. I think that
Dark Louise has found a really good
line, really good avenue in here to the
game. Still five runes up. Linsanity can
keep playing. Bhier is going to go in.
>> Ride the wind.
>> I don't know. Like
>> I I think we're trying to bring these uh
students in.
>> Oh, you think so? But we do we know that
there is a hex ray in hand, right? But I
think we're trying to bring those
students in if I'm not mistaken. You
bring that student in. We're at four
might student. We're at six to the five.
We get rid of the brin here. Oh, we're
actually bringing it to the arena.
>> Interesting. Okay, so opting to score a
fifth point if this survive or rather a
sixth point here. If it holds, it would
go to seven.
>> Cannot imagine it holds.
>> You play that in
sorry
>> the star cross in hand.
>> So he's at four, right?
>> Oh, okay. Dark just doing some math
here. four damage to it
>> and double
>> connect ray.
>> Okay, saying I am not going to waste a
unit. I am not going to crash multiple
things in there. I'm not going to play
the gambit. I'm just going to clear this
with two spells.
That's awesome. [laughter] I'm not going
to lie, this is I think this is why Dark
Louise is six though. I would have never
seen that. I would have been like, uh,
what am I doing now? Like I just let him
score a six and do something else after,
I guess. But the double hex ray, you
still have your inferno back. You still
have your watcher back. You still have
your hopeful back. And now you're asking
your opponent to answer with just a
Raven Bloom
>> and break both your battlefields or else
they're in a really bad spot.
>> And Lanity can't even win on their turn.
Like if they find some crazy line, no,
they have to score three points to win.
>> Dark Louise, the patient play pays off.
Did not go for the double score. Saved
the units. could have been at six points
at the start of this turn, pushed for
eight to win the game. Instead, said,
"Nope, I'm just going to keep every unit
alive on my field. My opponent needs
three turns to win. I can play the
patient game." And uh yeah, I think Dark
Luise is going to take this game, too.
>> Yeah, it's the biggest thing that I that
I think new players can take away from
this is point math.
>> Yeah.
>> Is knowing how many turns you have left.
>> Clock.
>> Yeah. It's the It's the clock. Knowing
how long you have until your opponent
just wins the game. Being able to kind
of map out your turn. And we're seeing
kind of a masterclass of this happening
with both these players. Actually, we
saw Lince Tanity do it in game one. And
now Dark Louise is coming back for their
revenge here in game two to try to force
a game three.
>> And I like this from Dark Louise as
well, putting the Knox hopeful in there,
too. Just like, you know what, nine
might. If you can't clear this, then the
time warp will win. Uh cuz that'll hold
for seven, time warp for eight. Lanity
is going to have to find a way to clear
at least one of these. Maybe a hard
bargain could stop the uh the time warp.
But if you spend the energy on the hard
bargain, then you're probably not going
to have enough to defend against the 10
might attacking in with the watcher and
the inferna.
>> I believe that was an eight count.
>> It should be eight because of the double
hex tech ray coming down
>> or maybe eight or nine. I regardless, he
should have enough for basically just
the time warp on the turn.
But of course, Dark Louise doesn't even
need the time warp to win. If you're
just able to hold one and then conquer
the other, that also works.
And we use that ride the win last turn
to try to score a cheeky sixth point,
which I like, but kind of makes it
awkward at this point. We do have a
starcross still. We have a stupify that
we can try to dig for answers with. We
have a Moonfall that we can try to do
something, but you are you have to get
over these battlefields at one point,
right? Moving in. Maybe you kind of can
move in to the arena's greatest and
moonfall and bring the inferno in. That
also doesn't feel great
>> in the grand scheme of things. It's just
there's a lot of different opportunities
here for Linanity to try to find some
way to break both these battlefields,
one of these battlefields, but very
cognizant of the fact that time warp
might be coming. You're not counting
your opponent's runes and, you know,
stopping on day and being like, "Oh,
okay." If uh you're not kind of
expecting that time warp and the stupify
uh will come out here.
going to try to draw.
Oh, interesting. Okay, we're choosing
the thousand tail watcher, which leads
me to believe we might be trying to get
rid of it through the Moonfall this
turn. So, we're going to give the
Thousand Tail with the base a minus one.
Give our student a plus one. See what we
draw from that stupify and take it from
there.
>> I'm not seeing this to be enough to like
threaten that much on the board. I would
imagine you go into the Kai'Sa, but it
seems like Insanity is actually toying
around with the idea of attacking the
Brin here plus the Noxis. hopeful. I say
that and now it moves up to the top
side. So there it's going to attack the
Kai'Sa.
>> And there's the Moonfall. Looks like
Moonfall runes are being tapped.
>> We have a Baron in the hand too from
Lanity. I just noticed.
>> Wow.
>> I love the the one of Baronss in some
lists or two of depends on the matchup.
>> I mean notably if we didn't really
dismantle their board last turn, they
would have won from this turn with the
Baron.
>> True.
All right, there's the Moonfall coming
down. Going to pull something in. If it
pulls the uh Noxis Hopeful, then it
everything would crash, I believe.
Right. It gives minus two might. So,
yeah, it's going to be the Inferna.
>> That makes a four versus three might
combat here.
And there we go. Raven Bloom takes it.
That's a point till Insanity up to six.
>> This is a rough spot right now. Very
rough.
You're currently losing on board, but
Fizz Moonfall maybe.
>> Okay, that's not bad.
>> Five. Yeah, this will be 524, right? Cuz
the uh our original, excuse me, minus
one from that stupify.
But again, playing to your outs.
Unfortunately, we know that there is a
time warp in the hand for Dark L. And I
don't remember seeing a hard bargain.
>> I don't remember seeing one. If
Linsanity has it, then this game
continues and is actually now maybe in
Linsanity's favor because if Dark Louise
does not win here, Linsanity will hold
for a seventh. Has the Fizz on the
field. If all Louise has is the time
warp.
>> Oh, wait. And then does he only have
nine? I thought he would have had enough
for the time warp. I thought he should
have 10 here.
>> Well, we do have a Darius and a cleave
in our hand, so we can win it origin
style.
>> Do you believe in rebuke? Is it still in
the time? [laughter] I don't I don't
think Rebuke is in this list
unfortunately. That would have been
crazy. And our Diana is also the Squirt
of the Moon Legend is tapped. So, we
cannot use that ability to use the
Starcross. So, we're off Starcross uh
runes as well.
>> Yeah, I guess I just lost track of um
how much power Caused Stark Louise had
spent on the last turn. And it looks
like it is going to be the Darius play
that you were highlighting the classic
Origins. All Origins cards on the field
saved for the Fizz.
>> And we have Jose. Yeah.
That's it.
>> Game two goes to Dark Louise. GG.
Linsanity says, "Yeah, cannot stop it.
We're going to a game three with 14
minutes 20 seconds on the clock.
>> It's going to be a fast one.
>> It's got to It's going to have to be.
>> It's got Yeah, it has to be a fast one.
And I'm, you know, I'm kind of happy
that we saw the
>> Origins closer kind of win out that
game. Little cleaved areas that we
talked about earlier.
>> That was fantastic. Still great cards.
There's a reason Kai'Sa was good back
then. the reason that Kaisa pilots are
still able to make deep runs at regional
qualifiers today.
>> And this is going to be a bloodbath, so
to speak. Targon's Peak and Voidgate.
>> Wow. One of those you want to go to, the
other one not so much.
>> Correct.
>> The other one not.
>> But unfortunately, with 11 minutes left
on the clock, you have to go to both.
>> So, we uh jumped forward in time a
little bit
>> as not that much time on the clock, but
you can see these players are going to
go fast. Sex Ray. Nice response.
And no double spells. If Insanity had
like double stupify or something, could
have saved it. Instead, it's just Diana.
Yeah, this is going to be a Diana to
base again. Danger zone a little bit,
but we know that Diana's kind of like
the red herring in the deck. Some people
go like, "Oh, I got to get rid of their
chosen champion."
>> But the real threat is the Huay, right?
So, save saving that those runes for the
Huay or the Vex as well, right? because
it doesn't let you accelerate your
watchers or your Darius at that point
>> or your uh you know um why am I blanking
on the two two energy inferno. There we
go. Inferno is the ambush.
>> Your ambush. Yep.
>> But another point picked up by Dark
Louise. No point from Lanity as the
Hexac Ray cleared out the Brain Bloom
student. Five energy up still for Dark
Louise. Can try and establish a board.
Can try and you know maybe a Falling
Star. Inferna back to the base. Inferno
back to the base.
>> Yeah, we get to untap two from I guess
we've Well, we might have missed our
trigger, but we did caron speak. So, uh
we could have had two extra runes here,
which might be impactful.
>> That could bite. I mean, things like
void uh um
uh I'm trying blanking again on that
one, too. The day has been so long at
this point. Void Seeker. [laughter]
There we go.
>> Void Seeker. Yeah,
>> one of the popular ones, but uh Dark
Louise did have at least one in the
deck. Not going to be able to play it.
Dargon's Peak has been cleared. Diana
has scored a point. [snorts]
>> Yeah, this is going to be the tempo
battle that we're that we were talking
about earlier. There's the Kha'Zix that
we actually saw off the Diana. So, the
one of Kha'Zix now known information.
So, you know they're going to draw it
whenever they draw their next card.
>> Less scary when the bug's not invisible.
>> Correct. Yeah, who would have thought?
>> Did not evolve the W. I believe it's a
W. Is it the E? I should know this. I'm
a caster.
>> Yeah, I think you play a bit more League
than I do.
>> I do. I do.
>> Was it Mr. Buttkicker?
>> Sir Buttkick.
>> Sir Buttkick. Sorry, put some respect on
your name,
>> please.
>> Speaking of League of Legends, Insanity
actually an ex-pro League of Legends
player. Played on CJ Academy. Uh, played
on Team Pulse, I believe. Um, 100
Thieves Academy as well. So, he's been
around in League of Legends. We're
talking
>> and now putting up results in Riftbound
as well.
>> Putting up results in Riftbound. Yeah. I
I I casted this guy's games. I keep
looking at people like, "It's insanity."
And I make eye contact like everyone's
going to know who this is. And people
are like, "Who?" [laughter] And I'm
like, he played in like 2018.
>> So, just a full conquer pass.
>> Yeah.
>> From uh we did a little stack deck. We
untapped our runes and now we're
passing.
>> Full six runes up for Lynsanity. You can
play a lot of things in response to Dark
Louise's snipe spells. Kaisa loves the
snipes, but Diana can bounce and jump
away from them. Flash can get away from
Xtech Ray. Starcross can get away from
anything pretty much. Yeah, we do have a
hard bargain in hand as well. I got a
little peak. So,
having a bit of protection there as well
on top of the other reaction stuff. And
also, if you do
kind of try to get rid of that Diana in
a combat, uh, and you just bring, you
know, for example, one inferno, you try
to do something cute with it, that
Kha'Zix can just ambush it.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, we know the Kha'Zix's information.
>> Or wait, was that revealed when
Linsanity attacked?
Yeah, but I think we we we did stack
deck.
>> Oh, yes. Yes.
>> So, it could be in the hand.
>> Could be in the hand.
>> Or it couldn't be. But I did think I
think I saw it.
>> I imagine if you leave it on top of your
deck, the stack deck will pick it up.
Yes,
>> probably.
>> I got so excited about my Linsanity
story, I missed the stack today.
[laughter]
>> Should watch more of his gameplay now
than thinking back on his old gameplay.
>> We're in the present. Yes,
>> Rain Bloom comes down. Dark Louise can
just play a more patient game. send one
of these infernus to uh conquer void
gate and just try and match the points
and uh establish a board or could go in
and try and clear the Diana. It looks
like option A for right now.
And there's the Kha'Zix getting ambushed
in
just to try to protect that Diana a
little bit.
>> Curious. I guess you're just trying to
spend the runes cuz otherwise they're
kind of wasted. Yes, you keep the
Kha'Zix in hand, but you didn't
establish anything. You didn't develop
your field at all. This does look really
good for a falling star though.
>> Kind of does.
>> Falling star. Move the inferna in.
>> Yeah, you can pay the um hard bargain
cost as well.
>> Yep.
>> I would hate it. But then again, you
don't have that falling star for the Hi.
If that's the only answer to the Hay.
Sometimes it's really scary to use it at
a time like this
>> and debating it. Yeah. Oh, we're
>> Go ahead. Yeah, we saw the reflection of
do I do this or not and not
[clears throat] not loving his options
just passing the turn over to Lynanity.
>> Well, Dark Louise got burned using the
singularity uh game one not clearing the
way and I think that could be fresh on
the mind of like yeah that's a problem
and even things like flash would be able
to protect the Kha'Zix at the very least
even if the inferno goes in. So
>> can I read this? Sure.
>> Now development huge development for ill
insanity here. Bunch of units hit the
board. Yeah, it's again a development
turn, which is fine because you're both
at two. They can go up to four swinging
over a two point uh deficit. It's not
the end of the world if you're playing
uh if you're playing Diana, especially
since we know that there's a Baron in
the deck as well.
>> And now this is a higher value falling
star here. Clear the Diana and the Eager
Apprentice.
>> Apprentice
as well. Wow.
player, please finish your turn.
>> Maybe assuming, hey, we didn't see Quay
last turn.
>> They just developed, you know,
>> to end of the abandon actually coming
out from Lanity saying not right now,
but maybe later.
>> Maybe later.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. He'll come back to play on a
future turn. So, Singularity goes back
to hand.
>> Cheap counter spell abandon, but it does
mean that the spell is not gone for
good. It can come back again. The Kaisa
Legend is going to be able to make that
cheaper again. and Dark Louise being
very very passive with his units, not
sending in the Inferno to score a point.
In moments like this, I'm always a fan
of like, yeah, just go get the point. It
puts you on the even number. You trade
the Inferno, but you, you know, get
Lanity to come to the board. But no,
Dark Lu has been a very, very patient
player
>> and is holding his units as resources
for as long as possible.
>> Yeah. And actually, we had that predict
as well from the abandon. It has more
text on it than just countering the
spell. And we did see Insanity uh bottom
a stupify. So getting able to again
Diana is the queen of tempo. You counter
their spell and you still get to take a
look at your deck and kind of sculpt
what you want to sculpt here. And now
Lanity is able to kind of push up a
little bit. And there is the but now you
got to be kind of careful. You put the
singularity back in dark in uh Dark L's
hand and you just played out a you're
tapping out now to play an eager
apprentice and a qu
>> I guess. Are you just hoping that they
maybe you have another abandon?
>> Well, we have the Targon's trigger that
does already three or two runes, excuse
me. So, maybe we have a star cost.
>> That could work.
>> Two mind runes were channeled.
Singularity would only cost one because
of the Kaisa legend. And Singularity is
coming down.
>> Yep.
>> Dark L is taking the gambit saying sure
bet.
>> Oh. Oh,
maybe I guess it was a bluff.
>> Interesting. That had to have just been
a bluff from Insanity thinking, "Okay,
if I have three up, he's not going to do
the singularity play cuz obviously I
have something." And Dark L said, "Bet.
I'm just going to do it and gets
massively rewarded." Wow.
>> If you got it, you got it, but I'm going
to do it.
>> Yeah. And then this time remembers the
Targon's Peak Readyy's two runes. I
think
>> there's the Baron.
>> Oh, okay.
the full turn to commit the Baron to the
board.
>> And Baron's very obviously very good
into any deck that tries to
>> snipe
>> snipe because you can't target the
Baron.
>> Cannot do anything about it. And it
buffs all your other units. So these
guys are pretty massive going into that
Raven Bloom student.
>> Yeah, you have to be kind of careful
still because there are four runes ready
for that Kai'Sa. We know there's stuff
like void. We know there stuff like
hexac ray. You have to be careful. They
are. We have a four might Raven Bloom
suit and a five might eager apprentice
because of the Baron's passive buff
giving them plus two might.
>> So we do have kind of nine might to kind
of contend with here.
>> Yeah, Hex Ray would give essentially
four extra damage cuz three from it and
the one for the Raiden Bloom. So you're
going to need more than just one Hex Ray
for Dark Louise.
>> Yeah, this is going to be a rough for
and we do have a Hex Ray but that's
about it in hand.
listening to the players.
>> Notably though.
>> Okay, Dark Louise lets it go.
>> Yeah.
>> I love listening to the players in
moments like that. He was asking cards
in hand. Dark Louise made his choice.
Two points of Insanity for the turn.
Baron has been established on the board.
Six might attacking for Dark Louise.
What was your straw? Time warp. Time
warps big.
>> Darius here plus a card full swing into
Baron does get you over Baron
technically or but it is very very allin
and very risky and see how dark played.
I don't think that's going to happen.
>> Yeah. And and then your your only unit
left alive is in the Baron pit which
then any unit can just go into basically
get there for free. That would be really
rough. Lanity is able to win in one
turn. Now there are three battlefields.
You can hold two
>> and then conquer the void gate. That
would be enough. So I think Dark Louise
needs to factor that in to say I got to
deal with one of these two. Either the
Baron or the other battlefield. It's
just so much might being pumped from
that Baron.
>> Yeah. And again, we know there's a time
warp in hand. So if we are able to kind
of just get to six, right, if we can
clear both battlefields and just leave
that Baron isolated,
we're setting up for a win here. cuz the
Baron doesn't usually do much from this
position. It just kind of sits in the
pit because if it ever leaves the pit,
well, now you can go into the pit and
get more points. Kind of scary.
>> I like this call a lot. So, keep in mind
right now, Eager Apprentice is
technically online
where it's going to cheapen the spells
cost.
Interesting decision to not hexec Ray
before combat and then send Darius in
with the Infernas. It's just the two
infernas and one hexac rays worth of
damage.
>> We're trying to see I think if they tide
turner and bring the baron over I think.
>> Oh yeah, that's a good call
cuz that tie turner would really change
the math on that attack.
>> A moonfall works as well.
>> Oh, that's nasty. You can pull the
Inferno over to the Baron.
>> You can pull the Darius over to the
Baron.
That is a very high impact spell to pull
at this point in time. So now it's three
damage on the eager apprentice. The uh
Raven Bloom student gets pumped one for
the spell going off. So that makes it a
five
>> and then the five on the other. So then
seven these two infernas are no longer
enough to clear here, right? If my math
is correct, it would be five might on
Inferna and then you need to do two
extra to take out the eager apprentice.
So if you just pull the Darius into the
Baron, then the Infernas both die.
>> No, no, no Darius. Just
>> so we're not bringing the Darius in.
>> Oh, which is interesting.
>> Instead, just giving the minus two to
both infernas.
>> So Dark Louise will just trade with the
eager apprentice. The uh Rain Bloom
student has now three might plus the two
from the variance of five might total.
And we are still expecting that to be a
tide turner. Dark Louise is in a really
rough spot.
>> Yeah, we've just entered uh time as
well. So this technically being turn
zero.
>> Oh yeah.
>> And then we're going to have three turns
after Dark Louise's turn here. And I
mean we're going to most likely crown a
Victor. I don't think turns will decide
who wins because we have a time warp on
one side and a Baron on the other side.
Uh, and all we need to do now is find a
way to conquer that void gate if we want
to win. A ride the wind from
>> Linsanity would close the game out here.
>> And I think I just saw it.
>> Oh, that was August. Okay.
>> Did he not have one in hand already?
>> Oh, no. That was much earlier and he
tried to use it to score that cheeky
point. So, there's the tide turner.
>> Oh, what a tide turner back. Baron's
ready. Goes in. That's game insanity.
>> You know what? That's a better ride to
win. That's awesome. What a creative way
to pull that one off. That was smooth.
Linsanity with the Baron punch for the
victory.
That was insane.
>> I love pro players, man. Watching the
lines they find is a treat. Using tight
turner not once but twice cuz you're
bouncing your own one back to hand.
Plenty of runes to pull off that play
>> and the Baron was the answer. I mean,
the pet gave you extra point on the
conquer and the hold. Got you back into
the game. A lot of people I'd heard were
like, "Oh, Baron's not a great card
because it gives your opponent more
opportunity to score points." Well, it
also gives you more opportunity to score
points if you're able to hold it
yourself.
>> What's crazy there is that on the
previous turn, I always like to,
especially even when I'm judging, I like
to play the turn like I was playing it.
That's how I kind of judge low play and
stuff like that. I go, can I see what
I'm trying to do here? Sure. In every
world, in every situation, I was
flipping the tide turner on my
opponent's turn. Every line that I was
deciding, I was like, "Let's do the tide
turner. Let's bring Baron over. Let's
bring that Darius in." And Lindsanity
was like, "No, no, no. I'm not playing
for this combat. I'm playing for the win
next turn. I know I'm going to win." And
that was just absolutely a cinematic
finish for uh for Lindsanity.
Incredible, incredible play, especially
considering again the Moonfall could
have pulled a Darius in and the Infernas
wouldn't have cleared the full
battlefield anyway, but there were four
runes up on Dark Lu's side. So, I think
that Lanity went for the very, very safe
play to be like, I don't want to mess
with like another Hexte Ray or
something. Let's just hold this
battlefield, hold this battlefield win
on the next turn. But that's enough from
us. I'm hearing that we have Linsanity
standing by for an interview. So, let's
hear from the winner.
>> Lynsanity went against one of the
reigning legends in the Origins format
with Kai'Sa, but he had some Origins
tricks of his own. Tide Turner plus Gust
at the end with that Baron play.
Incredible performance there. You're 7
and0 with Diana. First Diana that we've
had on stream today. How does it feel to
also like represent something new with
this deck that I think that not a lot of
people are playing around?
>> Yeah. Um, I think one thing that my deck
has is um, well, first of all, it feels
really good. Um, but my deck I think in
particular is a little different cuz we
play Eager Apprentice. Um, that lets you
like do a lot more tricky stuff. Um, but
yeah, like feels really good to win on
stream. Last time I played on stream, I
lost and uh, my run went downhill from
there. So, I'm glad I won.
>> So, it's a good sign then because you
are now going into round eight 7 and0.
you're already locked in for day two
playing a highly contested legend here
with some other big names in the room.
Do you think that your list and the way
that you're playing it based off of what
I've seen I think you could fight
against these other titans in the room
is there maybe a player you're looking
out for necessarily?
>> Yeah, I mean obviously the um like
regional champions of Wall-E Allen or
it's like tough competing with them and
at first I didn't want to play the deck
because I it just felt bad to compete
with them but I played it a lot. is
really fun and I do think I am a pretty
good player. So I, you know, if I draw
well, I play well, you know, and
hopefully they draw bad, then I think
I'll get there.
>> And I I do want to ask you a more
personal question. Um, you you play
League of Legends, you've played at a a
competitive level, at higher tier. Are
there transferable skills here where you
played League of Legends at a higher
level, and here you are now playing a
League of Legends card game? Do you
think the strategic element and the
things and the game plans you have to
have going into, let's say, a League of
Legends game versus now a Ripbound game,
are there transferable skills that you
would say make you really good at what's
going on here?
>> Yeah, I think being able to um like
really lock in and practice and like
knowing how to practice is like very it
transfers to everything, right? If
you're able to be good at one thing,
generally you're good at other things if
you just put your mind to it. So,
>> and as you said and as you've put on a
performance here, putting your mind to
it helps you go seven and0. Insanity,
congratulations. Having a great run so
far today, but one more round to go. And
so we're going to go ahead and send it
back.
>> Not said it. You either win or you
learn. He said it between the lines. I'm
just saying. Obviously,
>> you're really reading there. That's a
fine print in that statement, isn't it?
>> Knowing how to practice is obviously
super important, right? Knowing where
you lost, why you lost, why you won,
more importantly, what lines you were
able to find. And again, Lani just
showed us a bit of a master class on how
to play the Baron version of Diana,
right? So, there's so many different
versions that are are are kind of
skullking around the room this weekend.
Uh, but what a phenomenal best of three.
>> I like what you just said there as well,
learning why you won. Because a lot of
times I think people think more about
their losses than their wins. They don't
think as critically about like, okay,
what did I do that set me up for
success? Was it something I did or did
my opponent misplay? Uh, like could I
have still done something optimally? You
know, you you look at prismaticism. I
was talking with the wall-ally earlier
and he was mentioning like prismaticism
after every win is like, "Oh, I messed
up all these different lines like, oh, I
did this wrong and this wrong and that
wrong." And it's like sometimes you
still like that the top players are
still critical. Whether it was a win or
a loss and I think that that as a skill,
League of Legends pros especially still
do that in review. Even if you win a
scrim, your coaches are still sitting
down with you like, "Ah, but you pathed
wrong. You should have been pathing
botside to help out them. Why'd you play
like strong side top lane for your
orange?" Stuff like that, right? So, I
think that those are the types of skills
that are easily transferable.
>> Yeah. And it just comes to anything
that's competitive, right? If you're if
you're eager to compete and you're eager
to win, you're going to be hyperritical
about yourself. And that's in every
aspect, right? I'm sure you know, you
cast a lot, right? I'm sure you do a lot
of that as well. You review your own
vods. You go, I don't really like how I
interviewed this player. I could have
asked them different questions, stuff
like that. So, it's very transferable to
every aspect of life, which and even
judging to be honest. So,
>> I think it's a pretty common uh uh thing
for most casters. We hate our own
voices. like listening back to your own
cast is like, "Oh no, that's the worst."
But you have to do it. You have to put
in the work to actually get better at a
craft. So, um yeah, it's cool to see.
And uh Diana picking up the win there.
Is that our first Diana feature match
victory so far? I know that there's
still a lot in the tournament that are
undefeated, but I I don't know if we had
seen one on stream uh yet.
>> I don't think so.
>> At least not on a primary feature match.
So, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> I'm not sure.
>> Cool. All right. I'm hearing that we
have a recap though of that game. So,
let's hop into that cuz Charmer is going
to break down some of the key moments.
>> Thanks for sending that over, Kangas.
And I just want to say I appreciate the
sound of your voice. I love to hear it.
But unfortunately, our viewers are stuck
with my own voice as we talk about what
we just saw at the end of that series,
specifically how Diana was able to
navigate this moonfall. cuz I know there
was a lot of discussion about whether or
not this was going to drag the Baron
over or whether or not they were going
to use the tide turner to maybe swap
spots with the Baron. But there is
something that I think Linsanity was
playing around. And if we're taking a
look here, we've got this big unit and
it's got 12 might. So right here, this
Baron has 12 might. That's very
important because if the Moonfall were
to drag in the Darius,
the problem is is there's multiple runes
still available. And in earlier games in
this series, we did see the Kai'Sa
player play cleave. Baron is so clutch
in this matchup against Kai'Sa because
it cannot be targeted by spells or
abilities. So, you don't have to worry
about Hexte Ray. You don't have to worry
about cards like Singularity, but you do
still have to worry about good
old-fashioned might. And I think that
the only way Lynanity loses this game is
if they lose the Baron. So, what we're
going to do is we're going to watch this
play out. The Moonfall actually does not
drag anything over. They just want to
win the combat with the double inferna.
And what that then opens up as a
situation where the Baron can survive
until the following turn. We know that
this is a tide turner that is down here
below. So even though Linsanity is going
to be playing from the top deck, there
are still options to move that Baron
around and get that final point. So
again, ultimately Lynsanity I think
properly identifies the only way to lose
this game is to lose the Baron. And the
only way you lose the Baron is if
somehow the Kaisa player generates
enough might to go over the top. You do
not want to put it in harm's way if you
do not have to. So with that in mind,
this is going to ultimately uh result in
Darius going up to the void gate as uh
our Kaisa player here is trying to still
keep up with points. Hope that there's
not a way for Linanity to score that
final point. This is also the neat part
about Baron is it opens up a way for you
to essentially win the game from five
because of the third battlefield. So
start of the turn, Linsanity goes up to
seven points. And then this is the
clutch part. As I had pointed out
before, this here is a tide turner. The
top deck is a stacked deck. You see a
gust there. Linsanity snap takes it.
Understanding that the line is to use
this tide turner to move the Baron over
to this location. Gust on the tide
turner. Play it in base. That moves the
Baron back. And then the move from there
to here is how you score that eighth and
final point. So this I think was a great
way to highlight the fact that Baron is
very good into some matchups
specifically where your opponents have a
lot of targeted removal like Kai'Sa.
Sometimes you'll hear people say, "Hey,
I don't know when I'm ever supposed to
sideboard in this Baron." If you're
playing Diana, this is one of the key
matchups in which you want to do so. And
this is exactly why. So well played by
Linsanity. Dodged any particular uh
calamity that may have occurred if you
got greedy and dragged the Darius in.
You don't want to be punished. You have
a guaranteed way to win. You just take
the victory. So congratulations to
LSanity. Now 7 and0 locked in for day
two. Looking forward to seeing how they
progress through the event tomorrow.
With that in mind, we're going to throw
things back to the desk.
Really cool moment there, man. I'm going
to be reliving that tide turner. Swap
with the Baron. Gus the tide turner.
Replay the tide turner. Swap with the
Baron. Like that. That play was so cool.
I love that.
>> I did the desk slam.
>> You did literally. I felt like
>> I was right here. You're very animated
when you cast. I love it. It's giving me
energy, too. And uh that was a great
energetic end to that series or that uh
that best of three there. Um meaning
that Insanity is still undefeated going
forward. We have one more round today
>> to close out day one of the regional
qualifier. This blew by really fast.
>> Yeah, it was a crazy quick day. Uh I was
I had a blast kind of walking the hall
seeing all the different legends that
were being played.
>> Not a bad day in the office, you know.
>> Yeah, there's been worse.
>> There's been worse.
>> Your pick to win the tournament was
Annie, right?
>> Yes. specifically because Prismat is
here and I felt that uh in unleashed
this is the last regional qualifier for
the unleashed format. I was like at this
point Prismat's cooked enough he's ready
to win. He won the last spirit forged
qualifier which I was casting he's going
to win the last.
>> Are you his good luck charm? Is that
maybe
>> I think so. I think actually you know
what that's a good point because he
speaking of charms he's got the five
best of andies. If he gets the six best
of Andy and I'm the good luck charm may
maybe I should uh negotiate a little bit
you know. Do you want to know the
counter to that?
>> Yeah.
>> Every time I've judged a Prismat game,
he's lost.
>> Oh, no. Does that mean that if you're
casting a Prismatic game, he's always
going to lose?
>> Time will tell.
>> Okay. All right.
>> And then we had Josh on Kha'Zix.
>> Yeah,
>> that was his pick. We had myself on Lux.
>> Yeah, you have Why? Explain yourself.
>> It's a good deck.
>> Okay. It's a resilient deck
>> to win.
>> I think so. I think if it makes it deep
into day two, it has a real chance to
win. I'm going to put you on the spot
because I do remember you saying
yesterday on rehearsal day, "Ah, put
whatever. Even if you put Lux, I'll
defend it."
>> I had two choices. Okay.
>> Lux and Leblanc. No.
>> Leblanc.
>> And I think both of those can definitely
win an RQ. Again, those decks are very
intricate to pilot. So, it really
depends who's behind the table.
>> Technically, both of them can do the
same limitless combo. It's the same
domains. It's just Lux is uh, you know,
more draw built into the legend itself.
Leblanc, you'd have to kind of duplicate
your your Leblanc chosen team.
>> A little trickier.
>> It's a little trickier, but still
decent. You know, you get Mirror image
to fight a little more in the early
game.
>> And then Charmer, I think, is the
villain of the desk cuz he chose Civer
to win.
>> That's a good point.
>> Yeah. So, I'm not the bad guy this
weekend.
>> Good point. I would
>> second I'm like the assistant to the
regional manager.
>> Assistant to the villain overlord. Yeah,
>> exactly.
>> Assistant villain. Uh well, a great uh
day so far here on day one. We've
featured so many fun decks. We had an
Ivvern undefeated in the last round. I'm
so I kept Okay, I need to stop giving
tips or giving like my feedback of like,
oh, you should cast this deck when I'm
not on the cast
>> because they keep playing the decks that
I want to cast when I'm not there.
>> I know, right? Like I didn't get to cast
the Jinx. I didn't get to cast the
Ivvern. Ah, it's okay.
>> We got the Baron finale, though.
>> Hey, we did get the Baron finale. I'll
take that. That was cool. And we were
even like kind of joking about the Baron
in the deck, too. It's like, yeah, it's
funny seeing some of these oneup bars,
but again, like it can give you the
extra battlefield to not only score on a
conqueror, but then also score on a
hold, and we saw the strength of it. So,
I think a lot of people have been
changing their mind on Baron.
>> Were you a believer when it was first uh
revealed?
>> A lot of people got really excited when
Baron was revealed. They're like, "Oh,
this is going to be the best Aurora card
ever, especially for Aurora."
>> And I'm like, "Nah, kind of. Not really.
It's going to be a good tech piece, I
And we've actually seen that where you
know people like Ali Alrazi and even we
saw in round one Tron is bad who his
main deck runs three Baron and one Elder
Dragon.
>> That was crazy.
>> And it's just for Diana.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just so when you play against
Diana, you win that game one and then
they have to kind of go into their own
mind and be like, is he going to side
out the Barons? Is he going to bring in
the Barons? Is he going to just bring in
the Elder Dragons and the Barons? What's
going on? What units can I expect? And
it keeps them guessing on game two. So
you're maximizing your chance to win
because usually when you're playing
Aurora, you're guaranteed to win one
game.
>> Yeah.
>> Usually your Aspirin's game. You're also
guaranteed probably to lose one game,
which is whatever battlefield your
opponent really excels at
arena's greatest. And if you match the
arena's greatest to the aspirants, it's
gets a little messy. So I really like
this new list. I like that Baron's
getting
>> I don't want to say a send off cuz he's
not rotating, but the set that Baron
came out in, we're seeing more Baron now
at this last uh Unleashed Regional. And
I love it.
>> Yeah, it was one of those really cool
ones when it was first printed. I
remember the first decks that I built
when unleashed uh when I did my pre-
rifts and like got a couple of cards is
I built a full dragon volibear deck,
which I'm still playing to this day.
It's still very fun. Um and then I uh my
roommate built the uh Baron pit or the
the the Baron uh Aurelia deck where you
put like the swifty boots on it, move it
around. Yeah, it's very fun. my villain
self built reanimator jinx with baron
with heroings and soul gorggers and I
just want to discard the baron and then
replay it from my trash on like turn
three and uh go down to zero runes but
it doesn't matter because I have a baron
naturally that deck didn't do too well
but it was a blast to play
>> shocking um hey sometimes the fun decks
I feel the same about the the dragon
poly bear deck as well by the way it's
blast to play in certain matchups um
just don't kill my heralds just just
don't worry about them don't even read
the texts okay the herald
of scales does not matter. It's not
important. Uh just let me do my infinite
draw.
>> Not even the dragon.
>> Yeah. Why would I care about it?
>> I told people uh at locals I was like if
I'm ever on a feature match playing
Volibear, my goal is not to win. It's to
make my opponent win by drawing out
infinitely and then just giving them the
game. Just prove I can do it and just be
like, haha, check it out. I found my own
infinite, guys. It's kind of the
opposite of what you want from an
infinite backwards.
>> It's a backwards infinite. Yeah. You
know, [laughter]
>> maybe I do want to play against you now.
>> I may be actually. Yeah, I'm not going
to play Volibear against you. I don't
think that's got a good lux match. I'm
going to going to be honest.
>> Oh, could be what?
>> Could be good.
>> Look, if I see my uh Drake counts, if I
see like Dre count draount immediately
and just go with the points, maybe I can
beat you.
>> But then there's a sprite burst you have
to keep in mind.
>> Yeah, it's fine. Um, for anybody
wondering why we're just uh talking
about our decks, we're waiting for round
eight. It's going to be right around the
corner. So stick with us. We have one
more round ahead for this Riftbound
regional qualifier. Um what are you
hoping to see overperform and make it
into day two? Cuz we're at that kind of
point now where it's like it's the last
chance for Dex to get into day two. Do
you have anything that you're like you
think this should be more represented?
>> Lux.
>> No. Well, there's going to be Luxes in
day two. We know there was an undefeated
going into the last round.
>> I hope that they're so undefeated to be
honest. Uh, I would like to see actually
um more of these mid-range decks kind of
pop up like the Lucian of the world. Uh,
I would love to see kind of those decks.
Show a sign of life cuz Ramble back
Lucian. We haven't seen any of those.
>> Or the, you know, blue sentinel hold Ari
deck. You know, some some mid-range kind
of deck like that would be super sick.
>> Now we're cooking. Now we're cooking.
Well, I hear that we have filled for
long enough and now we have Charmer
ready for a breakdown.
Hello everybody. I'm here to talk about
how some important players are doing in
the Swiss rounds. We're going to be
talking to some folks that are locked in
for day two and kind of hear how their
day has went so far here in day one and
uh I believe we're going to be starting
with none other than Colin.
>> Hello. Want to talk about your day one
run so far?
>> Uh yeah, of course. I started in round
two against a Rex Eye and was able to
beat that. My deck is uh very good
against aggressive decks as the set guy,
>> very good at holding. So, it was quite
good. Round three was against
Misfortune, so I it's an Aurora matchup,
which is one I'm always scared of, but I
get to play three sabotages in the main,
which is uh you know, never bad for me.
I actually ended up playing against
another Rexai after that, which was uh
[laughter] kind of a yeah, a weird
coincidence. So, uh, ran it back, was
able to 20 as well. I played against a
second Misfortune as well. [laughter] It
was back to back, which is very, very
strange, especially in day one. Uh, but
fortunately, I was able to win that one.
And then, uh, last was against a Master
Yi, which I was able to beat as well.
So, 6 so far and, uh, hoping to keep it
up.
>> All right. Well, it sounds like you
might be playing against another Master
Yi soon. With the way your day has been
going, everything's coming in pairs, but
congratulations so far on your run.
We're not surprised at all that you're
doing well, but it's great to see the
continued success. But Colin is not the
only player that is doing incredibly
well here on day one. So, we're going to
be talking to another player here
shortly.
>> Yeah, thank you.
>> Who wants to step up to the plate? Oh,
let me look. It looks like IO
is in the house. IO, you want to step up
and tell me how you're doing and
specifically how you're doing on what
legend? because it's not your normal
one.
>> I know. I'm playing Diana this weekend.
I I am overplaying Ezreal. It's such a
pain in the ass to actually [laughter]
deal with. My opponent's just playing a
little bit too slow. Takes a little bit
too long. Uh I have enough opponents. I
don't need the timer to be an opponent,
too. So, playing Diana this weekend.
Deck's really good. I mean, it just does
everything you could ever want it to do.
The deck the cards are great. I mean, my
first few matchups got solo carried by
just four costs Vex existing uh Lilia
and Rengar. So, yeah, very happy with
the deck. Yeah, that's a very fortuitous
matchup with the Lilia and the Rengar
because obviously Vex Apathetic shuts
that down. Uh any particular reason why
you chose to swap other than that Ezreal
is just more difficult and you wanted an
easier event.
>> I I think it's the timer issues. That's
really it. I mean Diana has really good
matchups especially into like Ireelia
and Master Yi, especially since we are
mainboarding like exceptal losses now.
So like Guardian Angels and Zas that
otherwise were annoying really aren't an
issue for this deck. whereas Ezreal had
a very hard time dealing with those
cards. So, yeah, it's just a lot of
really good matchups.
>> All right. Well, again, congratulations.
Been an impressive run so far here in
day one. Looking forward to seeing what
you can do in day two, but once again,
you're not the only one who's doing
well. We've got another fantastic player
on deck here. So, we're going to say
goodbye to IicO and instead we're going
to be welcoming in none other than No
Veggies himself. And uh based on the
Poppy on your shoulder, I assume that
you're running Poppy back for this
event, I know you're on Poppy in
Vancouver.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right. Well, what has your day been
like so far in day one?
>> Uh, so far it's been all right.
Obviously, I'm playing Poppy, so it's a
lot. Oh, being 61 is always nice. I'm
dodging the matchups I need to dodge,
hitting the matchups I need to hit. So,
so far it's been fun.
>> I'm happy to hear that you're having
fun. I had the pleasure of casting a
different player on Aurora Poppy earlier
in the broadcast and got to see some
amazing Ruination plays, got to see the
Harness Dragons, the Rift Heralds. Uh,
has anything other than, you know,
dodging certain matchups really stood
out to you at this event today? Um, just
getting better with the deck in general.
Finding the little inches where I can
like when I don't have when I don't have
u Aurora, you know, trying to find out
other ways to win the game, you know,
use Vanguard Army more as a removal
spell than anything. So,
>> all right. Well, thank you so much for
talking to us. Congratulations on your
run so far in day one. But we have one
more player that we want to hear from.
So, we're going to say goodbye to Nove.
And instead, we're going to be welcoming
in none other than another challenger
TCG player. And that's going to be Revik
stepping in here. And
this is going to make Greton very happy
because you're playing Lux. How has your
day one went so far?
>> Uh, it's going pretty good. I am 7 and0
on Lux right now. Um, I have been
successfully looping people today and
[laughter] uh hope to continue that uh
going forward.
>> All right. Anything that jumps out
before we let you go? I know that you
got to get ready for the next round.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um, no. I hope I keep
playing against Auroras. I think I'm
about to go play against a third Aurelia
in a row. This is a tricky matchup. Um,
but uh maybe he won't draw as many
Defies. So, we'll see how that goes.
>> All right. Well, thank you for taking
the time to talk to me. I'm going to let
you go so that you can get to your round
because that's starting here shortly.
>> But, uh, here on the broadcast, we're
going to be taking a short break. Don't
go anywhere. When we return, we're going
to have round seven of the regional
qualifier here in Hartford coming your
way.
>> Thank you.
Hello everybody, Charmer here at the
regional qualifier in Hartford,
Connecticut. And I am here with Goya
Rice who has a fantastic cosplay that I
just have to know more about. So this is
a very detailed cosplay. So is this
something that you made yourself or made
parts of it? And if so, what was the
process like for constructing something
like this? Okay, so I this costume
itself I bought online. Me and my friend
we made pillery and this was a very hard
project. We had to crunch this within
like a month and we did the LED strips
and cut everything and painted
everything together.
>> Now since you mentioned pillery I've
noticed right now we're holding it and
traditionally this is something that's
worn. How much of the event have you
been wearing it and if so has it been
problematic because it looks kind of
painful? Yeah. So, [laughter] the spikes
definitely hit the back of my neck and
then they catch onto my ears and my ears
fall off. So, I haven't really been
wearing her as much as I would like to,
but I mean when I ask when I'm getting
asked for a picture, I will put it on.
>> All right. Well, the last question that
I want to ask is, can we see the pillary
on? I know that it can be painful, but I
want to see what the the full outlook
looks like.
>> My ear might fall off, but ignore that
if that happens. Yeah, if your ear falls
off, you'll just be the Van Go version
of Brier.
>> No big deal. And so, if you're if you're
wondering, this is why I asked about
what it's like to have this properly on
because this is uh not very funl
looking.
>> No, you know, I I'm like two people wide
essentially. If I try to go through like
crowds, I'm going to bump into them. And
uh it's light, don't get me wrong. It's
nice and light, but it's still
definitely difficult to manage in a
setting like this, especially in those
like aisles. Those aisles are crazy.
There's no way I'm standing out here.
So, yeah.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to answer the questions.
I hope that the rest of the event goes
wonderful. Uh we really appreciate
everybody who pitches in with the
community. Just makes these events so
much fun and you're definitely a part of
that. So, thank you so much. With that,
we're going to send it back to you.
Hello everybody, Charmer here coming to
you from the regional qualifier here in
Hartford, Connecticut. And I am joined
by none other than Jubes who has a
fantastic collection that we're going to
feature and kind of talk about what it's
like to be a collector in Riftbound.
Jubes, what can you tell me about your
particular collection? Well, I obviously
uh play League of Legends as well, so
when Riftbound came out, I was like,
"Oh, I really hope we're going to get a
Yumi card here." As soon as Unleashed
released the Yumi card, I knew that's
where my collection was going to go. So,
I have been um steadily stacking Yumis
since the pre-releases. I was super
excited that they did a the promo card
for the skirmishes, and people have been
coming up to me all through this event
and then also in Vancouver and bringing
me more Yumis. uh steadily stacking the
collection up.
>> Yeah, this is a very impressive
collection and I don't think I've ever
seen so many Yumies in one place. Uh
have people been comparing collections
with you cuz I know that there has been
a person who collects rumbles around and
and some other legends as well.
>> For sure. I got to meet the Rumble girl.
I met uh the lonely porro guy. there's
quite a few people and they bring up
their binders and then we get to sit
there and flip through them. And then we
also get to do like trades. So like I
try to make sure that I collect cards
for people as well when I know that
they're collecting stuff and then we
pass off uh between each other that way.
>> All right. So if folks want to find you
and either trade some Yumis to you, give
you some yumies, or just see this
impressive collection, how can they
locate you in the hall?
>> I am over in the creator area for most
of the day. I have uh my binder there
and I'm ready and happy to do trades
with everyone. I've also been walking
around. I'm pretty hard to miss most of
the time. So, just snag me anytime.
>> And finally, what can you tell me about
the squeakers? Because that's one of the
most impressive things about
>> It's so fun. It's really great. I love
putting it in there because I do have
like limited visibility sometimes. So,
when I'm getting through, I can just be
like, "Excuse me, I'm trying to get
through." And people love that. And as
people are playing, they'll say that
they've been in their rounds and then
they hear the squeaker and they all like
look over and and see the Yumi. So
that's always fun.
>> All right. Well, I really appreciate you
taking the time to show off your
collection. Kind of talk about how fun
it is to have something that you can
collect a lot of. Yes, we all want our
three of to play the game, but sometimes
you want 300 or 3,000 Yumis. So, thank
you for sharing this with us and
hopefully this inspires you at home to
start your own collection as well.
>> Thank you so much for having me.
>> Hello everybody, welcome. I'm here with
the legend himself, the Wall-E, winner
of the first regional qualifier and also
on a bit of a tear in the last couple.
How's Hartford treating you?
>> Uh, a little bit less good than the last
two. Um, the other ones I started
undefeated. This one I lost my first
round. So, like [laughter] after my buy.
Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, a little bit
different, but um not trying to think
about it too much. Just trying to play
my best still.
>> Okay. All right. We saw actually who you
were against cuz we had them on a
feature match earlier today. He was
dressed up in a full suit and tie. What
was that like?
>> Uh I mean I sat down and you know it's
first round of the day and I'm thinking
you know it'll be okay. But um he played
super well. Like he dressed super well,
played super well. Um he did some things
that you know a lot of the zeros don't
do which is equip uh early. And by
equipping early, he plays around things
like Gust and then some other spells.
So, he made it tough on me. Uh, I think
I drew a little poorly, but also maybe
in game two, I could have played a bit
better. So,
>> you know, tough start, but going to try
to lock in since then. I haven't lost a
game.
>> Nice. Nice. So, yeah. I mean, you
mentioned that in the past couple you
started undefeated. This time you got
the loss out of the way early, right?
>> You know, in in Houston, actually, I
lost my second round
>> and then I won out from there and won
the tournament. So,
>> yeah, you won that tournament. So, there
we go. You're [laughter] on track. Um,
but on a real note, do you feel like
there's any pressure? Cuz now we've had
a couple of regional qualifiers. There's
names like yours, like Adlin, like
Prismaticism, these top performers
consistently. Do you feel like there's
pressure now on you to make top eight?
>> Uh, yeah. Like, you know, the thing is I
put pressure on myself ever since
Houston to do well. Um, because I see
people like Allan Prismat like, you
know, constantly top eight, like I want
that to be me as well. Um, and now that
I'm doing it, I think there's actually a
little bit less pressure because each
tournament since Houston, I just felt
like worse and worse that I wouldn't top
eight and I would get so close. I lost
like many winning ends. Um, and now I
feel like there's a little bit less
pressure because I'm like I, you know, I
can still do it, but there's still
pressure. Like when I say there's less
pressure, there's still pressure, you
know? Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
>> Uh, I got to say it's so impressive the
guys like that are able to do it. like
the variance in a card game is extreme.
You've played enough to know so being
able to top eight multiple times is
impressive. Why do you feel like you're
able to to hit backto back and maybe
even another one here in Hartford? Like
what is it about your play style or how
you approach the game that you feel
gives you the consistency needed to make
these runs?
>> Uh there's a couple reasons. So I'll
start with the first. Um there's a lot
of best of people like play people
playing for best of, right? So if you're
familiar with all of the best of heroes,
you get an edge. Um, so like you know if
your if your deck
>> should beat certain heroes but you've
never played against them before, you
can lose to them. So like just being
familiar with all the legends,
especially for day one
>> interactions. Yeah.
>> Uh the second thing I'd say is uh this
game is like super high skill.
>> I was actually super surprised. Like
>> every single set the skill ceiling goes
higher and higher and higher and I don't
think anyone is actually playing
perfectly. Like you'll see Prismat like
tweet all his mistakes every round,
right? like it's not easy to play the
game. So, I think because of that, uh
the people that are like able to play
close enough to perfect are are, you
know, continually coming out ahead. And
the the last thing I want to say is the
game because you're gated by two points
a turn. Your your minimum game length is
is usually going to be longer than other
games. So, because you're you're more
turns on average, you're also more
decisions on average. And because the
game is so hard, skill lets you leverage
that over the course of the game.
>> Yeah. you have time to actually think a
couple of turns ahead because you have a
couple of turns ahead to think for.
Yeah, that's awesome. Well, it's awesome
hearing your thoughts, man. Thank you so
much for the interview. Best of luck in
the rest of the tournament.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Hello everybody and welcome back to the
Riftbound regional qualifier in
Hartford. I'm Kangas and I'm here to do
a deck breakdown of one of the coolest
decks that we saw make top eight last
week in Utre. In honor of it being the
last Unleash format regional, we got to
take a look at how the met has been
shaping up by highlighting the void
burer herself, Rexai. Shout out Remiano
for pulling this off in the top eight.
Uh first off, let's look at the legend
itself, the void borrower, because it's
a very unique legend. Not everyone's
super uh comfortable with it. When you
conquer, you may exhaust the legend to
reveal the top two cards of your main
deck. You play one, you recycle the
rest. Essentially, the way that I think
about Rexi is it is a rush deck that
uses uh your hand, but also it uses your
deck as like a second hand. You know,
you're able to play cards without
actually using the resource from your
hands to play it. Then there's also the
signature spell, void rush, which we'll
take a look at next. Does something
similar. Uh it's just a normal speed
spell, and you reveal the top two cards
of your main deck. You may play one of
them, reducing its cost by two, draw any
you did not play this way. So, you don't
have to play a card. You could just
reveal two and then draw them, but you
get a discount on one of the ones that
you reveal if you do want to play it.
And that's why we're playing a lot of
little guys. You see a lot of two drops
in there. I'm going to highlight one of
the newer ones, Inferna. Uh, this is a
fantastic card because of the ambush
ability. So, if it's in your hand, it's
very high value. But also, this is
essentially what you're going to be
looking for in the early game with your
Rex Eye ability. You just want to start
with a two energy and then get more two
energy units out onto the field as you
conquer with the Rexai void burer
ability. One of the other cool new cards
that uh Rexi has to play with in
Unleashed is Pike. Red Pike is
fantastic. The Doside Butcher has hidden
and ganking. Uh so it can defend, but it
also the bigger one is when you play it,
you may pay a red power as an additional
cost. When you do, uh ready give me plus
two might this turn. So, it's only a
three energy to just play it. You could
hide it, but you can also just play it
and then pay the one extra power cost.
Tax in for four at that point. So,
you're starting to see the idea and the
identity of this deck is it's you want
to conquer at least once per turn so
that then you can trigger your legend
ability and then keep swinging in and
keep doing damage. It's a very honest
rush deck. You're not playing a lot of
bells and whistles in this one. As we
look at the the other spells, actually,
well, before that, I do want to
highlight one kind of fun thing that
they're on is three under Titan. Um,
this is one that even back in Spirit
Forge when Rexi first was revealed, a
lot of Rexi players I talked to were
like, "Ah, you don't need three. You
just go for like two, maybe even a one
of and you try and high roll into it."
But, I mean, if you're trying to see it,
I just say run the full three because
then you maximize your odds of seeing it
whenever it's revealed from your deck.
You add two energy to your pool. Also,
it's a pretty useful effect when you
play it because you're going to be
flooding the field with a lot of little
units and then this will buff all them
by two might. The the really cool thing
is when you whenever you reveal it off
of either your void borrower legend or
the void rush, you actually can trigger
that to get more energy for that turn.
Now, let's talk about the spells because
again, it's a very honest rush aggro
deck. Blood rush is the first one here.
These are the type of things that you
love to see if your opponent's on one
battlefield and you conquer the other
battlefield. You love to see things like
blood rush cuz you're running a lot of
little guys. This can then uh even
repeat cost to buff them up and then
they can swing in on the battlefield
your opponent is controlling. Classic
order spells like cold the weak and as
well hidden blade are just ways to
control the battlefield if your opponent
has big units out there. It's a little
bit of draw power for yourself cuz you
sometimes don't mind hitting your own
carry and dredger or honest broker or
things like that. Um but again it's not
a lot of crazy things. You see almost
everything is maxed out as a play set.
The only thing we don't have playets are
uh Vi, Darien Porro and then the uh
Rengar. Uh, speaking of the VI, I think
it's also worth highlighting just order
is such a strong domain right now almost
because of how good VI peacekeeper is
when you attack. You can play with
ambush and then it stuns something when
it attacks. Very, very powerful unit.
Uh, and then also would be remiss if I
didn't mention Elise Rexite Breacher.
Uh, we've seen this one since Spear
forge. Very popular in the meta, but
anytime you create uh tokens, they can
come in accelerated. So things like
carry and dredger uh and things like
Faithful Manufacturer can actually get
very fast units out there. So I said it
a few times, I'm going to say it again.
This is an honest aggro deck. You're
trying to win fast. You're trying to
conquer every turn. Uh and if the wheels
fall off, they fall off pretty hard. But
hey, they stayed out long enough for
Remechaniano to get into that top eight.
So congratulations to the pilot. Awesome
to see this in top eight at Trek. But
for now, that's it for me. Back to the
show.
Thank you, me. Appreciate that one. You
were just flaming me on it. You said
it's not an honest deck. You don't think
so?
>> No, of course not.
>> Why is it not honest?
>> Well, we get to see cards for free off
the top of my deck. Void Rush gets me to
see more cards for free off the top of
my deck.
>> That's the mechanic. You don't like draw
power?
>> Uh, I do. I like Lux.
>> It's honest in that it does one thing
and one thing only. Play a bunch of
dudes and attack. All right. Fair.
>> That's an honest deck in my book. How it
gets there is its business. [laughter]
Uh Rex has a fun D. Was able to get top
eight in Utre. We're still waiting to
see who's able to even make day two
though here in Hartford because we're in
our final round. Everybody that uh at
this point is, you know, 7 and0 is
pretty, you know, much guaranteed. But
then some of those ones that could drop
to X2, X3, you know, those are the ones
sweating right now.
>> Yeah. So, let's actually jump in and
take a look at the standings so we can
see where these players are standing and
what legends are locked in and not. And
actually, look at that. Rank one right
now. Top seed.
>> Vex. Vex. Vex. Gloomist. Couple of
Diana's here as well. Hey, there is one
Rex. I void. Burrower. I don't know why
I struggle with that word. When I try
and say it fast, I struggle. Burrower
for uh yeah, still seven and zero. Uh
but a lot of um variety overall. I would
say Diana is still the most represented
at least on this screen, but we're
seeing pretty everybody else is is a one
of here.
>> Yeah, we have an Ezreal as well. Vex
here. Shout out again. My hometown
Montreal. another Montrealer who's doing
it there. But we see some again some
variety here except for those Diana. And
if we jump over to the second page here
as we take a look further past that 10
seed, there's another Ezreal at the top.
Another Montrealer or two Ezreals left.
Shout out
>> there's your Maticism still undefeated
on Annie as well. So that's cool to see
a Pike as well. Okay,
>> fun stuff there. And now we're getting
into the X uh X01's and
>> X1.
>> Mhm.
>> Lives in a box. Very cool username.
>> Lives in a box. I uh I wonder how close
their list is to mine cuz I'm playing a
list of Draven that I call Draven Sucks
where you're playing all Evelyn and like
blast cones and bone skewers and you're
trying to suck the opponent.
>> I don't think it's that list.
>> You don't think it's Draven sucks? Okay.
All right.
>> We do have Sam D Sherman as well. 61
still on Rengar. As we jump down to look
at this, we have a Kaido who we just saw
get a little bit of an interview earlier
with Charmer at 61 on that Diana and we
have uh some Azir that's making a
comeback and then obviously we saw Luiz
Zero uh you know lose unfortunately to
that phenomenal baron play at the end
but 61 still currently locked for day
two.
>> I think that was the highest Kai'Sa that
I saw unless I missed one on an earlier
page I believe. So yeah. Um, and then on
this next page here as well, there's a
Leblanc, there's a Leona 6 in one, and a
Lilia 6 in1. I imagine Oh, two Lilas
actually. I imagine they probably dodged
a lot of chaos decks. I feel like the
Lilia match up into anything that runs
uh Vex is really, really tough cuz Vex
just kind of shuts down the entire
>> I might have seen like six Aurora decks
>> maybe,
>> and they're like perfect.
>> Happy to see those ones. Happy to see
those. Happy to see like Leblanc.
There's a lot of matchups that work, but
that's the beauty of the current format.
I love the fact that there's so many
different decks available and uh you
might have a really good match up into
some and a completely lossy match up
into others and that's why we get so
many different I think in Utre that's
why we had so many different in the top
eight uh was specifically because of the
variance and how many ones you have
available.
>> Yeah, it's the zoo of Swiss is what we
like to say.
>> I like that.
>> But we have one more round to play and
who better to decide what we cast than
you all at home. So, we're going to take
it to a vote so you can let us know
exactly what you want to see. We have
prismaticism against something must
work.
>> Something's got to work. That's a Rexai
into Annie. Very cool matchup. And then
we have B Schwitz on Diana versus five
up on Vex.
>> Yeah. And our Vex is our top seed in the
entire tournament at this point in time.
So, do do you think chat wants to see
prismaticism, you know, stress and play
with his hair, or do we want to see
effects?
>> Something tells me that uh the match A
will win this, but this is closer than I
expected. A lot of people voting for
match B. [music] Type A or B in chat
right now to let us know. It's neck and
neck right now. We haven't seen I don't
think a Vex on a primary future match. I
We might have gotten to see one as a
secondary future match at some point. We
just watched Diana take a victory. So
that's partly why I expected
prismaticism on Annie into a Rexite to
win out here, but seems like Chad is
actually swinging it back. Who's going
to take it? We're close. This is the
closest I've ever seen back to 5050.
>> 4951.
>> Everyone's individual vote counts. Spam
right now. Your vote legitimately counts
here. Which one do you want?
>> Oh my.
>> Sometimes it's like an 8020. What's the
point? I kind of want to see this Rex
eye. I kind of want to see the
>> stream yet. Oh,
>> so we're also divided on the death
>> and it Oh, it was just for one moment.
And again,
>> this is the closest I've ever seen it.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What? What just happened? Stop going B.
We're going B. For a moment, it was 51%
and they hit the button to say B and
then it swung back, I think. But for
that one moment that they hit the
button, it was 51%. That was the closest
finish for one of those votes that we've
done yet. And uh we're you get your uh
your wish. We see the Vex.
>> I want to see what this Vex is. We've
been seeing some lists uh that Vex is
kind of playing almost like better
Teemo. I put in air quotes.
>> Okay.
>> Where it's a very hidden card focused
deck and I trees on on those ones.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Exactly. And I'm curious
if that's what we're doing here. But I'm
actually looking at the deck list from
the Vex and it's not at all. There's no
banal tree in it. So, I'm excited to see
this deck list in this deck list in
action, excuse me, from the Vex.
>> Guess we throw away Prismaticism's deck
list. We're not We're not going to need
that one. Let's just look at these ones.
The ones that Twitch,
>> that's the Vex. Bring it back.
>> YouTube chat voted on. Oh, it did the
Vex go away. Oh, no.
>> Here we have the Diana deck list that we
could take a look at with everyone at
home. And we made a joke about Rebuke.
>> We Oh, that's
>> there's a rebuke right there.
>> That is a rebuke in the main deck. I
love it when uh players will do stuff
like this. First off, if you're
expecting a lot of Master Y, which has
been on some people's radars, this
cannot be defined. That's one of the
strongest things about Rebuke uh against
old formats and still relevant in this
format. But second of all, most people
just assume you're not on it. So if you
ever have two runes out, they're like,
"Oh, they got a flash. I can attack in
and get through a flash." No flash is in
the main deck in this Diana list. We're
not going to be opting for the full like
three Hay uh move around the Hay.
Instead, it's more about the Sprite
Fountains and uh you know, trying to
play more aggro, I'd say.
>> Yeah. And notably that rebuke that one
of only 16% of the Diana in the field
are running rebuke.
>> Wow. Low number.
>> So very unique tech there. Obviously
that sprite fountain is also different.
It either works as an aggro piece,
right? Or it allows you to ready some
runes with that Hay. So you can kind of
have your cake and eat it too a little
bit so to speak there. That acceptable
loss is in almost every Diana list I've
ever seen. Just such a cheap way to
either
>> get rid of it to draw an extra card with
way or when it's good it's great. And
when it's not good and you need it to
pump a unit on abandoned hall, you just,
you know, exhaust your legend and it's a
free spell that you can
>> you also can kill your own sprite
fountain. So in a pinch, you need six
might. You can sprite fountain, kill it,
get the double sprite tokens out. Really
cool. Take a look at the Vex, though,
cuz this is the one you were excited
about. Vex is one of the queens of
holding a battlefield. Step aside, Ari.
Vex is in the building. Yeah. And what's
actually kind of notable here about Vex
is I talked about the hidden Vex in the
past. This is not that. And again, we
talked about unique tech in the Diana
list. Three on guard.
>> Only 15% of Vex players in the field
today are playing on guard in their
deck.
>> Typically, when I think of Vex, I think
of multiple units holding the
battlefield on guard doesn't get a lot
of value. But this list, three Kha'Zix,
three Aurelia, this is like a combat
heavy vex. And notably as well, another
card we don't see a ton of in Vex, but
we see it in a lot of other chaos decks,
flash. only 10% of Vex are running
flash. Five up being one of them. And
this again just lends itself to you go
into a battlefield where there's a bunch
of units.
>> You maybe assign some damage to one or
you know give it a minus might. They
flash it back. All of a sudden my units
alone I can ong guard it.
>> Very interesting. Very interesting tech
choices. Also one other card I want to
highlight here. Pike. Uh this is another
one that it's one of the stronger hidden
units. Usually hidden units and hidden
cards don't go up very high in energy
cost. It's kind of part of the balance
of them. Pike's one of the higher energy
costed hiddens along with red pike as
well. I love this card. I've been
playing this a lot in my Jinx builds and
I think even like Teemo decks can run
this one. Um can get you more gold gears
and help you out not d ramp as well as
just be three extra men to battlefield
coming out of nowhere. Really cool card
there. So I'm excited to see how this
Vex pilot plays the deck. Unique build,
one that I've not seen before. And I'm
hearing that we are ready to hop into
game. So Diana versus Vex. At least half
of chat wanted this matchup. At least at
least for one moment, for one brief
moment, more than half of chat wanted
this matchup. What's actually kind of
interesting as well is the Vex does run
Abandon Hall.
>> Yep.
>> Which is a very Diana coded battlefield,
>> but also I don't think we've seen this
battlefield at all today. Fortified
position.
>> Oh yes. when uh you're defending, you
choose one of your units and then it
gets shield. Yeah, I don't think we've
seen that yet.
>> And off we go. We got the blinged out
legends on both sides. The overnumbered
showcasing the cool art of those
overnumbered legends.
>> Signature Diana, right?
>> Is it?
>> I think so.
>> I unless I crazy. Is that not No,
>> you might be crazy, but for different
reasons.
>> I also don't have my glasses on.
>> Should probably wear those when I'm
casting a game,
>> perhaps. Is that recommended?
>> All right, two energy units placed from
both players. Bishwites with arguably
the stronger one. I'd say it's just
definitively the stronger one for when
it's just alone as a unit. The Ring
Bloom student and now establishing the
Diana as well, developing the board
more. Tide Turner is available for five
up, so could get into a battlefield.
>> Yep. And we have five runes now
available for us. And we're in the
Trixie colors, right? Calm chaos, uh,
which is very, very difficult to deal
with. We do have two essentially
resource energy available if we're
Diana. Uh we can spend one in a showdown
with our legend. The other one we just
have a chaos rune ready in the back as
well. So now five up has to kind of
think of what their optimal line is here
because you could probably get rid of
one. You have three charm in your deck.
Uh you do have Evelyn as well. You can't
flip her on your turn, but you can at
least bluff it and flip it on your own.
And we're looks like we're just going to
perhaps take a turn to develop here.
we're going to just, you know, pass the
turnover. And patience is a virtue like
we've seen in many of the games today.
>> Game of chicken happening right now.
Often times you get to the top tables.
This is the type of game you see uh
rather than just sending the two might
units in to start getting early points.
They're instead saying you commit first
and then I get to hit you and then try
and get some card advantage in that
case. But Diana, I imagine, will go in
cuz you do get some advantage from her
ability when she's in the showdown. You
can look at the top card, but it's
actually the student that goes in first.
>> Sure.
>> Conquer.
>> I think five up was pondering something.
>> Maybe a Gust. Was there a Gust in the
main deck on the list?
>> Sure.
>> No.
>> Interesting.
>> I guess it would be like uh
>> existential dread. I mean, that's not
going to do much if you only have the
one up. Curious what the thought was.
maybe just baiting him out. But either
way, Bishwitz is able to conquer both
points, get two, and triggers that
Diana. I didn't spot what card was
revealed because I was looking at the
deck list. So, at least it's known
information for five up
>> and chat
>> and Chad. I'm sure I I don't have chat
up, so I'm sure they're spamming what it
was. Appreciate you trying to assist.
>> Yeah,
>> it'll be a surprise for me later.
Merchant coming down here.
>> We're going to start spraying our
student back. Yeah, seems good.
And already the tide turner can still
check the or rather the merchant can
check the tide turner that five up has
>> and another tie turner comes down from B
schwitz now swapping out with the Diana
not the merchant. So I thought maybe
you're going to cycle for an extra draw
off the merchant but instead saving the
Diana two might units out at the
battlefields. Five up has the ability to
cleanly clear one with the Vex but two
runes still available for Bishwites
as we drew the flash here. Five up now.
Seven runes. So definitely some room to
work with here. But again, Beastwitz was
able to just develop an insane amount uh
in the back as well.
>> Oh, there's Kha'Zix.
>> Oh, very nice.
>> Yep. And you uh move back the tie turner
on the Starring
>> and the Kha'Zix will trigger because
>> that traveling merchant is alone.
>> Yep. We've seen this uh tech whether whe
it's a hidden unit or an ambush unit.
Starring is a very versatile
battlefield.
>> Yeah,
>> good one.
>> Mhm.
>> Between Starring and Amateur Recital, I
was kind of at the start of Unleash
thinking that those would be the two
premier battlefields. I definitely think
Starspring has shown it is a more
versatile one to two. You can trigger it
at multiple times
>> at least once each turn.
>> Go to two. Mhm.
>> And five up showing the strength of it
right now. Getting second point clearing
off both of Bishwit's units. pass and
pass.
>> Interesting.
>> So, I think I did see five up draw a
flash. So, a way to protect your units
here.
>> Uh the Vex being on that battlefield.
You're probably going to want to clear
that one first before you commit to
playing, you know, a or anything like
that just in case you want to ride the
wind and do some funky stuff.
>> But stack deck to start us off. Going to
get some more information. See what our
options are. The one of rebuke gets
drawn. And I'm curious, are we always
taking our one of here?
>> If you don't, you're not going to see it
again. And that's usually the argument
for taking it in the Vex matchup. It can
get very expensive, but it can deal with
threats. The problem being it's like if
you bounce back the Kha'Zix, it comes
back. If you bounce back the Vex, you
pay the deflect cost. The immediate
board doesn't really show huge value for
it. So, you're kind of taking it for
either like a defensive play or a push
play later on. Did not see what he
actually took. Bishwitz is going to put
two back at the bottom, but we'll have
to wait and see if uh if we get a better
look at the hand what it was.
>> Yeah, this is where you got to get some
sort of advantage here. The tempo is
just dead even and with how tricky Vex
can get and kind of lock down. And if
you let Vex hold and give the card
advantage based on the Gloom Fist
Legend, it's pretty easy to fall behind
quickly. But we're going to push both in
to try to get rid of that Vex here and
use that Diana to look at more cards
because why not?
>> Stack deck reveal this time. I was
paying attention. Three runes up for
five up. Things like um I'm trying to
think. Um the the stun and draw card.
Why am I blanking on that one right now?
>> Back off.
>> Back off. Thank you very much. Back off
would be one of the premier ones here.
Push back the uh student and then clear
out the Diana.
>> Diana,
>> but instead just going to clear the
Diana and lose the Vex.
>> I don't hate it.
>> Yeah, it's fine.
Each uh player's chosen champion
>> traded there. Bwitz has only cleared one
battlefield and scored 1.5 up is going
to hold for one and then can play a unit
to the Kha'Zix. Move the Kha'Zix back
and then move it around. But with the
Vex apathetic now at the battlefield for
Bwitz. The Kha'Zix will not get the
bonus might and XP and also anything
played will be stunned and cannot move
that turn.
>> Notably also five up does have boots of
swiftness.
>> Oh,
>> in their hand. So able to just gank over
with that Kha'Zix as well, which is
interesting. So you could, if you wanted
to use your tie turner as fotter, you
could send your tie turner in,
>> try to get rid of that Raven Bloom, see
if they commit resources to keep that
Raven Bloom alive, and then if they
don't, you can then slap the boots onto
Kha'Zix, gank over. Now you do get your
isolation trigger. So it's kind of a way
to have your cake and eat it too, so to
speak. But we have disciplines, we have
onguards in the hand. We are now
>> almost in a light with the amount of
pump spells we have available to us.
It's impressive what FiveUp is going to
be able to do here. Again, most Vexes,
they think, okay, stack, stack, stack of
Battlefield, hold it, keep getting your
draws. FiveUp is playing a much more
adaptable style of Vex here. Was still
able to get the passive draw,
>> but has so much more punch ability
>> than what I traditionally see in the Vex
builds.
>> Go over here.
>> Okay, so there's the gank. It's going to
be a six might Kha'Zix
>> on six defending. And now the discipline
comes in. So that's eight might versus
six.
>> Uh, yep. Discipline resolves. Pick up.
>> So now we're eight to six.
>> Oh, interesting. We're Huh.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So now it's a Now it's a 10.
on six still.
>> Uh yeah, pass you.
>> Ong guard was not necessary. I'm curious
what the thought process there was.
>> And so I draw because I control that.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. I'm curious why we did on guarded
there.
>> Uh moving the tide turner in is smart
because obviously scoring the seed of
power because you control that other
battlefield. You get you get an extra
card.
>> Yep.
>> And maybe Oh, maybe it was for the charm
to kind of insulate, but I mean if
you're going to win that initial combat,
you could on guard's reaction. I'm not
>> sure why we did that.
>> My Raven Bloom.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
>> defy.
>> Going to defy that.
>> Nice. This is uh typically you think
like, oh, you're defying a one cost
spell. Is that worth it? 100%. Because
you're clearing the unit. You want to
make sure that Raven Bloom cannot punch
back in on the Starring. Five up. Has
two opportunities to hold here with the
Vex. Get extra card advantage and be
Schwitz is going to have to redevelop an
entire field.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Do you do
>> Huh? Do you track XP?
>> No, I don't track XP. I don't care.
[laughter]
>> Well, we're tracking it. There's two for
five up right now. I guess it would go
to four and then six cuz Kha'Zix won.
>> No, no, Kha'Zix um only one of them was
a one-on-one fight. So, that means that
it would be at I think four XP for five
up technically. But if you don't have
any mechanics interact with it, it's
just Kha'Zix as an ambush.
>> Correct. Yeah. Sprite found comes down.
So, that means a sprite has hit the
field.
>> Resolves conquered a four.
Beachwitz uh is able to at least develop
a temporary unit for now.
>> Sorry, in the in the showdown.
Uh I'm going to play stack deck. That's
>> okay.
>> Okay. Going to use that legend ability.
Otherwise, you know, not much we can do.
>> Ooh, the Moonfall might get spicy.
>> That's big.
>> We're fully tapped out,
>> but it would pull the Kha'Zix in. It's a
six. It would go to eight and then down
two
>> unless we play a unit and then Moonfall.
>> True. That's a good point. playing a
unit and not triggering Starring. One of
the rare instances that you wouldn't
want to do it.
>> Or if we don't have a unit, we can do
what you said earlier, which is
acceptable losses.
>> Yeah. Oh, and it would even kill. Okay,
>> that works, too.
>> Yep.
>> We're out of all the possibilities.
>> We're getting too cute and too creative.
>> This also serves the function that
Kha'Zix can come out on a future turn,
but for now, five up. also will have to
redevelop an entire board as Bishw still
has five energy up to play.
>> Makes me a little happy when I see my
preview card getting played.
>> Yeah,
>> Starcross, my goat.
>> That was your preview card.
>> That was my preview card. Very
fortunate. Yeah,
>> fantastic card,
>> man. What a preview card to be gifted.
Wow.
>> I saw it and I was like, "Oh, this is a
good one.
>> This card's kind of crazy."
>> Yeah.
Now you do put the Kha'Zix back in the
hand. So you're technically a stop the
hold, so to speak. Uh you're not letting
them go to six. You're not letting them
draw from gloomfist, but you just put a
very scary ambush unit back in the hand
for four uh five up.
>> The mutated mouse are getting played
now. This is obviously going to be a
development turn. There's no way that
you can kind of
>> develop very small development. playing
around the moonfall because if you try
to moonfall the mouser in now you can
ambush that Kha'Zix there as well
>> I suppose. Yeah, good call.
>> So the sprite fountain has temporary
keyword so if it dies at the beginning
phase creating another ready sprite
token conquer to five for bewites and
still tight turn is available. Could
conquer and then draw a card at seed of
power.
>> Yep. Conquer to six draw a card from
seed of power
>> and now suddenly Bishwites is in a
really good spot here. And Kha'Zix is
still available, but
you have uh one turn to win, couple
cards advantage, and another unit
developed.
>> So, we know about a Moonfall, we know
about a hard bargain. I think I also saw
a Kha'Zix in the hand of Bishwitz.
>> So, something that we need to keep in
mind of as well. And it looks like a
stupify.
>> Yeah.
>> So, a lot of tricks.
>> I guess I'll ride the wind, too.
>> And this is now the tables have turned.
Diana looks like in they're in a very
very good spot to close this first game
out here in round number eight. But five
up,
>> he has more than five up, so he'll be
able to uh to make something [laughter]
happen here.
>> But I got to say, it's moments like this
that maybe that on guard would be
helpful. You know, you're able to
actually punch in. You don't have to
commit the boots and swifties to the to
the mouser.
>> Although committing them to mouser
doesn't feel that bad if you attack the
tie turn. Just so many runes up for
Bishites that like that on guard getting
the extra pump of damage.
>> You're going to be missing it.
>> Kha'Zix,
>> we have to be careful though as well
with the temporary trigger from the
sprite because if we just assume, hey,
we're just going to leave that there.
Um, we could just ambush the Kha'Zix in
in response to that trigger, allowing us
to hold to seven and then kind of go all
in with the Moonfall to try to pull that
clear that battlefield and go with the
with the traveling merchant at the seat
of power to win.
>> Um,
>> not sure. Five up is thinking about
that, but as someone who plays Kha'Zix
themsself,
>> I would assume so.
>> Mhm. Five up also I believe should be at
6 XP now for anybody who cares about
tracking that one. [laughter] uh six
might and now eight because of the
swifties. Doesn't seem like any way to
ready it. It's just going to be the one
point scored for five up and then
Bishwitz will start their turn. Full
ramp runes plus one unit.
>> No Kha'Zix notably not trying to get
that seventh point
which is again fine. Uh we're trying to
maybe look for a close out here. We have
a ride the wind. Yeah, I imagine you
could still do it with uh just send the
merchant into the starspring, ride the
winded over, you can Kha'Zix, then you
get two triggers of the merchant, you
have a stupify, you have a moonfall, you
have a lot of options.
>> I think it would have been kind of
interesting to play that Kha'Zix in
response to the trigger, then moonfall
the Kha'Zix over after you've already
scored, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then with the Moonfall when it
starts that showdown, you can then ride
the win your Kha'Zix away [laughter]
from that battlefield. Let your opponent
go to six but then score the eighth
point and if they do some shenanigans
then you kind of move in with that
traveling merchant afterwards.
>> Yeah, but again Bishwit's opting to not
do the hold point means that now you got
to solve a different puzzle. You got to
conquer twice.
>> Bishwitz has made the decision to move
the merchant in. Discarded the stupify
to get another merchant. Establishing
this one and passing. So Bishwitz with
five runes up on five up side is
actually
>> opting to play a very patient game.
>> Five up will not be able to win this
turn. holds for one and then can conquer
for a seventh point but could not win
unless you had something like a Baron
but even then not enough runes
currently.
Yeah, we did get the we got an extra
draw from the gloom fist but again we
have to
expect obviously with 10 runes ready on
the side of Diana that there's this
traveling merchant is not going to be
easy to push off of that battlefield.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> we do have a flash in hand on five up.
So, we could flash our Kha'Zix back. We
don't need to. We have the boots. Yeah,
he just ganks over.
>> But h let's see what Bishwitz does.
>> Passive.
>> Many cards in hand, many runes up,
>> many decisions to be made.
>> Just one actually if you think about it.
But
>> and there's the
>> There it is.
>> It's a bug party
>> at the old Star Spring. Now, uh probably
not going to pull that merchant back
because if you do, then you are a six on
eight. You probably just want to crash
here. And now it's an eight on 10.
>> Uh discipline resolves.
>> Maybe Moonfall is going to come up here
perhaps.
>> All right. the wind. My
>> Oh,
>> Kha'Zix's over here.
>> Uh, Elfy,
>> nice. Good defy there from five up. That
was getting dicey.
>> All right, the wind a very fun card in
moments like this to try and just dodge
the combat and instead
>> go for a game-winning play.
>> You conquered a six.
>> You're able to just get onto another
battlefield. Five ups in a really tough
spot.
>> Oh, you held. You held. Sorry, you held
a to six and conquered a seven.
>> There we go.
>> Like when players uh confirm with each
other what the game state is, everyone
needs to make sure that they know what
their opponent's win condition is. It is
now seven to seven. Five up is scored on
both battlefields this turn.
>> So, it's going to be about either
developing or just holding runes up to
try and hold. Bishwitz has a unit
>> and it's going to be again full ramp
runes at the start of their turn.
>> Yeah, I was debating the charm. I I like
it. Uh you're going to get clearing
their stuff off the board.
>> Okay. So, pretty much asking you to
commit to it. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Five up could guarantee just clear this
merchant, but then that means that they
have nothing up essentially for
Bishwit's turn to be one rune. I think
Existential Dread is like the only card
I saw in their deck that they would
really be able to pilot for play at that
point.
>> Mhm. Unless they have another on guard
that they drew.
>> True. But
>> yep, that that was
>> trying to see what the threats are here.
>> Yeah, one of existential dread for the
uh ong guards. I suppose even like a
stacked deck. Not that it would do much.
>> I think you have to keep some runes up.
>> Yeah,
>> I think I did see another defy. Perhaps
I'm wrong.
>> Uh we do have an on guard. We do have an
existential dread. We have another boot
of swiftness and we have a flash and
then a mystery card in the hand of five
up. Oh, we have a Hay and Ride the Wind
that we saw with the same stack deck.
That's pretty nice. And the hard bargain
as well is going to really help push
that through. Let's see how 1 2 3 4 5 1
two. You You can double hard bargain.
Bishwites could double hard bargain with
the Hay,
but it would be eight attacking eight if
you discard a unit because the Kha'Zix
is six and then gets a plus two for a
fighting alone.
>> You're going to get two draws here,
right? One from the merchant, one from
trying to conquer to eight, but not
score in the other battlefield.
>> Discarding the Moonfall.
>> We have a ride the wind, we have an
Eclipse, we have a Vex.
Okay, this would uh stop a second
Kha'Zix from coming down.
>> Ride the wind.
>> Aama in response to ride the wind here.
>> Oh, nice
>> for the That's it.
>> And with that four leaving one up, you
have an existential dread as well. So in
case they try to commit to make that Vex
very large, you don't care about your
runes, you're going to win this turn,
you existential dread it, stun it. Yeah,
>> it recalls back home and you take game
one in a very very tight actual match.
Now we're going to go to an arena's game
for Diana,
>> but an abandoned hall game for Vex,
which I am of the opinion that Diana
probably uses that battlefield better,
but looking at this is chalk full of
spells.
>> Typically, I would agree. But this is a
fight combat Vex deck. It's got ong
guards. It's got disciplines. It's got
back off that you can use aggressively.
It's got spells that you can use
proactively when you punch in. But this
is a good start for Beast Whites. The
Rand Bloom Student will hit the field on
turn one.
>> And we got the mutated Mouser. One of my
favorite cards in the new set, by the
way.
>> Really? Little cat with tank.
>> A lot of tails. Not quite a thousand.
>> Well, it's mutated.
>> It is mutated.
>> It's not a thousand tail watcher. It's
like, you know,
>> ninetailed watcher.
>> Four tail tank. Okay. [laughter]
Port tail tank. That's a good name for
it. You know,
>> pretty textbook opens from both players
here, right? Two drop into uh you know,
two drop and playing my Diana.
>> And now we get to get a little bit more
fun with it. And naturally Bit saying,
"Hey, you playing an abandoned hall? I'm
going to go sit on that one."
>> Mhm.
>> With my Raven Bloom student. So, every
spell is a swing of two,
>> which is something that we have to keep
it keep our eye on here for five up.
>> Really good combo for uh any blue deck,
any uh of the mind decks. And
unfortunately, Vex does not have access
to that Raven Bloom student. So then
said the mouser will go over to the
arena's greatest and that gust will
respond. Five up has a reaction window.
Maybe a Kha'Zix would be the play if you
really want to get the point and try and
hold for one. Kha'Zix would be good. We
had a define hand that I saw as well.
>> Oh, sure.
>> Maybe trying to protect that battlefield
just to be able to do stuff like play
Kha'Zix after or bait the Diana to an
unfavorable trade. So, a lot this is a
pretty big decision point here is what
am I going to do with this mouser,
right? Am I going to let it get bounced
back to hand, just replay it for two,
take a turn off, and let my opponent go
to four for free? Doesn't sound the
greatest. When I'm looking at the hand
now, the only thing option we really
have here looks to be the defy.
>> If you defy, then you can just play your
Vex apathetic to Arena's greatest and
you have a tank uh protecting the Vex.
So, maybe that would be the play, but
then you're completely exhausted on
runes. Nothing else to play unless you
have a hidden card. Let's see what else
I can.
>> We do have an Evelyn in hand.
>> Evelyn. I think that's existential
dread, I believe, next to the Evelyn
left.
>> No, that's a charm.
>> Charm.
>> We have a tide turner, Aurelia, Fervent,
Existential Dread, Charm, and that Defy.
>> Well, the Defies hit the table.
>> You conquered the
>> So, no Aurelia play this turn.
>> Couple of units. Yeah, Tide Turn are
going to go out to the battlefield.
Probably hide the Evelyn, I imagine.
>> Oh, that's pretty good. I like
I'll use Diana's ability.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> So, conceding that our Diana is going to
going to perish here.
>> Yeah.
>> Just trying to get some more
information.
>> We have a Fizz now.
>> Could get back to Gust.
>> Um I'll pass Focus. Uh pass back.
>> And there goes the Mouser. Did exactly
what it's there to do. Protect the unit,
keep control of that battlefield, clear
up the
>> uh clear up the Diana in the backline.
And then now if you want to kind of push
that Vex off and deny her card
advantage, you have to get off of the
abounding hall with your Raven Bloom
unless you have a way to uh accelerate
something in which with just six runes,
you can't really wear the ride the wind
here.
>> Uh so it's going to be a little bit
awkward to kind of try to get over to
that battlefield and start denying the
card advantage that Vex can get.
>> Well, if you want to preo
>> Oh, okay.
>> Wow. We want to be psychos.
That was
>> and the stone of all time.
>> And the stone cold poker stare from
five.
>> I don't really think I want to be a
psycho.
>> Oh, come on. Be a psycho, Bishwit.
>> Just have your card.
>> Oh, no. Do it for the people.
>> Okay. Well, Bishw's not going to play
the the psycho game.
>> Um, ready this go to three. Yep. Hex
trigger.
>> Yep.
>> Bishw saying, "Yeah, you can have your
extra card."
>> Drop for turn.
>> Five did ramp a lot of runes on that
turn. Yeah, we did draw another Defy. We
do have an Evelyn which acts as a charm
now cuz if we flip it on our turn, uh,
we can pull something in. That being
said, if we pull the Raven Bloom in,
it's kind of spicy. And if we pull the
Traveling Merchants in, we let them
cycle their hand.
>> And Diana Legend is still up. So that's
>> Yeah, we got three.
>> Yeah, it's a definitely a spice one.
>> Let's see what five up decides to do.
You could play the Vex Apathetic.
Not that that really helps, I suppose,
in the the whole Evelyn charm scenario.
>> Oh, wait. Evelyn's in hand, so didn't
hide the Evelyn, I guess.
>> Oh, was what was the other hit? Was it
Edge of Knight? No.
>> Trying to remember what the uh the other
hidden card was cuz we we saw the entire
hand. I believe some cards in my hand.
>> Unless it's another Evelyn. Maybe he
drew the Evelyn for turn. Yeah, cuz he
drew two cards for turn. He drew the the
>> Yes, he might have drawn the Evelyn and
the defy. Okay,
>> that would make sense. Yep.
>> Or he accidentally hit
>> like the Scooby gang. We We got to the
bottom of that one.
>> We took the mask off.
>> We took the mask off. Turns out
>> it was us the whole time. Yeah. Just
being silly little guys.
>> Little guys. Like Beast Below.
>> Yes. Just like Beast Below. Shout out to
five people that have
>> watched from that game and [laughter]
understand that reference when we were
also vamping there. Five. I'm saying a
lot of time. Oh, there we go. There he
is. There he is. The little guy. Show
little guy. Uh five is taking a lot of
time to decide this turn. I think
understandably you're up one in this
series,
but this game state currently is
precarious.
>> One of the merchants.
>> Going to flip the Evelyn. Pull in the
merchant.
>> Move trigger.
>> Yep.
>> Discard acceptable losses.
>> Sure.
>> Draw a card.
>> Okay. acceptable losses goes down.
>> Uh I'll pass pass back.
>> Okay.
>> Kind of interesting that stayed in the
main deck after siding. I would have
expected that to be one that comes out.
>> Yeah, maybe. I mean, again, it's it's so
versatile in the list, right? Cuz you
can either throw it away, you can use
it, especially on abandoned hall game.
>> You tap your Diana Legend and your Raven
Bloom gets plus two.
>> If if you read the five ups on the
abandoned hall. Yeah, cuz that was a
five ups choice of battlefield there.
>> Yeah. Sometimes you just don't have a
great card to replace it with from the
side either. You're not ready for this
type of matchup with that many
sideboard.
>> Yeah.
>> Thanks to
>> And also if you're on sprite fountain,
you keep those in. Acceptable losses let
you accelerate that sprite fountain and
kind of get six smite on one turn if you
need it. So
>> all right. Well, Vex Apathetic goes to
the base of five up just developing a
small backline. And I think Bishwitz is
going to be rewarded for not playing as
he said like a psycho cuz now with five
being completely exhausted in terms of
energy. Nothing can be done about what
Bishe is about to do here. Yeah,
Moonfall paying the deflect cost, moving
it in. Everything gets minus two.
>> That's be a three on two might total
with the plus one on Braven Bloom. And
that is
>> disastrous for five up. Bishwitz just
took control of the entire board.
>> Yeah, I feel like that was a very risky
play for five up, right? just kind of
tapping out to play, but there was
nothing really else you could do except
for hide an Evelyn with your Evelyn
right besides that. You didn't have
enough to play your Aurelia.
>> You're not just going to sit there with
four ready and one Evelyn and be like,
"Hey,
>> come at me.
>> Come and get me."
>> Yeah.
>> So, a tough spot to be in right now for
five up. And
>> I can't even think of anything five up
could draw here that gets you back into
this game. I mean, at this point, it's
your next turn is probably just going to
be develop again and pass. And your
development's going to be an Aurelia,
just a singular Aurelia. You have Defy
as well, but Bishwitz is going to get
two more turns here. Vex Apathetic at
the battlefield. Going to be pretty
good.
He drew a Dread.
>> Sure. Stun it.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. That's it. That's the entire
development. Bishwit's at seven. You
just need to hold one of these two or
you can move everything back and then
try and punch in harder on your turn if
you want.
But keeping that Vex Apathetic out there
can feel pretty good. Let's see if
Bishwitz actually wants to go. At least
the merchant will move back. Cycle a
card.
>> Coming home. Yeah.
>> I mean, we're at we're at seven here at
this point. No point in overcommitting.
No point in playing for the hold.
There's one unit and then we just
dropped the Hay [laughter] as well.
>> The proverbial nail in the coffin, so to
speak. We have a bunch of might in our
backline. We have that can get bigger
and all we have to do is conquer both
battlefields next turn. And they have an
Aurelia.
>> This this game 6 ft deep. Uh one Aurelia
I don't think is going to be enough to
deal with this field.
>> Trip
to four.
>> Kong to four points. Aelli is out of
battlefield. Bishwites needs to conquer
two to win this turn
>> on their following turn I suppose I
should say.
>> So there's the Evelyn getting hidden
unless we drew back off or something.
And now we're just saying hey you got to
have it.
>> Existential dread defy. What was the
third card in hand? What did five draw
for turn? I'm trying to
>> trying to spot it.
>> Dread back and back off. So very
interactable hand.
>> Very interactable back off can even draw
into something like an ong guard or a
discipline. Yep. So I think five up if
you draw the right thing off of this
maybe actually lives. But the problem is
like if I'm Bishwits I'm trying to get
rid of that Aurelia quickly because if
it's like an Evelyn or a Titturner
that's flipped that doesn't get as big
off of all these things that target it.
Aurelia can get quite big. Nothing in
hand currently targets. It's actually
all just stun effects and um kind of a
bounce back to hand effects. But let's
see how Bewitz approach approaches it.
>> Uh draw card.
>> This is interesting. We're putting the
Vex on the Arena's greatest. This is
notable because now if it is a hidden
unit, it's going to be stunned.
>> True. That's actually point. I didn't
even think about that.
>> Or Kha'Zix in hand would be stunned.
>> Yep. Very, very heads up play.
>> We're giving up the might that we'll
get, but and the rebuke we see it being
used.
>> Floating energy.
>> A very expensive rebuke.
>> Note floating energy.
>> Reveal Evelyn.
>> It is stunned.
The Aellia will go back to hand, but
five up does at least have a unit there.
That is crucial because with all of
these stun effects uh in hand, that
means that if Evelyn can just hold, then
beites can ever conquer. Also important
to note that Defy could not hit the
rebuke. The one of Rebuke did come up
into the defy match up.
>> Traveling Merchant.
>> Yep.
>> So we're we're using Quay first.
>> Quay gets a plus three. So this is an
easy existential dread target.
>> Traveling Merchant.
>> Very high value as well.
>> Discard Fizz, draw a card.
And I'm probably thinking we're backing
off the Raven Bloom.
>> We're existential dreading the Qu
Existential Dread uh on these two.
>> Oh, nice. Double stun works as well.
>> You're stunning these two units.
Stunning these two.
>> Yeah, you don't have to stun and then
target that same. You can split the stun
across two.
>> And the back off here to just full stun
and recall them is a very very good
play.
>> Yeah.
>> And then giving plus one to this if it
>> Oh, it's a banned hall. Yeah, you
actually don't need to commit the back
hole technically right now.
>> Use my floating energy.
>> This is
>> three total energy plus the one power
>> defy.
>> Nice. Y
>> and exactly enough runes to back off as
well. Left up.
>> Yep.
>> You know, name five up. This is a heads
up play
>> from the Vex player. Well, they did a
five up at the beginning of this Diana
player.
>> Oh, that's a good point.
>> My
>> Yeah, that's good. Okay.
>> All right. Starcross gets there.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Back off could stun the merchant, but a
stunned unit can still conquer the
battlefield. So, as long as the Evelyn's
gone and there's no body there to push
back the stunned units. Bishwites would
conquer that. Five ups going to go to
game three and have to pick up that
Evelyn at some point here. But Bites is
able to equalize one to one now in this
very very pivotal last round of the day.
This is round eight. If you go
undefeated into day two, you put
yourself in a really comfortable
position.
>> Yeah, we're going to be actually going
to abandon Hall for Bishwit. So, another
abandoned hall game. But notably, I
don't think Bishwitz is prepped for a
fortified position there.
>> I would be very shocked. It's almost
similar to abandoned hall. It's just
only on defense.
>> Yeah, it it essentially it's a similar
thing. It's just, you know, during
combat, but Phil's a similar position,
but if you can get there first cuz five
up will be going first, we assume. Um,
then you just keep holding that and then
maybe Vex does turn into a bit of a more
stack everything and hold type of deck
as there's the Mouser.
>> Yeah, we got Mouser into Diana. And now
we're This is where it gets a little
tricky though because if we bring that
Mouser up to fortified position and we
have a charm, that's all we need. We get
the shield from the Mouser and the
shield from the fortified position. We
get shield four. Uh and that's kind of
going to punish you. But I don't see a
charm. We're just going to play the Vex
and we're going to say we got a big
battlefield. We have a mouse uh sorry,
Mouser, which is a cat with many tails.
uh who has potentially a shield four or
you can give the shield to the Vex as
well if you want to but most likely
going to be using that Mouser to protect
that Vex
>> and a hidden card to boot. So uh five up
has a very fortified position.
>> Oh, I like what you did there.
>> Well, I should say very fortified
fortified position. Fortified squared
position.
>> Exponentially fortified.
>> Now it's getting a little ridiculous.
Bishwe is going to have five runes and a
Diana to try and crack this or you just
accept the Vex is going to be drawing a
lot of cards. This is the pressure seat
that most Vexes try and put people in is
like, "Okay, hit me or I'm going to get
card advantage on you. And if you hit
me, I got answers." Um, Diana doesn't
have to take the bait. Can just choose
to go to the abandoned hall. And that is
what Beichwitz is going to do and just
accept probably. I imagine that five up
will be getting a lot of draws.
>> Yeah, we're going to reveal a rebuke.
The one of being found again.
>> And yeah, just double checking. We're
not running any in the side either. So a
true one of just always has it.
>> Yep.
Now I expect Vichwitz to develop more of
a board. A Vex Apathetic is a great
development here and a pass of turn. So
five up will get the Vex Gloomist extra
draw.
Channel two runes and draw for turn. So
five runes to play with a lot of cards
in hand. And as long as you just keep
holding this
>> um I like this kind of pivot here.
You're no longer pressured to keep
fighting. Yes, you have on guard in
hand. It's not going to do as much in
this like double hold position, but you
can just develop a unit to base. You can
play the pike. I like this a lot. Now,
anytime a unit dies while he's out of
battlefield, uh at least the first time
a unit dies while he's out of
battlefield each turn, you can get a
gold gear exhausted. Also has backline.
Oh,
I'm hearing
>> I'm hearing the judges have a
conversation, but I don't know if that's
live right now. So, uh
>> I'm not seeing it synced up with the uh
the lips of the players.
>> All right. Well, the Vex is uh either
way getting swapped with the Tie Turner
and going into the Diana. There's one
rune up on Bishwit's side.
Let's see if he's going to have a
response. It's stacked deck. So that
Diana is going down.
>> And that means that that uh Diana is
pretty much just marked for death.
You're not going to be able to save
that. Vex will be able to clear that.
And FiveUp is still holding very strong
on the other battlefield. I believe I
did see a uh an ong guard in hand. Did
you Did you notice that for five up or
was I I saw a one energy spell that was
I'm pretty sure that that was I didn't
see that. Trying to take a peek here if
I can take a look.
>> Might be a charm. No, it's a star cross.
Okay, just going to put that Vex back to
hand.
>> My tie turner.
>> So, there's this. And here's the
deflection.
>> Yeah, she needed to play something to
get that Vex above the might of Diana.
>> Uh, so we're going to be five. Bounce
the Vex back. A little bit expensive,
right? We have to recycle two. One for
the uh star cross and one for the Vex's
deflect. But again, this allows us to
win. Now we're very well established on
both of these battlefields and fantastic
position
>> with our Vex there. They can't really do
anything.
>> Yeah. And the Pike just saw something
die. So the gold gear will come out. Uh
and then you can still hide the tide
turner if FiveUp wants to spend another
power cost and is going to do just that.
So heavy D ramp going to be a four runes
at the start of FiveUp's turn. I don't
think they created a gold gear off the
pike. So, five up has not actually
triggered that pike uh to to get the
extra uh power cost for the next turn,
but we'll see if that actually ends up
mattering or five up would need that.
Either way, it's a development turn for
Bishwitz. It's going to be Vex Apathetic
plus the Raven Bloom Student.
>> Yeah. So, a little bit of again, we're
redeveloping, which is what we did last
turn, which is a huge tempo swing now. 5
to one in this game. That fortified
position not really impactful right now
yet, but you know,
>> plus the extra draws every turn from the
Vex Gloomist and five up is in a
fantastic position
to continue controlling this game and
close it out. Seems like uh judges were
consulted about something right there.
>> No cards at the beginning, right?
>> And now it is FiveUp's turn to play
here.
Bishwit's looking at their hand.
It's five up. I can't tell if they're
processing the play or if Bishwitz is
considering a
trigger. I don't think there's a
reaction window here unless it was off
of the Vex Blumis, but the
>> the Glumus would be the only thing.
>> But turns have already been channeled,
so it it would appear as if we've passed
the beginning phase.
Well, either way, it seems like we have
a slight pause on play on the stage
right now. Current game state is still
five points to one. It's still five up
with a massive card advantage and Bites
having to solve a brutal puzzle. How do
you get past a Vex that gets to start
first on fortified position and now also
controls Abandoned Hall. Five up has the
best of both worlds currently. Yeah, and
a full grip of cards as well. We have an
Evelyn there. We have a discipline there
with two disciplines actually it looks
like. Yeah, we have a tide turner if we
want to kind of like move and start
stacking a battlefield. A stack deck for
more information. Uh the world is our
oyster so to speak if we're five up
right now. We have a pretty big point
swing. So if we really wanted to we can
hunker down on the battlefield or we can
try to spread ourselves uh on both.
>> That vex as long as it's in play
somewhere will stop any new units from
coming in and kind of adding to the
party like those like Kha'Zix that we
saw or ride the wind or something of
that nature. As long as it's at a
battlefield at the very least.
>> Oh,
>> why would we play the game where both of
us know the top card instead of just
rand I'll appeal. Yeah, I'll appeal it.
>> Okay. It seems like So, so I did notice
that Bishwit's asked cuz when five up
picked up a card, it looked like a a
second card had kind of shuffled in as
well. Bishwitz had pointed it out and
now Five just revealed the top card of
deck. So potentially just
>> giving information to
>> both card too.
>> It's a random card.
>> It's a random. would be a random card,
but
>> yeah. Yeah. Interesting uh game state we
find ourselves in. It's been a long day,
a lot of dueling, I'm sure.
>> To play the game knowing what
>> the human element starts to come in when
you think about how many decisions these
players have had to make to go
undefeated on these streaks. It's a lot
of mental processing.
>> I think my brain would be jello at this
point.
>> Yeah. I'm tired. And all I've had to do
is talk about the game for half of the
rounds.
>> That's true. Yeah. Not even all eight.
And these players, even if they had the
buy, right, they've been playing for
now. This is their seventh round if they
have the buy. Eighth if they didn't have
a buy and undefeated in game three, 13
minutes left on the clock. It's been a
long day for them. And you know, I'm
sure they're hungry. I'm sure they want
to go get some rest. Uh so obviously
want to make sure Riftbound decides who
wins as well. Exactly.
>> Want to listen in on what the players
are saying here.
>> We do have a judge call.
>> Yeah. just trying to get insight into
their current states as again it's a one
to one game
tight game state for Bwites
I would argue heavily on the back foot
currently
>> yeah you're a puzzle guy
>> solve
>> solve win in one turn
>> uh maybe not one maybe not one turn but
like how do you break kind of
>> drop a purple yaso and a purple Draven
on the field [laughter]
>> and two spellers
>> and two spellongers Yeah, that's a fun
one. Um, maybe we'll get a chance to
show some of that content. We had some
fun. I created some dual puzzles for
some of the pro players. We got
prismaticism and try out a couple. He
was surprisingly very good at them.
>> Who would have thought?
>> Who would have thought, right? Yeah.
Solved them in about 30 seconds each and
made me feel silly. Uh, I spent a lot of
time on those. Um, but maybe we can get
some other players to do some later on
as we're waiting for this judge call to
come through. I got to ask because again
on the topic of uh of energy stamina on
these long days, how does it feel on the
casting side, Gret? I know that you've
been on the the head judge side. Those
have got to be long days as well. Do you
feel like you have more energy being the
on the commentary side now?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Jud Judging is you're on
your feet all day, right? You're I think
in Atlanta I did uh 35,000 steps on
Saturday.
>> That's a lot of steps.
>> Um Yeah. So that is in the tier list of
steps. That's on the lot of side.
>> That's a lot of side. Yeah.
>> My bad.
But yeah, casting has been awesome.
Community's been great. The games have
been phenomenal. So, it's really fun to
be able to sit and watch the games and
not
>> co-casters have been great.
>> You've been okay.
>> Okay, I'll take okay.
>> Okay,
>> I'll take okay. You know what? I strive
for okay.
>> Okay. Is a good place to be. I had a a
college professor that gave me a great
lesson. They said, "Don't let perfect be
the enemy of good." You know, just
sometimes good is good enough.
>> I feel like I've heard that somewhere.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, is okay good or is
okay a tier below good? Cuz it kind of
feels like it's a tear below good based
on the look you gave me. You said it.
>> No comment.
>> No. Okay. All right. We'll get back to
that one. Upstage comedy. Yeah, we're
making jokes. Be
>> slow. Shout out Kai. I called them the
observer cuz they observe for League of
Legends all the time and I know they're
the one clicking the button for those
cards. We could say any card and Kai
would probably run it. Brother Kai, run
um irresistible fa. Let's see if it
works. Will Will Kai do it or will he
throw me under the bus?
>> There it is.
>> Hey, shout out Kai. Let's go.
>> Got it.
>> You try it. Name a card.
>> Promising future.
>> Kai, don't do it. Kai, don't do it. It's
going to be really funny if you don't do
it.
>> They can hear you. Oh, there it's gone.
Ah, [laughter]
>> shout out Kai. Well, promising future.
Just cuz you're a Lux player, you want
to highlight that one?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, understandable.
>> It's a good card. Fun card.
>> It's a great card. I used to play it.
So, so the funny thing about Promising
Future, especially in Lux, is I used to
play a Lux deck in Origins where the
whole meme was you just draw cards.
You're just playing Promising Future and
um Oh, actually, we're getting an update
potentially for the judge.
>> We have a card and then we
>> Yeah,
so this was really a looking at super
card information and they were told that
it was just going to be revealed.
>> Can't quite make out what the judge is
saying, but
>> that's all right. The way that we fix
these situations if we can is we try to
uh randomize it into the random portion
of the y.
>> Do you know anything about your deck?
Did you mulligan? Have you rec?
>> No mulligan. No recycle.
>> Okay. So you don't know anything about
nothing.
>> Okay. So I'm going to have you take that
shuffle it away. The warning is correct
still.
>> Can I have you shuffle? Yeah, I'll
shuffle.
>> Y and we'll basically continue on get
you the program extension. Take about 12
minutes. Okay.
>> Uh do they just stop?
>> It would be.
>> All right. Seems like we
>> they added the two while you were gone.
>> Had a ruling.
>> So, how much time do we have overall
now?
>> Yeah, we're now we're talking about the
time extension. Uh, which is totally
fine. Uh, it looks like a if I had to
guess,
>> educated guess looking at extra card
error.
>> Past head judge
>> formerally head judge. No longer
currently head judge.
>> Now level three caster.
[laughter]
>> Le caster.
>> L caster. So, it looks like looking at
extra cards. So, what we're going to do
is just shuffle the random portion of
the deck. Since he didn't mulligan and
he hasn't recycled any cards, the entire
deck is the random portion of the deck.
So, we're just going to shuffle the
deck, continue play, uh, and take it
from there.
>> Tough position to be in, but it looks
like uh, as we resume play, the Evelyn
will reveal from Hidden, pulling in the
Raven Bloom Student. There are two
backline units now, plus a tank unit
anyway. So, that Mouser will be tanking
up the damage.
>> Plus four cuz of the fortified position.
>> Oh, yeah. That is a final.
>> So we have a time extension of seven
minutes for that judge call just to make
sure that we had that uh for the
players. So you'll see that eight jump
up to 15. So this is not the round timer
for round eight specifically, but it's
the round timer for our Bishwitz versus
five up match.
>> Yes. Want to make sure that the players
still have the full amount of time to
play after a very precarious board
position, especially for Bishwitz
because when you're this far behind and
uh your undefeated streak day one is on
the line, you definitely want that time.
This time up doesn't remember the gold
gear. So, the pike does create one
anytime it's out of battlefield and any
unit on your opponent's field dies if
you kill an enemy unit. Um, then you get
the gold gear. In fact, actually, Kai,
speaking of Kai, could you pull up pike
for me, the purple pike? Cuz I I think
it might even just be if a unit dies.
>> Correct.
>> Uh, if you kill a unit at least one,
>> the first time a unit dies while I'm at
a battlefield, play
>> once for when an enemy unit dies while
I'm at a battlefield. Yeah, but you can
snipe it with a spell. You can do all
kinds of stuff. Yeah. Okay, cool.
>> I pulled up the alt art, too, for Nice.
Thank you.
>> Showing it off.
>> Yeah, I got three of those.
>> Weird flex.
>> I lied. I have two. I'm just going to
use that instantly. [laughter]
I'm just going to stop that.
>> I correctly flex. Yeah. So, stack deck
here. Going to look at Oh, we see a
Kha'Zix. We only have three runes ready.
Unless that Okay, three runes ready, it
looks like. Going to take a look at our
hand. We do have a discipline. Two
disciplines still in hand.
>> This is again a very commanding
position. Four five up,
>> I'd say. So, uh, Bishwitz has one unit
developed. It's a good one. It's Vex
apathetic, but you're not even worried
about a Kha'Zix coming down because
there's only three runes up at this
point. You're just worried about getting
points and trying to deny five up as
much as you can. Five up can hold two
and then be threatening game on the next
turn.
>> But at least will guaranteed have two
more turns to figure out this puzzle.
And the thing is again, you have to push
that Vex off that battlefield to be able
to get other units in to try to break
that fortified position because that is
a big battlefield, right? You're going
to have a tank unit there that's going
to have five might, then a backline with
three and another backline with two. So,
you have 10 might to go through and
guess what? There's a hidden card. It
could be a back off. It could be another
Evelyn. It could be another pike.
>> Merchant.
>> It could be a merchant.
>> They're not merchant. Uh tie turner.
>> It can be a tie turner.
>> Please don't be a merchant. We don't
want the game to end.
>> That [laughter] would be a very awkward
game loss. That's for sure. You ever
tried to hide a rebuke? Uh, all right.
Fiz comes down. It's going to copy a
stacked deck. It looks like
>> we [snorts] found a singularity. That's
actually not a terrible.
>> It's a very good one.
>> Uh, one. It gets around. If they do have
a tie turn, it doesn't really care where
the unit is. It's just going to shoot it
for six anyway. So, if you want to try
to get rid of that Vex and maybe the
Mouser or the Pike for example, you can.
It does feel a little bad to kind of
singularity a three might or a one might
unit, but on that fortified position
that is not a three might and a one
might unit when you try to fight them.
>> Uh five up would have to chain what
three spells to save the Vex cuz
abandoned hall could uh give it plus one
each time.
>> Although I suppose things seems like on
guard actually on guard could
>> discipline just saves it.
>> Yeah, discipline does or unguard. Yeah,
true. But it's just going to be a combat
for Bishweite. So sending in the Vex
apathetic and then
>> in combat gusting the pike to try and
deny the gold gear generation. And this
also gives the plus one might to vex at
abandoned hall.
>> There's an interesting decision now with
who you discipline. Are we disciplining
our pike to get it out of gust range or
are we disciplining our Vex to get it a
bigger but like buff over the other Vex
and not just in a trade.
>> The pike plus.
>> Interesting. Okay. Okay, so we're
disciplining the Pike
>> and then we give the plus one to the
Vex. So now the Vexes would crash.
>> Pike correct does not get bounced back
to hand. And the Vexes currently are
threatening each other. Five on five if
we heard that correctly.
>> Ooh, hard bargain is going to be great.
>> Very big because this will deny the plus
one might from the abandoned hall and it
will also
give another might to the Vex on
Bishwit's side. And there's the tide
turner. We're going to save our Vex.
This is beautiful.
>> Not a merchant, notably.
>> Yeah,
>> the intent was there. Yes,
>> you were well intentioned.
>> Mhm. And this will swap away. The Vex
Apathetic will survive over at the
fortified position and Titer will
unfortunately get beaten down to the
trash as Vex Apathetic is quite large
right now. And that is a point to be
Schwitz.
>> I'm actually curious and it's something
I'll check in afterwards. how many of
this Vex uh their Swiss run today went
to game three because if we're keeping
the fortified position for game three I
don't think a lot of players are
accustomed into playing into it and if
we look at the strategy used by five up
here
>> not really caring about the abounded
hall at all just hunkering down on that
fortified position
>> exactly and I feel like fortified
position is such an obvious oh when I'm
going first guaranteed and if Vex's are
able to win their first game and then
going second they you know don't play
that fortified position they play the
abandoned hall instead cuz it helps them
punch in. It's again a similar concept
to the for position, but you can also
use it offensively.
>> Yeah, really heads up play.
>> We have another Evelyn, another
discipline. Again, our rune economy is
kind of low here though for five up. A
very power hungry deck. Uh obviously
because you have so many hidden cards
and
your charm and deflect on the other side
is kind of taxing your rune economy
here. So, five of trying to find the
optimal line. Going to tide Turner.
Maybe bring Yeah, bring back the Vex.
And now we're going to try to go fight
the other Vex, which should be pretty
easy. Everything's tapped out. Our Diana
Legends tapped out. We're just going to
discipline, draw an extra card, and
we're at seven. And now,
>> Kangas,
>> now it's puzzle time. You need to break
both or you lose.
>> You cannot let Five hold a single point
from this position. The seven might vex
will beat the four might Vex. Five up
draws a card for the discipline.
>> Goes to seven points. M
>> can hide a card. We know that the purple
pike was in hand.
>> Another hidden card.
>> Yeah. So, we got an Evelyn and a Pike if
I had to put my money on something.
>> Sure.
>> Cuz we saw them both. But again, that's
depending where we hid what, right?
That's three might somewhere and two
might somewhere else with backline. So,
it's going to be a little tricky to
break through both of these unless we
have, you know, the best hand ever as
our Diana. But with that Vex on the
battlefield, you need to clear the Vex
before you do something.
>> We know singularity is in hand. That's a
big one because there's not enough runes
for a hard bargain on five's side or an
abandon or anything like that. So the
singularity you can expect will go off.
I would imagine it hits the Vex
apathetic and the mouser.
>> Yeah. Um
but then after that that's a lot of your
runes that you dispense. So Bishwites
will still need more after that to try
and get through. But singular is a great
place to start because it also kind of
gives you information. You'll see what
uh at least the hidden card of the Vex
Apathetic is.
>> Yeah. And it'll leave you with, if my
math is correct, four runes in your
Diana legend. So effectively five if you
utilize your runes properly. I've seen
that as well.
>> Not terrible, right? But we're going to
try to skirmish a little bit first, it
looks like.
>> Not what I expected. Snacked deck in
combat will trigger the abandoned hall,
giving the Fizz plus one might. So
that's now four a threatening four.
I wonder if we're just asking for a
trade here. I don't see how that gets us
the win, but at least clears the Vex if
we have something like Quay Ride the win
in our hand that we're trying to I'm
going to reveal pull off.
>> And there's the Pike.
>> Okay,
>> so now we're at seven.
>> So the Fizz will only trade with a Vex,
not the Pike.
And then the gold gear would be
generated, but there's still a lot of
runes up for Bwites.
>> There is a Rebuke that we know that is
in hand, right? Or I believe it was this
game where we saw that one of Rebuke.
Yep. And that's going to be two runes
flipped over and we're going to be
rebuking the pike. Okay.
>> And that will give another might to the
Fizz. Fizz will now clear the Vex.
>> Conquer a three.
>> Five up still has one rune available,
one energy available, a hidden card, and
a lot of units at the fortified
position. But there's still a
singularity in Bishwit's hand. That is
still an option. Yep.
>> 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 total energy up. That
would be six of eight. You would still
have two more available,
>> but you can also Well, yeah, you really
can't just start to send units in and
try and chip away cuz fortified position
on the tank unit will just make it too
oppressive. Yeah,
>> it punishes those single combats, right?
You have to kind of swing in ones, have
them assign it.
>> Singularity here, I think, is a good
option. But if it's another unit and you
singularity two of those units, you're
again just trading and we're going to
push everything in. Interesting. side.
I'm going to assign it to merchant.
>> Yeah, move trigger on merchant.
>> Discard the apathetic. Draw a card. I
imagine this is probably a Kha'Zix
coming down at this point.
>> That is a big cat now.
>> Five tank
>> and plus the additional four. So that
should be nine defending on great.
>> Uh sorry, hold on.
So, we're moving the mouser over to
abandoned hall is our declaration I'm
putting it on the chain.
>> And this is good for multiple reasons.
It's going to mean the tie turner and
the Evelyn do zero damage. They're both
going to be zero might. And the mouser
is still a five. Actually, would it
still have the shield trigger?
>> It would lose shield.
>> It would lose shield. Yeah, cuz it's now
no longer
>> no longer a defender. Yeah, it's a
passive uh state of a one. Yeah,
[laughter] but even so, the plus one
from abandoned hall would have pumped up
the buff is to the six anyway. Um, let's
see what the other hand was. It's a
Netherland. Okay.
>> So, we do have two might that we can
kind of
>> Yeah. Uh, yeah.
>> You just kill all of them now.
>> Wonder would live. I only kill one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Moonfold is
>> I moonfold this though, right?
>> Oh, you
>> Oh, correct. Okay.
>> Oh, yeah. It's wherever you move the
unit to. Oh,
>> yes. Yeah. Oh,
>> now what? Okay, interesting. I guess in
that case, yeah,
>> but another Moonfall probably this
>> up here. [laughter] This still at least
uh prevents Vivo from winning on this
following
>> or Gust works, too.
>> It's a little less taxing on your rune
base.
>> Yeah,
two energy up. Let's see what Bishwitz
wants to do with it.
>> Okay,
>> passing the turn.
>> How many cards in hand?
>> One. One card.
>> One card in hand. We're going to be
going to six runes on the side of five
up. I don't really see a way to
accelerate, but again, Bishwitz is on
three points, right? That is at least
three more turns that we need to score
two points on each of those turns. So,
it gives us uh on five upside a lot of
opportunity to sort of set up for our
win our turn to win. And with one card
in hand, unless that's a
really rough to kind of come back into
it.
>> I think I see a Vex apathetic in hand
for five up.
I I at least see a four energy unit. I
can't tell if there's a power cost. It
could be a Kha'Zix, I suppose. Actually,
maybe that'
>> could be two Kha'Zix.
I did see a Vex cheerless if I'm not
mistaken. Uh that was on a stock deck,
but I don't know if it was taken by five
up.
>> Uh there's an Aurelia as well. So FO's
got a lot of options. you're really
going to uh develop one unit cuz most of
these are like four or five energies,
>> but still developing one unit. Okay,
it's going to be Evelyn and uh
>> Pipe. Okay,
>> so just replaying the known information,
>> which is actually very important. So,
we're not giving our opponent any more
information. They're like, "Okay, well,
I just saw these cards." Yeah,
>> but it does mean that you don't have
like an Aurelia readying
>> and then getting that plus one might and
then being able to, you know, move in
with an ong guard or something on five
ups turn. So,
>> more passive play, I'd argue.
>> There is a charm in hand which you can
use to just push something off of a
battlefield, right? You can use it as
kind of a pseudo offensive charm where
you just clear something and
>> score that eighth point,
>> make the Fizz go high five the other
Fizz.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> Or send them to base. Well, but then
they can swing back in at you.
>> Two cards in hand.
>> Two cards in hand. If they have it, they
have it. You know what I mean?
>> I guess
there's a very important decision now
for Bishwitz cuz depending on what is in
the hand. We know there's Kha'Zix in the
hand.
>> Four or five up. Yep. It is a very big
turn where you have to kind of decide,
am I going to try to keep them off both
battlefields? Do I try to fortify, no
pun intended, one of these battlefields?
What is the actual line here? And it
looks like the two cards in hand is a
stupifying a tide turner
>> and passing there. Not even playing the
tide turner, not even hiding the tide
turner. And this might be a little tough
because we can stupify the Kha'Zix when
we get it ambushed into, for example,
the abandoned hall or the fortify
position.
uh when we get that focus back or when
you know abandoned hall you get focus or
trigger or anything like that but again
I don't know unless we top deck
something insane from the stupify
>> this looks like it's in the bag for five
up here in round number eight
>> with Kha'Zix available with potentially
some buff spells like on guard
discipline I don't it's tough to see the
hand with the glare and five up also has
a lot of foil cards which makes it even
tougher
>> a hard bargain I think in the hand for
five up as well believe I saw it's the
last card closest to us.
>> Okay,
at the very least there's enough to deal
with the Fizz at the abandoned hall.
And if we want to commit the charm,
thank you for highlighting that. We can
send a Fizz over to another location and
then conquer. Looks like Kai's letting
us know the hand. It's a charm. It's a
flash. It's the Aurelia Fervent
as FiveUp starts to make the first call.
Pike will go in.
>> Kha'Zix. Yep.
>> I'll give this.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Naturally.
>> So, the plus two means a five might Fizz
defending.
>> Kha'Zix is now a six might attacking
with that Pike and Pike has back line.
>> Sure.
>> What do we draw?
draws one card. Have not seen it yet.
>> Gives the plus one might to the Fizz
over at the abandoned hall.
>> Um yeah, that resolves.
>> Uh I'll kill
>> and it looks like it was not something
that could be used in that combat or at
least not something that wants to use in
that combat. We'll just trade with the
Kha'Zix.
>> We got it
>> again.
>> 49 seconds on the clock. This could come
down to overtime if five up can't close
this out right here.
>> I'm going to charm your physical.
>> Yeah, I think it's just a charm and go
in right.
>> Oh, that's really tough.
>> I mean, be
>> gust gives you another turn here though.
And it is a
>> Gust.
We have a discipline. I I think
>> no.
>> Wow.
>> I guess no discipline.
>> We live to fight another day.
>> Yeah, hard bargain would have done
anything there either. There's enough
energy left on Bishwitz's side.
>> Yeah, I see. There's the hard bargain.
There's the flash in hand. There's the
Aurelia Fervent. There's the Kha'Zix.
>> We were one short from being able to
Kha'Zix.
>> Another Kha'Zix in hand. Yeah. So, all
all that five up can really do here is
hide the Evelyn, I suppose. And then you
hold up uh some energy for like a flash.
>> And the timer has hit zero. So, I I
would uh assume that this is now turn
up. I will hide a card.
>> The top deck of the century.
>> I mean, it could happen.
>> Into Gust to give that one. Yeah.
>> Another breath.
>> That's some Allen's EQ luck right there.
That was
>> And now we are in turn one of extra
turn. So each player will get uh Sorry,
we had the each player will get two more
turns. We just had the first turn from
five up. Now we're in the first turn
from
>> Bishwites.
Turn zero.
>> Yeah. Reminding himself your turn zero.
We knew that Ty Turner was in hand, aka
Timmy Turner.
I learned that uh from some of the
players. I didn't come up with that.
>> I'm pretty sure I told you that.
>> A good name. Oh, was it?
>> I think I was the one who told you.
>> No, [laughter] I heard it from uh some
cooler people. Okay.
>> Yeah, it was probably like prismaticism
or something.
>> It was me yesterday.
>> Sometimes you talk to me.
>> Oh, it was cooler yesterday [laughter]
>> back before I had to catch with you for
a whole day. Yeah, of course. All right,
the fizz is going to go into the
abandoned hall and that is going to be a
reaction of
>> uh that's fine,
>> Evelyn.
>> Yep.
>> Interesting.
>> Supposing maybe you're thinking like a
moonfall. I don't know. I mean, the tide
turner was already shown. It does seem
like it's going to be a Moon Moonfall
>> or not.
>> I mean, I I don't see how Bishwit's
going to have it. I I would think that
there's two cards in hand, right? It's
the tide turner and then whatever was
drawn for turn.
>> Star cross.
>> Star cross. Fizz. Star cross. Yep.
>> And then you can
>> What? Hold on. Three.
>> No, you have enough. Okay.
>> Cuz the hard you have to play around the
hard bargain a little bit, but you do
have enough. Yeah, cuz the the Fizz can
replay itself for three, copy the Star
Cross again, and play itself again.
If you hard bargain, then they can't
play the Fizz the next time, which I
think is definitely worth doing here cuz
it doesn't look because of the card
economy being so low for Bishwits. I
don't think you're going to get a ton of
value from that hard bargain cuz they're
not going to have enough cards to use
all their runes.
>> Exactly.
And then you deny them an extra card off
of like a stacked deck, which I believe
Bishwitz still has. Or Bishwitz could
just take the Gust.
>> Yeah, maybe a Gustier because then the
Fizz is guaranteed on the field. You can
just play the Tide Turner. Depends on if
you want to dig further into your deck
or just have two bodies on the field cuz
then if you have the Fizz and the Tide
Turner and FiveUp can't get onto the
board, you could just go in and try and
win. But nope, it is going to be the
Starcross.
>> Yep.
>> And it goes off. FiveUP's not going to
>> no hard bargain.
>> Hard bargain.
>> So,
>> here comes Fizz again. Stack deck
probably if I had to guess just to get
another card in the hand.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
now we hard bargain.
>> Interesting.
>> I like this play.
>> Okay, sure.
>> We get another turn if we want to
develop.
>> Yep.
>> Right.
Unless our
>> the one card in our opponent's hand is a
ride the wind or a unit and they draw
the other thing, then we're safe.
>> I believe five up saw the tide turner
hit the field and then white say ah and
then take it back. So should know that
that is a tie turner in hand. Should
know that there's not a lot has to work
with here.
>> And we're doing the develop again,
>> Evelyn.
>> Mhm.
>> We're back. [laughter]
Wouldn't you know it, it's the same two
units that were just on the field.
Bishwitz has somehow found a miracle to
stay in this game. Can he find one more
miracle and notably being at six and not
at seven, you can't just draw from
conquering.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're going to conquer now, go to
seven, and you're still going to have to
play with those two cards in your hand.
>> Vex apathetic.
>> That is a way to do it. But I think we
do have the Kha'Zix in hand.
>> Yep.
>> I don't know if we have enough. Do we
have pumps? Do we have something? We
have enough. We definitely have enough
runes to get over this.
>> It's coming down to the wire here. The
pause. This is the last turn. Five.
>> This could be where fortified position
backfires on five up.
>> Yeah. Actually,
now I'm trying to think back to when
turn zero was compared to turn one to
>> is it got back to five up.
>> Two three this. So, so was did Bishwitz
just finish his second turn in this
>> unless the graphic maybe the timer was
not super accurate? If it was Bishwit's
turn three, that should have ended the
game.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm assuming that maybe Bishwitz was
turn zero.
>> I I would imagine cuz he did also
reference turn zero. Sometimes the timer
is not quite right. I'm just going to
take a I always trust the judge of the
table. They're the ones that know the
time and they're the [laughter] ones
that would call what turn is zero. So,
sometimes on our end on the graphics,
it's not quite uh up to date. But that
does mean for everybody at home that
we're assuming that Bishwitz had
>> turn zero and now it's up to five up.
>> But notably that means it wouldn't get
back to Bishwit's turn to hold. Correct.
Looks like it's just a Vex.
>> Yep.
>> We're going to draw an extra card from
this back off. If it's any pump spell
for it,
>> we win.
>> That's game. GG.
>> GG's.
>> GG's are called.
>> Oh, don't worry about it. It's totally
fine.
>> Yeah. Well, wait. Is that Tai?
>> I believe it would be tie because
Bishwitz won't get another turn.
>> Bishwits can't hold for a turn.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's
>> I didn't even realize we were in turns.
It's I mean, I couldn't have done
anything differently, so it's fine. But
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. I believe that should be a tie for
both players at the table right there. A
tough one to say the least. Long pause
there. Uh Judge Ruling coming in. And
both players had a grueling day of
games. Seven and zero going into this
final round. That's a lot of riftbound
to process for one human brain.
>> Oh yeah. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> That was a long a long round eight. I
mean, both players technically still
undefeated,
>> right?
>> True.
>> Now just putting a one in the draw
column.
>> Losses don't exist, Granton. It's just a
learning moment or whatever you you've
said earlier.
>> I'm training you at this point.
[laughter]
>> True. And maybe uh some of your rules
knowledge will get soaked into my brain
as well. You know,
>> who knows?
>> Do I get a claim
level three judge? I don't have the
wristband. I looked at my watch. I have
this one. No. Yeah, not the same.
>> You have to graduate from the hot pepper
university.
>> Hot Pepper University. True. How How
much are courses in this? They're free.
>> Yeah.
>> Everyone can learn. Everyone can become
a judge.
>> I'm going to get a degree.
>> I'm going to Do you have like Do you get
a certificate when you graduate judge
program or anything?
>> Not yet, but I mean,
>> no.
>> Great feedback. Hey, let's get this guy
a certificate. That'd be great. You can
put it on a like a plaque and hang it up
on your wall.
>> Be my first one.
[laughter]
>> Nice. Nice. Well, either way, uh, a
tough one at the very end there, but you
saw a very unique and very cool Vex
build. I want to go back to that because
we haven't really talked about it. I
feel like by the time games two and
especially game three came around, we
saw a more traditional Vex uh, look, but
that game one was very exciting. the on
guards, the ability to punch. We didn't
see Aurelia Fervent do anything crazy,
but like the concept of Aurelia Fervent
with Kha'Zix's is really cool. I like
the creativity coming out from the Vex
player.
>> Yeah, and we kind of saw it there where
the abandoned hall or sorry, not the
abandoned hall, the fortify position at
the end of game three
>> kind of was the reverse nail in the
coffin that the Vex player was like,
well, now there's 11 might and I have
nine when I'm attacking and I need to
find some pump spell to get over it. But
the thing is, you would have to go run a
runner like a discipline into another
pump spell or a nexus uh or or just
something to stun. But even if you're
stunning, you're just going to bounce
back. So, it was a little tricky for for
that Vex player. But a very interesting
list allows for a lot of player agency.
And like I said, I don't think a lot of
people in this room
>> are really prepared for Fortify or this
version of
>> I imagine not. It's it's definitely not
one of the popular ones. So, it should
be able to kind of uh take people by
surprise, get you those wins. I'm
hearing though that we have uh best of
that we can start to talk about here
because we're at the end of day one.
Oftentimes some uh legends will already
be represented.
And wouldn't you know, my girl Jinx is
there. Jyn is there. Garen is there. And
that one's surprising. Ivory.
>> So you want to know some funny thing
about Garen? Yeah.
>> This is a Montrealer. You want to know
what his real name is?
>> Garen. Is this you?
Oh, this is Garen. got the Garen best
of. That's awesome. That's fantastic.
Oh, also I'm hearing that um if they
have the the real name that it's
confirmed. If it's just the uh legend
name, it's still in contention. So Jinx
looks to be in contention. Yeah, we have
Mr. uh Mr. Rays. I believe we saw him
who was undefeated earlier today. I
believe he was six and one going into
round eight. So curious to see how he
finished, but he did lock up Best of
Ivvern. So locked for day two, locked up
Best of Ivvern. Very good day for Ivvern
fans all across the globe. Sometimes
this doesn't mean that the players are
out of the tournament. Sometimes it
means you're the last one that qualified
for day two. And since you're the only
one on that deck that made day two, that
means that you get the best of. So,
shout out to these four. Awesome to see.
I met a lot of people that are going for
the gin. Oh, it's not. We're not over.
We got more. We got Leona, we got Vi, we
got Rumble. Actually, Vi still in
contention. Uh, but then set as well.
Colin K. How many best of sets does
Colin have at this point?
>> I think this is his fifth if I'm not
mistaken. That's That's like a tied
prismatism. He's tied Prismat I think at
this point.
>> That's awesome. That's cool. Uh Shadow
Clouds King and the Lost Ank.
>> Yep.
>> Rumble and Leona. You think it was Hook
Leona?
>> I don't think so. I feel like the the
Leonas that I've been liking are more of
like the um the the Namies and the the
Vise, you know, playing more of that
style than the hook style. But we'll
see.
>> But let's go take a look at the meta
share now. meta decks that we've had
today. Kind of take a look at that
together as we wrap up today. And
obviously to no one's surprise, Master
Yi, the most played deck this weekend,
but only at 11%.
>> Well, you say [music] to no one's
surprise. I know a couple of people that
would be surprised. Some folks ahead of
the day on Friday were saying, "Yeah, I
don't think that Master Yi is going to
be the one anymore. I don't think it's
going to be at the top. It's probably
going to be a Diana uh that would
[music] be the most popular." And Diana
is the second most popular. But this is
a pretty sizable difference between
Master Yi and Diana players. What's
crazy, if you take away the top three,
every deck after the top three is below
5% meta share in a player in a [music]
tournament with almost 2,000 players,
that is an exceptional feat. And we
continue going there. Already really
high on the the share, by the way. That
was pretty uh pretty high.
>> And uh a lot of these now going into 2.7
to 2.3% [music]
here. Only a seven total differential
between Rengar and Vex on this screen.
Almost cinematic Jin. We just needed
four more gins to show up, right? Almost
have 44. I'll take 42 and 2.4 A.
>> We got the fours there. We got the
fours.
>> Okay,
>> MF uh not too far behind Civer probably
a big Aurora shell there as well. And as
we jump into this other page here,
Lilia, Leona, Annie. Interesting to see
Annie this low if I'm being honest,
right, with how how much success Prismat
has been having with the deck list.
>> Well, also I think a lot of people would
just assume Prismat's going to get the
[music] six. True. No point in trying to
compete. So [laughter] maybe some folks
going that way. But you were talking
about Lucian earlier. There's your
Lucian Auo there as well. Pretty low on
the the total. But let's see what the
next one looks like because I imagine
it's going to get even lower here as we
get into the garens and such.
>> Um Jen for having uh already the best of
uh decided. Surprising how many there
were. But here we go. Ranata at 22.
>> Yep. My girl Lux 24 1.4% 4% of the field
>> 1.4 but a lot of them doing very well.
So it's not a popular deck by any
stretch but the ones that are attempting
for the Limitless Lux are actually
pulling it off. Um [music] some more
Auroras like the Volibear and we saw Lee
Sin earlier. Uh Master Ye Master a fun
one the XP as most people call it. Uh
[music] not the highest percentage share
there but some
>> we did have a 5 and0 at one point
[music] XP in the tournament. I'm not
sure how determined on the earlier
slide. That means that people are still
in contention for it for sure.
>> Yeah. So, people are making it work at
the end here of Unleashed.
>> Yeah. Uh, and I I imagine that's the
last slide. Oh, do we have one more?
[music]
>> JK.
>> Oh, there's 10 10 Rumbles.
>> 10 more Garens than Rumbles. More garens
than Ivvern.
>> Double the amount of Garens to Rumbles.
>> People really wanted that Garen,
>> I guess. So, Teemo, shout out Teemo with
21 and set at 20. No surprise at Colin.
really the last one truly mastering the
deck and showing the power of it. But
again, Darius, go one week back to Utre.
[music] Yeah, that made top eight a
baited oak Darius deck and there's only
20 at this tournament contention for
best of is still out there. So maybe
somebody's able to make a deep run
again, but it just shows how dark of a
horse that was last week.
>> Yeah, not not not a lot of Darius
believers
legend. It gives you an energy. It's
crazy. There's some very funky stuff you
can do with the turn one seal into a
pike into a I scored a point before you
even play out to play the game.
>> It's like a It's kind of like a red
yellow Annie if you really squint.
[laughter]
>> And I mean really squint.
>> Okay. Yeah,
>> you hear what I'm saying, right? A
legend that gives you extra energy to
play with.
>> Come on.
>> Sure.
>> I'm reaching here.
>> You're reaching. So Or is Kai'Sa is what
you're trying to tell.
>> Orin is basically Kaisa. Jyn is
basically uh both Danny and Kai.
[laughter]
>> Okay. Okay. Now, now we're getting a
little crazy. We're getting a little a
little psycho.
>> Yeah, it's been a long day.
>> Uh couple 8 O's as well. So, let's take
a look at uh who is still undefeated at
the end of day number one. Um at the top
uh something must work. Had a buy and
then one out and uh looks like they're
[music]
>> playing against Prismaticism and got the
win. So, Prismaticism is not undefeated.
Uh we do have confirmation from
production that Something Must Work did
beat Prismaticism.
>> Yeah. So Rexi, I believe, is what
Something Must Work was playing. Taking
the win over Annie. Finishing the day at
8 and0 must feel really good, especially
when your last round opponent is a
regional qualifier winner. Five-time
best of winner.
>> That's a He's going to have a good sleep
tonight.
>> That feels fantastic. [music]
Mom Sky, what a staring gaze right
there. Gets a buy in the first round,
but then wins out from there. Um, and
>> pretty diverse Swiss run as well here.
>> Very diverse. A Lilia in round six. I'd
imagine an Aurora Civer and then an
Azir. Two Azir actually on his way. Yep.
All right, let's take a look at the next
one here. And this one's going to be
[music] Evans Rim. That is four Das in a
row. We got uh yeah, four Diana actually
played against his teammate. This is Sam
D. Sherman's team if I'm not mistaken.
And playing against his teammate in
round five, unfortunately. a little bit
of you know friendly fire so to speak
but getting the win able to close out
the day at 8 to0 going through a
gauntlet of Diana
>> absolute gauntlet and I believe piloting
the master I think that whatever uh the
one is up by the buy I actually maybe
master is the default buy either way
it's uh Sami Sherman next also
undefeated
uh unless I'm seeing a defeat there on
the right this is 7 and one now 71 Sam
>> yeah we're hearing seven and one okay
[music]
uh took down a Garen oh took took down
took down the Garen.
>> The Garren best of Garen. All [music]
right, Sam Sherman just adding more and
more accolades. He took down the best of
Garen at
>> tough feat. Uh Batm Smack as well. We
saw I believe on stream uh on the Teemo
>> and Prismat losing his last one. Almost
a perfect day one. So going down to
something must work in round number
eight. It was the other option that we
could have saw on stream, right? But
unfortunately for Prismat finishing the
day at 71, but I say unfortunately like
it's a bad thing. 71 is still an
exceptional exceptional record. So he'll
be able to go into day two with his head
held high. He's still live for top
eight. And we're going to be going to
another fan favorite, right? Allan ZQ,
who actually did also lose to a uh in
round number four. So 71 Allen ZQ going
into day two as well. So two of our
defending sort of regional champions are
going into it. And then Colin
>> Okay. Yeah,
>> also just one loss
>> already the best of set in one of the
bottom 10 represented decks at the event
uh and was able to pick up a lot of wins
only losing to that Azir matchup. I feel
like that's got to be a tough one for
overall just so many units flooding the
board. So many removal uh spell options
as well [music] uh but having good
matchups into the rest or at least uh
favorable win record against the rest
everyone that day two is now what we're
going to take a look at next here. So, a
lot of names are going to be on your
screen. If you're a fan of any of these,
if you're following any of their
journeys, [music]
uh, take a screenshot, send it to them,
give them congratulations for making day
two. We've seen some of them on stream.
Actually, a lot of them on stream. Um,
[music]
and again, uh, some some heroes here,
some some new faces. That's the beauty
of events like this, uh, is that you
always have the opportunity to create a
legend for yourself. Who knows? Maybe
cream cheese becomes our next face of
the sport
>> or Carmen Hiego.
>> Carmen Hiego. I'm going to assume it's
hi. Oh, hi Diago.
>> I like that. The Diago as well. Deluxe
Phil [music] cheese. There's a lot of
cheese in the dairy references.
>> Are we in a dairy?
>> Shout out cows.
>> I would say no.
>> Okay.
>> I don't believe that Connecticut is
state. Uh, as somebody from Minnesota,
I'm just going to say no.
>> No. Okay. Uh, cool.
>> Yeah. [music] If it's anywhere east of
Michigan, that's going to be a no. Um,
>> that means nothing to me. I don't know
geography
>> under Well, you're also Canadian, so I
think that you get away with this one.
Speaking of [music] Derry Derisu Disu.
Yeah,
>> there we go. That's another one.
>> Um, some of these names I want to say
really bad, but [music] probably
[laughter] shouldn't. So,
>> we see Wowee.
>> We did have an interview with the Merc
team earlier. One of them their players
here making day two. Gatarina.
>> Yeah. How about Chud Dawnbringer?
[laughter]
Yeah.
>> Oh, I love I love card games, man.
[laughter]
Htf giggles.
I'm I don't know if I'm brave enough to
ask what HTF stands for.
>> Team name. Surely.
>> Sure. True. Yes. Definitely. Definitely.
Raging Bananas, the classic. [music]
Again,
>> I counted four Montrealers so far who
are in the
>> Wow, I like that you're recognizing them
as well. And just a reminder, any one of
these players could become the next
[music] face of the sport. Yes, that
includes Dusty Balls and [laughter]
I'm happy they made it. I saw their name
on the stream earlier and I didn't know
if they were going to make it far enough
for us to highlight. [music]
We got there.
>> We got Tiny Guy.
>> Tiny is a little guy.
>> Think he's friends [music]
below.
>> Tiny guy. Oh, I would imagine. Yeah,
>> I would imagine. He blows. He's kind of
like like a copy bar, you know, kind of
chill with everybody.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> A chill guy like we've been saying all
day.
>> Mhm. Exactly. And again, a reminder, if
you know any of these people, please
screenshot, send it to them, rewind back
to when they were on the page. If you
know X Pooky, get in their DMs right now
and say, "Hey, you were on stream or at
least your name was." And uh shout out
for making day two. I think it's awesome
we take the time to highlight each and
every person that did cuz it's a big
deal. It's a day two event. It's a long
day. It's hard to do, you know, 18
points or better with this level of
competition this far into the set in the
last, you know, unleashed regional. So,
hats off to all these players.
>> Much better than us.
>> Yep. Well, hey.
>> No.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Much better than us. And here we see
that last standings. And I'm I'm going
to say it. We got first [music] seed
Montrealer.
>> Okay.
>> Fourth seed Montreal. Linsanity who we
saw absolutely perform. Something must
work who we saw beat Prismat. This is a
stacked top 10. We got Rivia on my girl
Lux in the top 10. So
>> technically we just top eight right now.
Lux has made top eight.
>> Oh, I don't think that's how it works.
But I'm I like your enthusiasm.
>> One could you dream, you know.
>> One can dream. One can dream. Exactly.
All these duelists definitely going to
be dreamers going into tomorrow.
Hopefully getting a lot of sleep ahead
of those dreams cuz that's a long day.
We saw that last round feature match be
a grueling grind getting the time
extension still going to time
regardless. Uh I'm sure all these
players are going to want to head back
to the hotel rooms, get some sleep, get
rested for tomorrow because it's another
long day of games tomorrow.
>> And I think it's probably time for us to
do the exact same thing.
>> You tired? Should we Should we get out
of here?
>> Get out of here. Yeah.
>> All right. All right. Well, probably
close out the show first.
>> Yeah, we we should probably leave them
not hanging.
>> Thanks for watching everybody. It was
great day one of the Hartford [laughter]
regional qualifiers. We've been your
casters. Shout out as well to Charmer
and Josh for the other pair. And shout
out everybody in production who stuck
along with us and keeping all the gears
rolling. We'll be back tomorrow for more
rift action and we'll see you there.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
[music] Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]